[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I am fueling up on coffee today because
I have a feeling this this could be a
very long day and the world championship
match here Ivanka is in makeup do you
think you need an extra thick layer
today Ivanka I think so because today
Magnus has the white pieces and that
means he's gonna go hard all right
welcome today to you guys
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
game one between the reigning Champion
Magnus Carlsen and his Challenger Jana
pomyachi ended in a draw and back here
to guide us through game two of course
Grandmaster David Howell and David you
think nerves will still be a factor
today or will we see two sharp guys
ready to fight I think for sure Kaya
there will still be nerves in the air
especially on the part of Yanda
palmyachi who has his first ever game in
a world championship match with the
black pieces he's going to be on the
defensive Magnus is going to be throwing
everything at him and I think the
viewers today are in for a treat all
right well it fell like an intense game
yesterday how will you sum up the first
day yeah it was very tense I think
that's the perfect word it was a bit
cagey neither side wanting to take too
many risks but actually the level of
play the quality was extremely high both
players at some point had the advantage
but the opponents were always able to
defend and neutralize it was a great
start and
of the winner of the first game well
that's a tough one I think the Carlson
team will be happy a solid draw with
black relatively comfortable but then
again the napoleonchi team they survived
their first ever world championship game
and they'll be feeling confident trying
to take that momentum into today all
right well the two childhood Rivals they
faced off in the first game yesterday in
Dubai
on the first day of the fide World
Championship in Dubai the long-awaited
battle for the title started with
nail-biting tension Queens are off might
still have Pawn up but White's peace
development isn't great especially on
that Queen side if you look on the left
there and those pieces still fast asleep
and meanwhile Magnus especially with his
Bishops and especially now the Black
Knights in the middle of the board might
be starting to create threats and it
looks like Magnus has moved instantly
again still in his preparation after
this bishop moved this bishop moves
logical so I understand how Magnus had
predicted it in his opening preparation
Magnus moved immediately now that the
black Rook was only looking at a pawn
that was protected by White's King and
Rook he's shifted it across he's kind of
changing the pace of the game he's
creating threats and just because we're
building up to move 40.
alarm Bells would be ringing in my head
Napoleon actually lower on the clock
down to 20 minutes if napong actually
plays this move again it looks like we
might be headed towards the drawer the
position will repeat itself three times
it's the first result of the 2021 World
Championship it's a draw I'm feeling
okay
um I think I will be will be better but
at least I'm happy to start start the
match with uh with a decent results
today will be the second of a total of
14 games to the side of the world
championship match it is the first
player to reach seven and a half points
that will be crowned the world champion
and if it's tied after those 14 games
then we will have time breaks with
faster chess on December 15th and I bet
there's gonna be some fast chess maybe
even bullet chess going on down at the
good night today because we've sent
Ginger GM Simon Williams down to the the
popular uh chess Pub in Oslo and it is
Saturday Simon is it gonna be packed out
today
hello there hello everyone in the studio
and hello everyone watching I think I've
got my perfect job I'm in a pub and I'm
in the first ever chest Pub the good
night pub in Norway yes I've scored a
result is it going to be packed well
it's just opened and we can maybe have a
little look around as we come and just
see what it's like it's chessboards
everywhere it's going to be shown on the
screens we come through lots of people
are setting up in the bar we can see we
have the lovely bar area over here the
coffee machine getting ready if we go
around to this area they're going to be
doing live commentary in this bit here a
little bit empty at the moment but I
think we must space for half an hour
it'll be totally packed with people
playing chess people watching the chess
and people cheering for Magnus Carlson
I've actually spotted another grand
master over here so we can go this way
and we have Norwegian Grandmaster an old
friend of mine tourbillon hello torpion
you're live
you're live so be careful what you say
and um there you go anyway so it's going
to be great fun and like I say I found
my perfect job and good luck back at the
studio and let's see how Magnus can get
on with the white pieces today
oh that sounds like the perfect place to
be today Simon and uh maybe wait a few
hours before you start with the beers
okay
I'll be well behaved today don't worry
lots of coffees
very nice very nice it's gonna be fun to
follow Simon with all the Norwegian fans
down at the good night in the studio
we're gonna get comfortable and as
always if I go we want the viewers out
everywhere in the world to interact with
us yeah it is going to be a historic
match and we want everyone at home to be
part of this experience and so we're
asking everyone at home to share their
selfies show us where you're watching
from who you're watching with and also
send us your move suggestions your
thoughts anything to join in the fun and
you can do so by tweeting us using the
hashtag
c24 live look forward to featuring your
tweets on the show yep and I bet there's
gonna be a lot of great move suggestions
because it takes a lot of time yesterday
we had even a move that took 50 minutes
I think David So to have those creative
ideas from viewers at home would be
really nice for sure I mean there's
going to be lots of unexpected moves
here in the studio we failed predict
some of the uh some of the moves so if
the audience at home if you have some
ideas if you have any questions about
the games about the player's mentalities
about anything at all feel free to
message us and remember there will be a
very special segment later there will be
a guess the move challenge with a
special price on offer two yeah coming
up at some point David makes the call
all right well you guys he is 31 years
old and playing his very first world
championship match after he won the
candidates back in April he became very
secretive he didn't show himself too
much out in the world but we did meet
him after playing Norway chess in
September
is walking into probably his last over
the board tournament before the world
championship match
I feel like very likely because there is
not such a big choice of for the
tournaments and some of them are you
know basically not interesting enough he
played two matches against world
champion Magnus Carlsen in Norway chess
both ended in draw but Napoleon actually
lost
in Armageddon two relatively quick draws
but I guess
because games were more or less fine but
I don't think it
really matters what matters now is the
world championship but he does not want
to talk about his preparations did you
get some answers today
well uh even if I uh get him even if I
got some answers I would never tell
about it have you gathered a team well
it's
I I believe this is sort of a secret so
what's the plan now for you leading up
to the world championship match well
I'll just continue my preparation so the
point is simple and then you play the
match
[Music]
you were in New York in 2016 and some
people were saying maybe you were
working with karakin somehow but will
you be talking to him before the match
to get some advice well why not I think
if it would be useful and okay of course
I will talk to him but uh actually I
just was in New York as a guest so just
I was very very interesting you know to
basically just hang around you have to
feel the atmosphere of the mentioned of
course it's a very special chess event
here you know it's
you know you can't attend it every day
Magnus Carlsen has held the throne for
eight years how are you feeling about
the match of course I'm excited and I'm
really I'm really looking forward and
it's really challenging probably a bit
Magnus in the match
just wait for a couple of months
very secretive yeah
you did say yesterday David that we do
know he's been working with a very
strong computer system from a university
in Moscow but what do we know about his
team yeah Jan he's been trying to keep a
bit of mystery he's been trying to keep
us guessing trying to keep Magnus
guessing we do know that his main second
is Vladimir putkin he's been with him
for many years we interviewed him
yesterday we saw him in the video there
there are rumors however about some
other strong players for example Sergey
kariak and Timor rajable they've been
spotted in Dubai on social media they've
been posting pictures in Dubai who knows
which team they're working for it could
be the ponyachis either way he's got a
lot of support out there all right and
you've got his team yesterday do you
think it was like
white pieces we managed to draw with the
nerves high five afterwards or do you
think they weren't too happy
I I think that would be very pragmatic
about the whole situation because
found himself surprised in the opening
and of course he had to handle that he
was playing of Magnus Carlson's
territory and then we have the fact that
he found himself in a very difficult
position to play but he survived he
escaped he got away with it so they
would be pleased about that but some
things to kind of take lessons from is
the fact that niana pony actually could
have actually pressed at some point and
he chose to take a draw so some small
things to be thinking about there all
right he's gonna have the black pieces
today yeah the game starts in 20 minutes
we're gonna have a quick commercial
break and we'll be back in a few minutes
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the making of a new world starting
October 1st
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
a car is arriving the venue in Dubai is
a Yana ponyachi or Magnus Carlsen
arriving playing Arena 4 game two I have
heard rumor it is Jana pomniacci the
first player to arrive for game two with
his teammate Vladimir putiket see him
coming out of the car he needs to be
sharp and ready today with the black
pieces David what do you predict from
Jana pomniacci in this game well there
are two strategies that janapony
actually could adopt either he could
just meet Fire with Fire play
counter-attacking chess and really try
and put pressure on his black or he
could stay Ultra solid it's very
difficult in a world championship match
it's not necessarily his style to just
remain passive and Ultra solid but
traditionally that is what happens when
these top players meet in these big
matches so I can't wait to see the first
few moves I know and of course we do
have the world championship fantasy the
Magnus prediction challenge that you all
can join in and it's actually too late
to submit the predictions for game two
David yeah I just looked on a few
minutes ago to try and submit my
predictions and yeah I missed my shot I
missed my one opportunity and I've been
trying to change my predictions
I think it's okay so I I'm predicting
that Magnus will play with the Queen's
Pawn in the opening and then I thought
maybe uh you know Napoleon is known to
take a risk maybe he's going to play the
risky grunfell variation so I guess that
and then I started thinking about it a
little bit more and I said no I want to
change I think it's probably going to be
what we call a Catalan defense and then
I'm locked into the grundfile yeah and
we do have our very little league of our
own and you are on top David after uh
game one you predicted almost the right
amount of moves and the right opening
yeah that's right I did okay on day one
and I was just impressed by how many
people entered the prediction Challenge
online uh at that liquid that we just
saw I thought I did pretty well but I
was only in 131st Place 130 players 130
predictors managed to get there before
me oh impressive yeah impressive stuff
all right you guys we're now going to
show you some very exclusive footage
from a training camp that Magnus Carlsen
with his team went on in Spain about a
month ago and his main second Peter
Heinen Nelson also revealed a little bit
of their plan against janapomniacci
is it already sort of the start of not
showing your ideas not playing your best
openings and stuff like that well I will
say at this
point I don't know what my ideas are yet
so I'll just read it as a normal game
[Music]
in very short our job is to create an
opening database for MacBooks to use in
the world championship match
the head of the team is Magnus Magnus
gives us some directions where we want
to to go and we try to fulfill these
kind of issues
well here you're up against someone
who's probably also spent half a year
together with a team we have so much
time that we have to create this big
puzzle of of options and such our
assumption is just that Magnus is the
best player in the world and such and
I mean it's not our job to win games I
mean well if we are the underdog we
might try such but we think Magnus is
the best player in the world I think
even by quite some margin right so it's
probably more have to neutralize and
make sure he gets some territory where
he can show he's the best player
our role is to make sure Magnus gets
gets the ability to show he's the best
player in the world so it's well we
shouldn't make mistakes we shouldn't get
him into the kind of trouble but sort of
to have brilliant preparation for him to
win is not sort of we don't see it as a
necessity
these are some very exclusive uh footage
from Spain about a month ago looks warm
and nice yeah yeah it's really
interesting to have this kind of insight
into what the top players do and rare as
well very rare I don't think we've ever
seen it before that type of access to
exclusive access and was also
fascinating to hear his main coach
Carlson's main coach's opinions it's not
necessarily about winning the game
straight from the opening it's not even
about finding the best moves it's just
getting Magnus out of the opening
surviving and letting him show it's the
best uh he's the best player and we saw
that yesterday he survived the opening
comfortably and he did manage to
outmaneuver Napoleon actually for a
while and uh I think the team will be
very happy with how the matches started
and today is going to be a big test for
them as well and is it for the team is
their main job the white games or do
they also have very important job when
it comes to the black games I mean the
devils and the details it has to be with
both colors the focus has to be again
also in situations where Magnus perhaps
has to play for a draw and has to play
for a win every single thing has to be
be accounted for because it's a match of
14 games you can't just focus on the one
opening so I think they will be in their
laboratory preparing all those opening
surprises with the white and black
pieces
for sure they've got a plan A A Plan B
plan C Plan D every in any scenario has
been accounted for now so with the white
pieces today then for Magnus Carlsen is
there any way we can predict what he's
going to bring well uh I think he might
have a few ideas in store it just
depends on what his strategy is probably
he's prepared two or three different
openings and today he's just needs to
decide whether he wants to go all out
whether he wants to maybe surprise him
upon me actually there's so many
different routes you can take and either
way I think he's going to be more direct
than we used to see from the world
champion all right and the person
closest to the players in Dubai is Tanya
she got some interviews with them
yesterday and today Tanya game two
magnets with the white pieces what are
you predicting down in Dubai
I'm predicting another intense fight
Kaya it is day two here in Dubai I am
outside the playing Hall the auditorium
it's on my right we see the giant border
set up there's a live commentary going
on here with former world champion
vishwanathan as well as Grandmaster Anna
music The Buzz is on here and as you
mentioned it's all about what we're
gonna see in the first moves of game two
now game one has some fascinating
opening by Magnus Jan was up for the
challenge the Challenger showed extreme
confidence uh in his presence in his
moves and up for a big fight it was not
just about playing the position it was
as much about playing the player in game
one the big question today what does
Magnus start with in his first game with
the white pieces and for all the Panda 3
I've got with me Grandmaster Jonathan
thistle the official reporter from free
day thanks for joining us thank you
Tanya
um you want a prediction I don't like to
be too specific but I think it'll be
something quiet it'll be I think it'll
be a sort of a white variation of the
kind of position that's happened
yesterday where Magnus can play for a
very long time position in his own style
I think one thing I'm absolutely sure is
that he wants to strike early in this
match
but big risks
don't think it fits in so I predict
a deceptively quiet opening but a very
long hard fight a long hard fight is
exactly where what is magnus's forte
Jonathan what do you think is he going
to start with one E4 today or 1d4
I think one D or c
I don't think he
Magnus has
well
okay I won't rule anything out I think
it's more of a question of style I think
Magnus in the past has gotten a little
over ambitious sometimes with white
against uh Jan and you don't want to
really provoke a big crisis early I
think
very interesting and Jonathan finally
tell us we had game one yesterday Jan
with the white pieces Magnus with the
black pieces what was your takeaway
about the opening approach that we saw
from both these players
I don't know if your experts and
machines have worked everything out yet
my impression was that Magnus was very
slightly surprised first
um
but I'm not really surprised he was
maybe it just had to think a little bit
harder to remember his his prep I mean
they were both obviously extremely well
prepared
I thought
it was slightly odd that Jan played a
line where he grabbed something and
would defended and Magnus decided to
sacrifice something and press and I
think that will that reflects I think
that they're both a lot more versatile
than people like to think it's not the
stereotyped kind of clash of styles they
can both do what the other likes a lot
more than people think
fascinating that is the prediction from
Grandma so Jonathan to silly the 1d4 or
1c4 I'll be bringing you guys all the
on-ground action we're gonna have
liftoff really soon over the board
action starts now let's go back to the
studio thank you so much Tonya so many
interesting people have made their way
to Dubai to follow the match and here's
another one who's in Dubai Magnus
Crossing today ooh and a very nice
light kind of beige suit you're almost
matching David yeah actually I noticed
Magnus Carlson yesterday he wore black
shirts with the black pieces today he's
all in light because he's got the white
pieces so you're his lucky advisor David
wears black socks when he's playing
black white socks I wore my black shirt
today though what does that say
Magnus he's not normally superstitious
but this time maybe following a bit of a
routine so far yeah you always say it's
all about the details the devil's in the
details you usually say like is it also
some superstitious involved in this it
could be you know chess players on a
touristly superstitious especially when
we've done something and we've been
lucky and we've won we'd like to keep
that Trend going and chess players is
all about pattern recognition and if you
can apply that in life by following
superstitions let's say then of course
every little bit helps yeah minus goes
in a white shirt ready for his first
White game in this world championship
match and we did see some interviews
with him yesterday both Tanya and also
press conference he did seem to be in a
quite good mood right yeah I think the
main thing for Magnus he said he said it
himself on many occasions he needs to
feel relaxed in order to play his best
and he looked relaxed yesterday he made
a couple of jokes in the press
conference which is always a nice touch
it's entertaining for us but uh overall
I think he's just enjoying the moment
and uh of course it's going to get even
more tense it's going to get even more
stressful as the games tick on as the
games go by but right now I think with
white this is the perfect mood to be in
uh for the world champion all right it's
kicking off in about six minutes game
two in the world championship match
we're gonna head back down to Junior DM
Simon Williams at the good night pub and
also we've seen
um Magnus now Simon arrived with a white
shirt and a pale suit and I bet there's
going to be a bunch of Magnus fans down
at the good night
yeah I think 99 of people down here are
going to be rooting for Magnus obviously
the pub is in Oslo and we just met
someone who's come all the way from
Poland to watch the world championships
in this Pub so I think that is pretty
cool
um I'm starting with a coffee just so
you know that I'm behaving well coffee I
promise not vodka and um you can see
it's a lovely layout if we just pan
around yeah
it's still a bit like um empty here at
the moment but people are coming in
slowly and you can see they're at the
bar now it's filling up a little bit
we've got broadcasts on the TV lots of
things going on and uh it's gonna be
packed I promise you in probably about
30 minutes time and like we say lots of
Magnus supporters there I don't know
what it's like in Russia but it can't be
as good as this surely so um yeah um
it's going to be interesting to see what
happens
well enjoy yourself Simonson we will be
back with you quite uh soon when the
game kicks off and uh this Pub David
after moving to Oslo you enjoyed it
yourself it is a super nice place yeah
that's pretty much my favorite place
these days they all know my name is yeah
I enjoyed being there it's just nice to
kind of just sit hang out with friends
but also have a chessboard with you and
uh yeah the atmosphere is fantastic and
I'm sure we'll see that later on today
definitely and on social media yesterday
Ivanka did we see mostly Magnus fans or
did we also get some uh Goya napoleonchi
we certainly had a lot of Nepal niachi
fans but we also I must say had the
majority being Magnus Carlson fans a lot
of people cheering for Magnus and uh
yeah definitely everyone feeling the
tension of yesterday's game in fact and
again once again I see that many of our
of our twitteries or Twitter whatever
you say um they're absolutely uh can't
wait for the game to begin a lot of
excitement and everyone is just on edge
you know everyone wants to know what
kind of approaches the players have
taken whether Jana pomachi will go all
in Meet fire with fire or will he try to
shut the game down oh it's exciting I
know I know the first move of today it's
always tense and exciting it is coming
in four minutes and if you are Rihanna
pomniacci fan out there then do send him
some good energy on social media using
using the hashtag c24 live and uh it was
it lasted I think almost exactly four
hours yesterday the game David should we
also remind everyone about the time
control for the match yep as we saw
yesterday the time control
um the time usage is essential in these
big matches and for the first 40 moves
both players have two hours on the clock
120 minutes once they reach move 40
they're both given an extra hour an
extra 60 minutes and that carries them
through to move 60 to last the next 20
moves once they've reached move 60 they
get 15 minutes to complete the game plus
30 seconds after every move so it's a
long time control it can easily stretch
to seven hours and Beyond but the
players they have to be aware of the
clock if they get low on time we will
see some big blunders all right and the
game is kicking off in three minutes we
are waiting for uh the footage from
Dubai to show the venue and the player
is coming to the board yesterday Magnus
arrived quite late Jana pomyachi was
sitting ready for quite some time before
Magnus arrived on this seems to be a
strategy that Magnus usually wants to
use he wants to be the latest to arrive
for some reason it's not this time oh
wow no he's there bright and early I I
do remember that I have to quote my
father my father always liked being late
because he liked kind of coming into the
playing Hall and making your opponent
stand up to shake hands
and uh that's what we're seeing yeah
there we're seeing uh Magnus is the one
brighter early to the wood all right
they're ready both of the players minus
Crossing with the white pieces the
reigning Champion the Challenger Jana
pomniaki with the black pieces final
predictions you guys will it be a draw
today or will we see a winner and who
will that be ladies first Ivanka well I
think I I should stick to my prediction
that I predicted this morning on the
Magnus nepo Challenge and I said I think
Magnus will win wow I'll say draw just
to be different yeah meanwhile we do see
the ceremonial first move about to be
made by the fide president of khadid
valkovich and which porn is he pushing
will we see Magnus retract that pawn and
push a different one looks like a King's
Pawn that that's E4 one E4 will Magnus
stick to that move you don't have to
follow the move but the uh kind of
ceremonial make uh move maker he takes
it back out
I think that is a sign because he then
adjusted the Queen's Pawn okay and it
was quite a confident adjustment so
Moment of Truth which Pawn has he pushed
it does look like D4 Queen's born
Queen's born okay so so far I'm okay
with my prediction okay the night has
come out okay this is what Napoleon
actually does nearly 100 of the time
against 1d4 against the Queen's Pawn
Magnus that taking more control of the
center with pawns will we see okay it's
not a gruntuality of anchor I think your
prediction wasn't quite right there
unfortunately
um it looks like he's pushed his e-pawn
so will we see a nimzo Indian defense
will we see a transposition to the
Queen's Gambit oh and now this is the
thing I okay for eign
quite recently in Croatia
and uh yeah this is the main line of
what we call the Catalan opening and the
Catalan opening
um it's kind of shown once white
develops his Bishop to this Square
White's light squared Bishop just
sliding across to the longest possible
diagonal this is still Mainline Theory
we'll explain some of the ideas uh
behind both sides openings a bit later
on meanwhile black is the first to
Castle and White follows suit so both
Kings super safe we won't see any direct
attacks in this game most likely we
won't see any quick checkmates uh
definitely Magnus Carlson he's going for
the longer grinding type of approach so
black has grabbed a pawn but that pawn
won't survive for too long White's queen
move there is a that Queen is about to
recapture the pawn that white has
sacrificed and I've had this position
countless times in my career both of
these players have as well and okay
slight surprise here janapong actually
pushing a pawn to defend uh his extra
pawn and uh this one is less common I
think there are two or three
Alternatives that maybe have a better
reputation than this last move so I'm
actually trying to surprise Carlson
there
if napongi actually played this against
me I would have been very surprised so I
wonder how Magnus feels right now
so do you think Magnus and I will take
the first little bit of pause in the
game yes
um I think there's one main move in this
position that's simply to push white a
pawn so the pawn on the left out in
front of the Rook just push it two
squares forward to try and undermine
Black's Pawn structure on that Queen
side
and I would be surprised if Magnus
didn't play that move but after this
kind of small semi-surprise he'll just
sit back for a while as we see you just
take a sip of water calm himself down
this is just good kind of uh game
routine for anyone watching just if your
opponents play something a bit strange
or something you haven't seen before or
something you haven't studied for a
while and just take a breath you've got
two hours on the clock you need to
invest invest that time wisely yeah
definitely and I do have to say that
Magnus Carlson does have experience with
this line with the black pieces because
he actually played against dingler in in
Croatia 2019 and if my memory serves me
correctly he won that game it was a very
complex game and uh well yep somebody
actually recently used that idea that
Magnus did in that game against Ding and
then he used it against me and it's very
scary actually for white so uh Napoleon
actually it's very interesting the
strategy using magnus's medicine against
him and and uh using his own ideas
against him potentially and the reason I
should mention that Black's last move
this Pawn push is highlighted in Orange
on the board there uh the reason it's so
surprising is because now White's Bishop
if you look at the white light squared
Bishop in front of the king its diagonal
has opened up and Magnus there deep in
thought
he knows what to do here for sure he
knows there are maybe two or three
options for white but now he's choosing
between them if he has two or three
options he's going to be trying to pick
the option that he thinks Napoleon she
hasn't studied or maybe won't be uh too
comfortable with Napoleon actually for
sure has some tricks up his sleeve and
it's up to Magnus the reigning Champion
to deal with those tricks and uh okay
head in his hands we saw this posture
from him yesterday what will he do maybe
just while Magnus thinks I can explain a
couple of the options here that he is
mulling over so Black's last move was to
push this Pawn forward and the reason
this was done is to Simply protect this
extra Pawn black is actually a pawn up
right now the reason this is not maybe
the most popular move is because
suddenly the white Bishop has a clear
eye line towards this rook in the corner
so for example if at some point the
White Knight does jump forward maybe not
now but over the next couple of moves
then suddenly this Rook is hit in the
corner
the most popular move however is not
this night jump because black has a
couple of options black can actually
give up that rook in the corner and take
a pawn black and just use his Knight for
example to block this Bishop's diagonal
so the most popular move is to challenge
Black's Pawn structure and to try and
open up the white Rook try and open up a
line for it and also undermine these two
guys this most commonly leads to Black
pushing forward again and just giving
this Pawn back but saying to White if
you take it you'll lose a lot of time
with your queen suddenly the black
pieces pour out and uh suddenly there
might be some trouble for white along
this diagonal so I'm expecting this Pawn
push from White for sure I'm expecting
the pony actually to push forward
himself and uh then maybe a night jump
one of these two white Knights okay I
was gonna say one of the night
would jump to the square and recapture a
pawn instead Magnus went with the other
move I suggested he jumped with his
Knight into the center first yeah
it's the third choice actually
um in this particular position and uh
it's primarily a third choice because
black can get uh quite daring and
actually capture the pawn in the middle
of the board with the queen just kind of
forgetting about The Rook yeah so giving
up the rook in the corner black can take
this Pawn with the queen and once this
Rook disappears from the board Black's
Queen drops back to capture the White
Knight and actually this is quite likely
to happen now and if we do a quick
material count white has won a rook but
in return black has a knight and two
pawns and together the Knight and two
pawns are pretty much the same as a rook
uh meanwhile White's Bishop would be
stuck in the corner so that transition
is not clear who it favors I'm a bit
surprised by magnus's decision but
either way it's uh it's definitely
heating up the could well be some
sacrifices now and once Napoleon
actually gets back to the board I expect
him to see well I expected to play a few
very very quick moves just to assert his
authority and trying to show Magnus that
he's well prepared and what opening did
you say we had today it's the Catalan
Catalan and every day chasable makes a
free course available on the opening and
the game and today's course has been
made available it is of course a course
on the Catalan it is free and available
on the link that you see in the bottom
of the screen so if you want to dig
deeper into the opening that these two
players are now playing then head into
chessable and do that yeah I definitely
recommend that for anyone who maybe
thinks that they are strategic player
maybe a positional player because the
Catalan opening despite the fact it does
sometimes lead to Wild positions like
this it's mostly for those strategic
players who like long games who like end
games and who like to just grind away so
if you think at home that you're a
strategic player go check out that
course it is really good actually I take
myself and I would also recommend it to
those players who love play playing with
Bishops especially the light squared
Bishop if you like just putting pressure
on your opponent making them feel a
little bit uncomfortable and asking
questions then this is the opening for
you because the whole opening just
hinges on one thing really and you look
at White's light Square Bishop it's on
the perfect long diagonal take a look at
its counterpart sitting there on the CH
Square not so good and if black were to
develop that light Square Bishop then
hey life is very jolly but if not then
there's going to be a very very
uncomfortable and I've fallen foul of
this many times when I played on the
black side against the Catalan yeah it's
definitely one of the most annoying
opponent openings to play against from
the black side and uh yeah that white
Bishop you mentioned Ivanka it's a bit
like a sniper it's just from afar it's
just eyeing up so many different targets
and controlling so many different
squares and uh yeah like Ivanka as black
I struggled many many times this opening
and it took me many years to actually
find an antidote that I was happy with
or relatively happy with even these days
with white I mean Vladimir kramnik as
well former world champion he was the
one who uh taught modern players that
the Catalan in any situation is I mean
extremely dangerous weapon it is an
extremely dangerous weapon and certainly
everyone at home also thinks that but we
also have a lot of people cheering for
Napa and are also saying that nepo is
the one who has won the battle we have
Johan Miranda Who Says nepo by playing
the move B5 which is the pawn protecting
the other pornity for is just a deadly
dare with the Catalan Bishop staring
down the queen side nepo won the prep on
this one he knew there's a good chance
Magnus will go for the Catalan
positional setups rather than the risky
and he refers to an opening nimzo so uh
yeah so Miranda's saying that yes
is the one who is feeling comfortable
hair yeah interesting point of view that
actually I'm half inclined to agree with
Johann there but at the same time I do
think that the opening battle is yet to
be decided I think the next five or six
moves might well dictate who will be the
happier of the two I did also say that
Napoleon actually would play a few quick
moves I'm surprised he hasn't but then
again magnus's last move this knight
jump into the center is not the most
popular reply so uh just nepo there not
looking at the board even just looking
off into the distance he was just trying
to remember a few things for sure he
studied this position and once we do see
the next four or five maybe even six
moves then we will know who has won the
opening battle Yeah I mean so the big
question here is actually will black
grab the pawn do you think with the
queen and just forget about the Rook or
we'll kind of try and play it a little
bit safer and just intercept that that
attack on against the rook and just uh
move the Knight to the center block the
diagonal oh which one would you do if I
had studied this position before and
gone into a bit of detail I think I
would grab that pawn in the center with
the black queen but then again Magnus
didn't spend too long on the last move
uh maybe if nepo hasn't studied this
position in the last couple of weeks
maybe he'll be a bit vague a bit foggy
on the details and then the safer move
for black is to plant the knight in the
middle to use Black's Knight there and
put it on the D5 Square to block white
so should we do a deep dive as to why
black can potentially capture that pawn
with the queen okay so while nepo takes
a sip of tea we do see Queen takes porn
being maybe the most critical move right
now and it's the movie for sure
calculating or trying to work out
White's only way to justify the two Pawn
deficit now the two-point sacrifice is
to go and capture this black rook in the
corner White's Bishop might get trapped
here though uh once black takes this
Knight it's level material as we
mentioned earlier black has a knight and
two pawns for White's Rook but White's
Rooks aren't that great and white
normally has to spend a move here at
some point retreating this bishop
example retreating it back and you can
play a couple of different moves first
but later on if the position stabilizes
it's not clear whether these Rooks are
better than the minor pieces blacks
Knights often post themselves up in the
center of the board this one lands in
the middle the other Knight might try
and jump into the middle as well and yes
a rook is worth more than a night but in
this exact position it's not entirely
clear so yeah totally I agree with you
there David very not clear and also take
a look at those pawns that black has
especially on the left side of the board
and you can imagine those Rooks really
need open lines to get mobilized and
that's not really possible there's only
one open line on the board and it's
blocked up by a very powerful knight in
the Santa so this is Black's kind of
compensation yeah black has great
activity in compensation for that for
giving up that Rook material competition
as well but if Nepali actually I mean
this is critical this is what he maybe
should go for if he's well prepared but
no problem actually if he's not certain
if he's not sure then I expect to see
this move the Knight blocking on the D5
Square very nice Central Square and this
bishop now is a bit frustrated it wants
to crash through it wants to break
through towards that Rook but it's not
easy to do that for example you can gain
time against this Knight in the center
this looks natural but then again once
the Knight moves even if it retreats
then suddenly this bishop is not happy
is staring only at its own Pawn so okay
critical moment here will Napoleon
actually play the solid Knight to D5 or
will he get greedy and capture this Pawn
in the center and ask Magnus to prove
that he's well prepared what do you
think David
um
so let's assume that an apartment
actually knows his stuff
then if he knows his stuff and if he's
100 confident and
I don't know uh you're in the same
situation you know your stuff but you
know maybe this is not the thing you
focused on
do you do do you go for it I mean I
wouldn't have the courage person but
Napoleon actually it's a far braver
player than me what do you think your
Banker is he going to take this Pawn or
is he going to plant his night he's
known to be a risk taker and he knows
he's known to to love Dynamic play so I
I think he's he's battling his instincts
his instincts tells tell him you know
snap off that pool with a queen exactly
and then just uh trust he's got to trust
his opening preparation he's got to
trust his memory and uh but the fact
that he's hesitant makes me think that
he might actually
not grab the pawn and just block the
attack with the Knight yeah I mean this
position he can play by Instinct he can
bring his Rook to the center he can play
on his Knight in the middle lots of
natural moves but I think it's all about
the psychology right now Magnus uh well
I think Napoleon actually when he played
this B5 Pawn push earlier when he pushed
this Pawn forward I think he was hoping
Magnus would sink into the tank and
think for 20 30 minutes instead Magnus
played after two minutes and suddenly
Napoleon actually he's the one who's
maybe just psychologically uncertain if
he does take this Pawn he's worrying
that he's running into some computer
preparation for Magnus it's not clear
who's going to be bluffing there who's
going to be better prepared oh this is a
critical it's only move eight and this
is already a critical moment and upon
actually spending nearly 10 minutes on
this one move oh and was he going for
something okay he's pushed a pawn
forward I think this was the third
option I was about to suggest but uh
he's actually blocking this Bishop's
diagonal but he's giving back the pawn
that he grabbed earlier so if white
wants to take this Pawn then he can and
we would see a trade now white Bishop
would attack this rook in the corner and
this Rook would just slide across and
move to safety so this is maybe a solid
option he's not gone for the most
aggressive ambitious Choice there
Napoleon a bar does shift sides yeah and
I also have to say it's not the most
popular move
yep um it's definitely not the most
popular because I guess players who go
into this variation they want to be
direct they want to grab stuff with
their Queen and uh it's maybe not human
instinct to play an aggressive line an
ambitious line and then suddenly play a
solid move later on so
um yep slightly surprising but Napoleon
actually maybe just not willing to enter
into those Muddy Waters yet
and uh he's just gonna say to Magnus you
didn't play the most popular move now I
didn't play the most popular move she
was not going to confuse more
yes but now I I I don't know I'm a
little bit concerned actually for black
because it tends to be in the Catalan
type of positions that if you don't play
the most popular moves you end up with a
very bad light squared bishop and you
just have to suffer
suffer trying to get that Bishop out
trying to deal with your lack of space
and and now I'm going to say that Magnus
has won that opening battle
um I still think it's too early I don't
know okay
um because if black is able to get the
piece out especially that light Square
Bishop you mentioned the black light
Square Bishop that's a home asleep then
maybe you can just argue he's pulling up
yeah but if white does grab the pawn
back in the meanwhile there will be
trades and it would free up the black
position
yeah I do think the next few moves are
still critical yes um and it depends
maybe Magnus will play some quick moves
and completely refute black system and
say okay white has a big Advantage but
if he doesn't find some energy here in
his position then it could just fizzle
out I don't know yeah I completely agree
with you uh the next few moves are going
to be vital and we're going to find out
whether black is doing okay or like oh
like kind of I'm thinking that white is
doing more than okay and uh whilst we're
waiting for Magnus to think about
whether he should capture that pawn
that's just been offered
um we have a question from Rahul on
Twitter who says
why does Magnus and Yan be so secretive
about revealing their team they kind of
dodged those questions about their team
in the press conference yeah it was kind
of fun in the press conference yesterday
I came up with some very sharp answers
there so uh it's like Cloak and Dagger
it's all it's like a spy movie or
something everyone's trying to find out
secret identities it's like the masked
chess player like nobody knows exactly
who's behind that mask but
um I guess the answer to rahul's
question is simply that it's all about
information if you know who is helping
Magnus for example if you're a Napoleon
actually you can look at the helpers
games you can look at the coaches games
and you can see what openings they
specialize in for example uh we know
that Peter heiner Nielsen helps Magnus
for sure yeah napoleonici and his team
they've studied Peter Heine and
Nielsen's games his openings his
preferences and if you know the whole
team then you know pretty much all the
information there is so for example if
they knew that Maxim was in the helpers
team because maximum plays the same
opening everything at the time he is the
expert it yeah then they would sort of
know what to prepare against and also
stylistically what kind of approach he's
going to take so you gauge a lot of
information by looking at who's helping
that person and like I do know a story a
long long time ago where a wife was
married to a very top Grandmaster and
one time she peaked at his opening files
and she played it and she won a nice
game and the grandma said why did you do
that for
everyone knows you know that you're
married to me and they will be looking
at your games as well as mine and she
goes oh sorry
but she did it wouldn't be a very nice
game I've done that myself for Ivanka
actually one game in the Isle of Man I
was playing against a very strong woman
player and I studied her husband's games
and I won straight out to the opening so
uh yeah it's all about information these
days and you have to be a bit sneaky you
have to be maybe make some deductions
you have to pretend you're Sherlock
Holmes but it can work out sometimes
yeah yeah great with those questions on
social media I also saw Lawrence with
the comment there that he's in Saint
Andrews and I love golf and I know
there's a great golf course there and we
have a move yeah we have a move and
Magnus has pushed his Pawn he's putting
some pressure now on Black's Pawn chain
on that Queen side on that Left Flank
and now there's maximum tension he's
actually trying to capture a pawn with
his last Pawn push he's again trying to
wrench open this diagonal for that white
light squared bishop and uh no problem
actually has to deal with this threat
there is a pawn hanging in the middle of
the board Black's Queen can still go and
grab that Central Pawn uh if and upon
that she's feeling greedy actually maybe
we should check this out because it is
critical right now if black does take
this Pawn but I think there will be
consequences and Napoleon actually has
to be very very careful if he wants to
be greedy we're yet to seen upon
actually back at the board Magnus deep
in thought despite it being his
opponent's move and if Napoleon actually
comes back and snaps this Pawn off then
I think there are options for white but
for example you could take this Pawn now
you've delayed it one move and after a
trade here we see Black's Brook attacked
in the corner and this Pawn attacked as
well so if that moves the Rook for
example then we might see white just
play don't take spawn and suddenly this
Rook has come to life it will actually
cause some serious damage later on the
bishop will also gain some time against
the black queen black has lost a lot of
time in this whole transition and hasn't
gained anything in the process it's
level pawns level material and white has
a big Advantage so actually taking this
Pawn is double edged I'm not sure I
would recommend it right now for
janapomniatchi but that does beg the
question what else remember there is a
threat so if black just plays kind of uh
in a relevant move on the wrong side of
the board if he pushes a pawn for
example then we would say see a capture
and now the white Bishop opened up again
against this Rook the move I'm
predicting uh the move I think is the
safest at least now is to just plant the
night in the middle of the wood we
suggested it on the last turn and I
think it's imperative now he has to play
this yeah Napoleon actually if he wants
to keep the balance just to block this
Bishop's prowess to block its diagonal
all right
and I was just going to confirm here
that is actually the main move in the
position
actually I think I've studied this exact
position but through a different move
order so playing a few different moves
earlier but it's transposed back into a
position that is uh relatively known
that is familiar all right well none of
the players are at the board right now
Jana ponjaji is in the mood but he is uh
in the resting area right now so let's
head back down to the good night where
Ginger DM Simon Williams is having a
good time today I suppose
okay
it's not going bad down here to the
studio and it looks like a very exciting
start to the game
um with this uh well Pawn sacrifice in
the opening and yeah we're in the good
night we're in the first ever chess Pub
and we're just gonna have a very quick
word now with one of the owners the
creators the OG of the good night so uh
hello Christopher how are you doing are
you okay yeah I'm fine thank you for
asking good and um so you've started
this Pub the first ever chess Pub in the
world and um everyone plays chess down
here and it runs nicely you excited
about the world championships
definitely it's always fun to have
something on the big screens and be kind
of like a football club instead of just
the chess Pub so it's really nice to
have that feeling of people cheering
when the bar changes the evaluation and
stuff that's impossible I bet loads of
people are jealous of you and everyone
else is down here I mean not just able
to watch the chest but to have a beer
and to play Chess at the same time yeah
and it looks it looks like you have a
good selection of beers here yeah so
this is the place to be of course if you
want to listen to a Grandmaster or if
you want to analyze the game yourself or
just have a friendly piece of Chess
while uh watching the game on the Telly
brilliant so um thank you Christopher
maybe we'll come back to you later
um so the good night chess Pub in ausley
so you if you are in Norway please come
down watch the chest Magnus seems to be
doing very interesting things there what
do you reckon about the position back in
the studio there Kaya well I'm not going
to say too much about it Simon but I bet
David has something to say yeah I just
think it's heating up we have all the
pieces on the board as Simon mentioned
is a pawn sacrifice and it's a bit like
yesterday Magnus was pulling down for
most of the game today he's a pawn down
again yeah so he's showing a bit of uh
yeah a bit of a stylistic quirk there
Simon I know that you love sacrificing
pawns playing for the initiative playing
for the attack you must think his uh
compensation is promising here
oh yeah I'm very interested in the
position because uh the Catalan is a
very sharp opening and it's not
something that Magnus plays all the time
so I think he's certainly going for the
win but what I'm also impressed with to
be fair is Yan's response Yan hasn't
really backed away he took that pawn
there was many more safer options he
could do so he's clearly not scared of
Magnus so this is going to be a very
fascinating game and it's gonna get
exciting over the next 10 moves or so
all right Simon uh we hope you're
enjoying yourself and that some more
people will uh come in to play some
chess maybe you can play some chess
later on today as well
yeah I think I'll I'll certainly give it
a go you know um maybe when the middle
game's over I might even get a cheeky
beer we'll see how things go and play a
little bit of Blitz and uh well maybe
the viewers can watch me lose a very
quick game later on or maybe well win a
quick game we'll see so I'm holding you
as the favorite in that one thank you so
much everyone we'll uh we'll uh come
back to you later on in the game
yeah
okay cheers guys later
all right that seems like the perfect
place for Simon to be just in a chest
Pub it's in his element yeah yeah you
know surrounded by good atmosphere Good
Vibes and uh talking about Good Vibes
there's nothing but good vibes for the
players on social media everyone is
cheering for Magnus or nepo and this
positivity and uh I do quite like
looking at some of the Selfies and I I
really like David keary who's watching
from Northern Ireland and we have a
really cool viewer there and uh
it's a dog
and we'll see we'll see him we'll see it
soon and I also quite like uh yeah there
he is Peter S who says I wanted it yes I
certainly wanted it and he's showing
himself watching us on the show and if
you two want to send us your selfie who
you're watching the show with where
you're watching the show from then you
can do so by tweeting us using the
hashtag c24 live and we will feature
them on the show and I also have to show
you one more it's quite cool it's by
yogesh back bakshi and it's a picture of
Jan pomniacci and uh that he's thinking
and he says when I see that annoying
cousin in a family gathering and already
thinking how to avoid him get out of
here
Magnus and the piano are definitely
giving us all the facial expressions
that's the beauty of Chess you know you
can watch chess players concentrating up
close and personal and you can see their
game face and you know they're all the
emotions I mean that's one of the things
about Magnus and Yan they're very
expressive players yeah definitely and
the holiday is coming up so I guess we
all can relate to that and there Jana
pomijachi his clock has been running for
almost eight minutes he's been away from
the board now he's back where has he
been yeah I was gonna say meanwhile
there's a big mystery going on because
sometimes you say you see players leave
the board sometimes they go to the
bathroom they get some refreshments but
normally as soon as their opponent makes
a move you see them return within a
minute or two because they will have
screens right they will have screens
back there they will know when it's
their move and eight minutes is a long
time to sacrifice uh away from the board
and now we'll see more of those facial
reactions that we were talking about
from Jana ponyachi maybe there'll be
some surprise Maybe try and get back in
the zone
by pondering for a couple of minutes we
mentioned that Black's night hopping
into the center of the board it's pretty
much forced right now I think there's a
90 chance we'll see that move but
hopefully Jan is feeling okay hopefully
he's still feeling focused and not
Disturbed or anything it's still very
strange to see a player leave for that
long from the board and is it a tough
decision for Jana ponyachi now the move
he's gonna make personally I don't think
it's that tough I think black's Knight
jumping to the D5 square jumping into
the center of the board
yeah I mean I just don't see any of your
other option simply
um I think you will play that move but
it might just take him a while to kind
of re- reassess and just scrutinize the
position a little bit either way I think
we'll see that move and hopefully yeah
nothing has affected Yan all right well
we did see in the opening move today it
was the fide precedent dark I did
workward she made the first move for
Magnus and earlier today Tanya also uh
did get an interview with the Veda
president
we're at the Exhibition Center this is
the playing Hall of the fide world
championship match and with me is the
very Dynamic president Mr akari
dwarkowicz thank you for joining us
thank you thank you you're welcome to
our world championship it's absolutely
incredible to be here and you must be
very pleased to have this at such an
iconic venue yes we are we thought about
collaborating with Dubai exp long time
ago and we are happy that it actually
happened and despite the pandemic
despite all the shifts in terms of
timing we are here Expo is a big partner
and I think the match has started very
successfully absolutely Mr dwarkowitz
it's tremendous success to host the
match at this venue the hype around this
Clash the interest around this is so
massive it's a historic moment for chess
it is Magnus carlsen's world champion
holds his title for already a few years
he defended his title title on a number
of occasions now it's a Russian changer
who's it's time to get the crown back
back to Russia so it is historic and our
idea to join forces with global expo
here in Dubai I think creates a momentum
the chess is not just chess but also a
part of global Society global vision and
Global progress
absolutely it is a city of gold and what
can be
more the two player players have great
Ambitions Magnus wants to defend his
title Jan wants to get it and I think
their idea of becoming the becoming
champion and holding this for as long as
possible drives people crazy they want
to watch it they want to watch their
emotions how they feel about it how they
make moves how they're nervous about
each particular second so it's a really
great occasion all right Mr dwalkovich
there have been some key changes in the
format of the match we've got two more
classical games and we've got less
number of rest days what pushed fide for
these decisions well Rog was to create
even a bigger pressure on players so
that they can start making some mistakes
and not just having 12 draws in a row
like in London between Magnus and
Fabiano Carolina last time but actually
starting winning and losing the games
that was the main idea absolutely big
fight entertaining chess now of course
you have immense responsibilities as the
president but also everything you do
seems to be driven from your passion for
the game and as a lover of chess what do
you have to say about this epic Clash
between Magnus and Yan well I think most
players are role models for millions of
Chess lovers around the world so what
they're doing here is of the official
World Championship they're fighting for
the crown but the heroes for millions of
players young and older who want to
achieve something conscious or just
enjoy chairs and our social activities
that we do now with support of all kinds
of Partners but driving by feeder is I
think the best possible thing we can do
for the world thank you so much Mr
dwarkiewicz there we have and it's great
to see chess going under his leadership
Mr Gotti dwarkowicz back to you guys in
the studio
thank you so much Tanya and uh all right
we have had two moves on the board I
almost fell off my chair because the bar
shut up it's uh you know gone down a
little bit but it's definitely side now
yeah I'm surprised actually to see that
evaluation bar just above me there kind
of scoot over to the black side so
drastically and uh we did see a couple
of moves let's show this in this
position I did expect Black's Knight to
park itself in the middle of the board
we uh explained this idea earlier this
is simply to block the power of the
white Bishop that was sensible it did
cost the anapon actually more than 10
minutes if we include his break away
from the board but it was pretty much a
forced move I think any other move would
have given white a decisive Advantage so
great move there from napoleonchi maybe
he won't be happy with how much time it
cost him though and Magnus reacted
immediately maybe thinking in Napoleon's
time and bringing his Knight out and
this is the type of position where white
is simply a pawn down and you might
argue oh he's never going to get the
pawn back these three black pawns just
kind of defend each other and uh for
white it's not easy now to grab that
pawn and restore material parity that's
why the evaluation bar I think is on
black side because black has an extra
Pawn however white still has this very
powerful uh the potential of this bishop
might still has two decent Knights this
Knight now putting pressure on Black's
best piece this night in the center of
the board and at some point white might
threaten to regain a pawn by capturing
here at some point white might just try
and expand in the center by pushing all
of his pawns forward maybe this Pawn
maybe this Pawn white is very very
flexible and I should also mention in
terms of the evaluation bar above me
this is based on stockfish but different
computers evaluate different positions
in different ways and for example you
could turn on Leela which Lila zero
which is a neural network program which
is based more than AI than stockfishes
and maybe that would say oh it's just
equal or maybe that would prefer the
white position so maybe just a
difference of opinion here in terms of
all of the computers that Magnus and
nepo would have been studying with all
right well if you are following the
Leela assessments at home then
update us what is Leela saying about the
position right now yeah I would love to
find out actually so definitely tweet us
what Lila zero says and uh Lila zero can
be checked out online on the cloud
database
and that's one thing all the top players
do now they compare stockfish which is
traditionally the most powerful computer
Engine with others and it's all about
this bishop long term I think this gives
great compensation I don't think black
has a big Advantage here despite what
our evaluation Bar says I think it's
still too early to decide and uh in
terms of Napoleon actually's choices
maybe there aren't that many still if
you could for example think about trying
to defend this Pawn you could think
about defending uh bringing his Bishop
out sorry and he could maybe even
consider just pushing a pawn and kicking
away the white knight from the center
but that would be committal and might
loosen the Integrity of black spawn
structure you don't really want to touch
Pawns in front of your own King right
now yeah and I do have to say you know
that night move like you say it does ask
questions of black how is it going to
defend the pawn and the move that you
just suggested uh pushing the pawn
forward attacking the Knight well that
is actually the top choice of uh not
Leela but uh cessie which is like a
stock fish
um super powered socks you know running
on a very powerful engine and Top Choice
there and the only move it says that has
a small Advantage for black is actually
to kick the Knight back Alternatives or
to actually pick up the pawn that's on
the B line and move it up one square to
attack the White Knight and finally the
third choice is actually just to develop
the light squared Bishop but a really
awkward Square defending the pawn that's
under attack
um so the actual Bishop A6 yeah this one
okay so yeah blocked in by its own pawns
but it is doing a defensive thing with
this bishop this somehow feels
superficial Bishop on this Square you
nearly never see it in chess and I mean
what's it doing there exactly it's just
looking at its own porn it's kind of a
waste of three points yeah maybe in a
dream world if white again just does
nothing if white just kind of plays a
slow move maybe you could make an
argument for the pawn pushing forward
now and The Bishop's diagonal slightly
lengthening but uh yeah either way I
would be very shocked if we saw your
young upon actually Park his Bishop on
this Square top players they're all
about pattern recognition as you
mentioned earlier Ivanka and you nearly
never see that pattern in this type of
opening a bishop on this Square so I
would be surprised if we didn't see it
for example this Pawn push as you
mentioned attacking the White Knight or
maybe this Pawn push attacking the other
white knight it feels like the white
Knights are too strong and you need to
drive one of them away yeah I agree uh I
I think that the the B Pawn push where
you attack the Knight on the left side I
think that's much more natural than uh
weakening the light squares around the
black king but what happens though if
white just jumps into the center with a
knight because these two knights now I
mean okay black has a strong Knight too
but these two white Knights control a
lot of squares and suddenly Black's
extra Pawn it's been loosened it's been
weakened you have to give it back where
do you have to yeah you probably have to
no okay then then just thinking ahead
then it's perhaps much more natural to
kick back the knight in the center
possibly and then if you if you're
materialistic that is yeah I mean there
are consequences here maybe black can
make an argument for pushing one of
these pawns for word and initiating some
real chaos but it feels like the chaos
it will be beneficial for white because
just in general in chess if you have
nice centralized pieces
tactics will work in your favor
tricks will definitely work in your
favor so this move tempting but not
clear what the follow-up would be the
more I look at it the more I think this
move might well be played hitting this
white knight at least forcing it back
where it came from and yes black has
loosened his King slightly with his this
Pawn push but now look at this bishop we
talked about the Catalan opening being
all about this bishop it's not a happy
bunny right now it's trapped behind its
own Knight and by the Black Knight as
well
okay actually long think from him they
do say long think wrong thing but uh
maybe it's worth investing the time now
yeah and we do have to remember that
both players will be feeling the nerves
and they'll be this is a very key
position and every move here will count
and uh whilst and is considering which
Knight to attack well I just wanted to
share with you a poem Oh well actually
it's uh it's hang on let me get it it's
an acrostic Limerick by Andrew Vedder
and uh it's very very cool we have very
smart
um Twitter audience and it says calm
Catalan Carlson wants to see happily be
porn marches free earlier than expected
seventh move disrupted Sharpie prepared
is
spells chess
yeah and it looks like there's another
one on our screen as well another
Limerick so several oh okay Limerick
number eight there on the screen I think
you were reading another one Ivanka it
looks like Andrew is uh oh okay quite
the Wordsmith wow wow wow keep sending
in those limericks that is so cool I
know and if you want to oh yeah I just
saw it just now gravy nipple Matthew
prepares yeah yeah brilliant brilliant
stuff okay so if you want to also tweet
us your suggestions your your uh poems
your selfies then you can do so by
tweeting us using the hashtag chess24
live c24 live 24 Live yes all right well
he's still thinking about his next move
or person and by closest to these
players is Tony Antonio it must be so
intense to watch these players fight
against each other
guys it's super intense in here I'm
actually inside the plane menu and I
can't talk louder than this so I'm gonna
have to whisper I want to show you guys
so you can feel the vibe and the
atmosphere it's absolutely crazy this is
to playing all the auditorium come with
me
on the right side we can see it's a
packed Auditorium
with big screens up on the wall
we've got big screens up on the wall
where the players where where everyone
can follow the live games and right
there through the glass you guys can see
the action being played Magnus is
currently not on his chat Nepal having a
thing that silencer is so loud oh my God
one can almost feel the tension being
here
and the opening that we've had
absolutely crazy stuff going on this one
is going to be a fascinating fight I've
got to get out of here before someone
tells me to leave back to you guys in
the studio
wow that is so intense thank you so much
from that report inside the planet
playing venue Tanya wow I almost felt
like oh
we have Shivers and uh Kaya you've been
there in 2016 for the world championship
match between kariakin and Carlson was
it similar yeah I went to my first match
in 2014 yeah and that's when I got
hooked on chess because it's just so
intense you know sometimes you can say
that you can actually hear
the cracking in the brain and that's
what it feels like being inside these
playing venues it's just super intense
yeah it was the same for me in London in
2018 with Carlson against Carolina I was
actually sitting outside and of course
the players they're playing in the
soundproof box uh but everyone was still
too scared to whisper yeah nobody was
even Whispering because we were just
scared of disturbing the players and
kind of ruining the the kind of vibrant
okay meanwhile I moved from Jana
ponyachi and he has played the move we
were predicting so he has kicked away
this white knight in the center of the
board or he's trying to kick it away
with a pawn so it comes with upsides and
downsides to this move yes you remove
one of your opponents most active pieces
from the middle but you do loosen your
King's position so I mentioned actually
this game wouldn't end in checkmates or
direct attacks this last move does give
Magnus the potential to go for an attack
later on oh and the answer is
immediately again yeah yeah he had to
actually that was the only move to put
the Knight on a good Square I mean if
he'd moved anywhere else it was on a bad
circuit and it would be kicked away and
white would be in serious trouble but I
guess we should expect a quick response
also from janaji now then yeah because
his Pawn is under Fire he has to deal
with that issue and there's only really
one move to play and that is to push the
B Pawn one square forward and attack the
Knight yep let's show that because uh
actually Jana ponachi over the last few
times there's only one or two options
but he's been burning a lot of time he
spent more than half an hour now for
this game and Ivanka thinks that because
of the pressure on this Pawn actually
this Pawn now is attacked by both whites
one and by whitesnite now the only way
to deal with it is to push forward and
this Duo here are actually pretty scary
and I don't think Magnus Carlsen can
ever trade Knights because now these
double pawns can correct themselves but
I can take this Knight and suddenly look
at this Pawn chain this is beautiful
this is perfect black will just be a
clear Pawn up here and probably just
winning so Magnus would not be allowed
to trade he would have to plant his
night in the center and hope that later
on he can regain his Pawn uh a favorable
way but yeah this one is definitely
heating up the look at the computer the
evaluation bar thinks it's plus one for
black
this uh this is drastic times for Magnus
but he's not spent that long on the
clock he's hoping for some pressure uh
on this pawn and maybe if he gets time
he'll push forward in the center himself
so there's definitely positives for the
world champion for Magnus Carlsen
despite what the computer says uh either
way Napoleon actually maybe he's
spending so much time because he senses
an opportunity in this game is black
yeah and uh one thing that we kind of
noticed from yesterday's game and uh
that the computer evaluation was very
favorable for white it was saying
Napoleon she's going to win it's a porn
it's a pawn after all however Magnus
deliberately chose that line so
obviously he's like well I don't agree
with the computer assessment I actually
think that uh in that particular game
game one that White's position was very
unpleasant difficult to untangle the
pieces and you see the same thing here
because yes the computer might go black
is a pawn ahead take a look at those
black pieces on the left side of the
board a little bit of claustrophobic oh
kind of bunched up together fast asleep
yep
not easy to untangle and again when you
think about the potential Road for
improvement for black you know black
ideally wants to be pushing pawns you
know that's what you do when you're porn
ahead you march forward again not very
easy to achieve and every Pawn Advance
will have its consequence and and will
be weakening a potential Square
nice exactly despite what the computer
says it's not easy at all for black to
come up with ideas here and actually as
we talk the completion evaluation has
dropped slightly uh it's no longer so
far in Black's favor and in the current
position this is the one we're expecting
either way not an easy choice for
napoleonji and
he had what was it 11 12 minute thing
then another long seven eight minute
thing and now he's been thinking a few
minutes again
I mean nearly half an hour down on the
clock now for naponyachi that is going
to be worrying for him and worrying for
his team his coaches will be looking at
this thinking we should have studied
this position we should know exactly
what to do here but uh yeah even if you
study this type of position with a
computer it could be misleading for
humans it's definitely not an easy
position to play yeah and yeah is now 25
minutes down on the clock but it's some
perfect because Magnus has played so
fast so far in this game only 11 moves
into game two here but at some point he
will also take some pulses to think I I
suspect yes for sure
um it's hard to tell actually where the
Magnus is still in his opening
preparation because it looked like he
was surprised earlier but just by a kind
of transposition of moves it might have
gone back into something that he's
familiar with and uh this does look like
the type of position but back in 2018
2019 Magnus was embracing he loved to
sacrifice pawns around that time he said
he was in inspired by uh in the 2018
match working with a Russian Grandmaster
Daniel duboff and I don't know if he's
part of the team this time it's not
clear probably not because he's playing
a Russian but either way Magnus loves
these type of positions and uh that's
why he's been playing so quickly and
also he has experience with these type
of positions from the black side as well
he knows how unpleasant they are and we
can see that Magnus is not actually at
the board and we do have a question from
killer whale on Twitter who asks us what
do the players do well they walk away
from the chessboard yeah good question
it is certainly a good question I know
when I leave the board I'm pacing I'm
thinking about the position I'm actually
if I'm nervous I'm trying to calm myself
down using some mantras and generally I
don't like to think about moves but I
like to think about plans when it's my
opponent's turns yeah what about you
David yeah when I leave the board it's
normally to clear my head for example at
the recent Grand Swiss tournament
there were several occasions I would
just leave the board I would just walk
up and down but just just you know my
mind would be anywhere apart from the
chest I'd be thinking about dinner that
night or what I was going to do in the
evenings or about some emails I forgot
to answer
but then once I get back to the board I
feel I can give 100 to the chest itself
I also like to watch other games the
players here can't do it because they're
the only game going uh in the box but uh
I do think napoleonchi he's more of a
Pacer we saw him yesterday walking up
and down up and down but then Magnus I
think he likes to go and chill away from
the board away from the cameras it's
nice to kind of get away from from the
intensity sit there and chill maybe do
some push-ups I don't know
to get too sweaty at the board all right
well uh we do have Simon Williams Ginger
GM down at the popular good night and
also and I heard rumor in Simon that you
are there with someone who's actually
coached Magnus Carlsen earlier in his
life
that's right not just someone who's
coached Magnus Carlson but Magnus
Carlson's first ever coach and um he's a
good friend of mine I first met tall
Bjorn Hanson about 20 years ago and uh
well he's a grand master now so hello
tourbillon hello and uh you're a
magnus's first coach is that right yeah
I was teaching him when he was nine and
I for a bit more than a year and he was
I was lucky he was actually my first
student so I was lucky with that that's
pretty good he was your first student he
ended up being world champion yeah okay
so you've got a good track record yeah I
guess that's amazing and I remember you
told me when he was nine years old I
knew you all those years ago and you
told me this this kid is very special
um and you picked him out over all the
other kids in in the in your class what
made him special when he was nine years
old
I I remember uh at that time in Norway
there was like no really big stars and I
just watched the elite players and I
just dreamed that one day we have a
player up there also and then I got this
massive talent that I told people that
he's uh he's so incredibly good right
and people don't didn't really believe
me and like okay sorry but we do have a
move as well so let's just see it so we
now have a move on the board we can see
the board here and black has played the
move B4 yeah so being magnus's first
coach you're obviously cheering for
Magnus but what do you think about this
move what you think about this position
it looks to me like a very interesting
dynamic position has Magnus where the
white piece has got enough compensation
for the porn I think like definitely it
is a compensation but it's um the
opening phase is not finished yet like
black still needs to get these pieces
out and um I think he actually went here
we're getting do you have a move so
coming in yep the kind of idea just
defend this one but he's got lots of
compensation here yeah definitely and we
discussed here like the the F6 yeah it's
it's weakening but the like short term
you get this Knight away and it makes
life easier for black but in the long
run there are some weak weak spots yeah
it looks very interesting here from from
my point of view here okay black has
this extra Pawn but white might be an
attack the black king all the blacks
pieces are over on this side of the
board and look at that little guy there
we're going for checkmate tours is that
right yes we're gonna kill the king so
and what what was Magnus like as nine
year old was he was he a nice kid he was
a nice kid he uh he was like normal
normal kid like yeah he wondered like
when will he cross like 1000 rating
points oh wow he was 900 uh rating when
I started approaching him and one year
later he was 1900 so we're getting 1 000
points in one year and uh but the
special thing about him is that he
he got this exceptional feeling for uh
for where the pieces needed to be and he
remembered everything and he was so
interested in everything about Chess I
just told him one crazy idea and the
next game he tried it and uh he was so
open to learn things and good
understanding so he was he was a bit
like a sponge I guess like you gave him
something to do and he would just sponge
that information on yeah and a real raw
talent I mean we're talking about
Casablanca yesterday uh an ex-world
Champion one of magnus's favorite uh
world champions and he had that natural
talent but clearly as a nine-year-old
tobians just told us that Magnus Carlson
had that and well done to YouTube's the
tours as I know you
um for having been Magnus Carson's first
coach and uh we're kind of cheering on a
little bit today being in Norway and uh
like we said we're down the good night
pub in Oslo so get yourselves down here
if you want to enjoy the environment you
can see it's packing out a little bit at
the back there more people are coming
into so if you want to get a chair get
down here and torbian my very good
friend it's great to see you we've got
some stories but we can't we can't tell
them to the camera is that right no no
these are stories that were made between
us maybe after a couple of beers we'll
get Toby and back on and we'll let them
slip but for now back to the studio and
I'll let you guys in the studio talk
about what's happened in the game all
right now I want
them because I
worries over that there's some crazy
ones
all right thanks thanks so much Simon
for that report and uh for bringing us
toward Bjorn wow magnus's very first
chess coach and also from analyzing this
game you also said Simon when uh pushed
this queen okay interesting yeah a
strange move not one I expected shivanka
surprised no definitely not the one I
expected either I mean it wasn't the top
choice of the computer
um okay but it is a reasonable move and
what's very interesting about it is that
it kind of maintains the tension
everything is overprotected the pawn
structure Integrity is still kept intact
um still black has the issue of those uh
Queen side pieces that are not doing
anything so to speak but uh all in good
time I think all in good time and yeah
the reason I'm so surprised by this is
it just feels superficial the queen is
the most powerful piece in chess and
here she's doing a purely defensive job
it's not even a directly defensive job
it's indirect here defending upon a
couple of squares away for example if we
do see a trade then now the White Knight
cannot capture this guy because the
Queen's vision is on this Square so okay
there is a clear idea behind this move
but usually in this type of opening the
square the queen sits on is used by
either Max bishop or by Black's Knight
so Black's Queen has actually taken a
square away from its own pieces and
normally once you play your opponent
plays a superficial move or a strange
move that you don't normally come across
that is a signal to attack that is a
signal to step forward and I do feel
Magnus now he has to choose between a
few different strategies the most
natural to me would be a pawn push I'm
not sure exactly which one I would be
tempted slightly to open things up to
break down the head of Black's Pawn
chain over here for example we could see
a pawn trade and uh here at least now
there are more open lines and open lines
will favor white because his pieces are
more ready remember these guys I sleep
at home not ready for the action however
this would be committal because now
you'll never get your Pawn back you've
actually traded off Black's week
important and white will be a pawn down
long term so this one is committal the
other option that comes to mind
immediately is to push forward in the
center to try and kick away Black's most
active piece Black's most centralized
piece and if we see a trade of knights
then I think white would be very happy
look at this Pawn center it's going to
be hard to break down and despite being
a pawn down I think white has all the
chances here however this also does
offer the opportunity if white pushes
forward for Black's Knight to jump and
attack the White Queen black would gain
a bit of time here and maybe black could
even at some point plant a knight in the
heart of White's position so a lot of
tempting moves for Magnus he's actually
played this he's allowing this variation
he's allowing black to put a knight on a
very very active square but he's at the
same time creating a very powerful Pawn
Center and this is the 101 of Chess
Basics basically
um you just want to
control the central squares with your
pawns first and the pieces pull forward
later on the computer the evaluation bar
is not such a big fan of that move but I
think it will maybe slightly recorrect
itself and yeah I think the computer
just being a bit materialistic here
black support up but the rest of Black's
position is a bit smelly right now yeah
I have to say I'm gonna you might be
surprised by this but I actually
preferred your other pawn move which
broke up the head of the pawn chain and
the reason I say that is because this
Pawn Center does look very very
impressive but there are consequences
and if you take a look at the light
squared Bishop kind of Trapped and again
there's no kind of clear path what
you're going to do with these pawns
apart from control squares and uh my
experience in this type of position is
that it's a lot more difficult to play
with the black pieces if your opponent
opening is opening lines for the pieces
um
but then having said that it is very
tempting uh I'm not sure I also would
resist the the bait yeah we can't blame
Magnus for playing the most natural the
most tempting movement it certainly is
you know you get the phone Santa love it
yeah and he played it quite quickly as
well after only a maybe a six seven
minute think
um in this type of tense middle game
that is a good time investment in
general you don't want to be thinking on
any move longer than 15-20 minutes but
six or seven minutes at this critical
moment where both sides are just getting
to grips with the position I think
that's a good practical decision from
the world champion still maintaining a
big time advantage and uh
also a big moment for you and upon
actually yeah where to move that night
to trade itself off for White's night
which has actually long-term favorable
for black but short term not so great
would it would just allow uh White pawns
to kind of control each other in the
center
a night trade right now or do you run
away gain some time against the White
Queen but at the same time keep a lot of
pieces on the board and uh if the more
pieces that are left on the board the
more ammunition maybe Magnus has later
if he wants to build up an attack
um what would you choose humanka to
trade or not to trade
a tricky question actually
um my instincts are telling me to attack
the queen but then you know my head is
actually saying capture the night and
use that time to develop pieces
because I'm I'm really worried about
those pieces that are not working
and uh sometimes it can be an issue of
timing because you know say you attack
the Queen the queen is driven to a
square in the center where she has her
sights towards the black king you know
Simon kind of pointed out nicely White's
goal is eventually eventually Checkmate
right and uh again that night would be
offside so timing is everything so I'm
gonna go for Knight takes night what
about you David okay I'll go for the
other one okay
the White Queen and uh stylistically I
mean we know we've talked about these
two players Magnus he's a bit of a
universal player he can play any type of
position especially comfortable in the
end game but in these middle games where
he's got some initiative some long-term
goals he tends to be okay as well versus
Napoleon who's more Dynamic who's more
direct
who do you think this favors this type
of scenario personally I think this
favors Magnus not necessarily because it
suits Magnus and strengths but I don't
think that pony actually is so
comfortable in situations he's pulling
up and defending how about you I I
completely agree with that I do think
that this favors Magnus I mean we've
commentated on the Champions chess tour
and this is very similar to the
encounters that he's had against Daniel
duboff where he was playing with a pawn
up and it was Daniel duboff that he had
to kind of restrain initiative so Magnus
is very familiar with this type of
position so and and you know
foreign yes he's done a lot of work in
this particular line
but he's not so familiar he's kind of
his kind of bread and butter variation
was actually some a completely different
opening yeah exactly and probably
actually historically always went for
the grinfeld defense against one D4 and
it was only in the last couple of years
that he's realized he needs to broaden
his Horizons broaden his opening
repertoire and that's worked very well
for him it's brought him into the world
championship match but maybe
slightly less experienced than Magnus in
this type of scenario long term all
right his thinking again and we don't
only have Tanya on ground in Dubai we
have two reporters located here in the
Expo 2020 in Dubai where the world
championship match is going on it's a
huge Arena it's a huge place with a
bunch of stuff going on and our Danish
main man down there is you know what
what's going on there today roon around
the Expo area
foreign
well hello Tanya yeah you are absolutely
right this place is huge huge we just
had some dancing going around uh going
on behind us we have the robots all
kinds of robots uh we have all these
huge huge uh buildings that I would like
to share with you because this what you
see up here I would just like to show
that for the stream that's the Dubai
Exhibition Center that is where the
players are actually playing so uh today
that the mood is a little bit different
the weather is a little bit different
it's a little bit more damp here today
and the mood is also it's more tense
it's like okay now the show is rolling
and we just came out from inside of the
Dubai Exhibition Center or deck as they
call it and everybody are like a little
bit antsy like what's going on what's
going to happen it feels like something
big is going to happen today and I was
with my cameraman the awesome Island
right there waiting for Marcus to arrive
prior to the game today and something
kind of fun happened the car rode up and
I spotted inside the car my fellow Dane
Peter Heinen Nielsen who's famously the
trainer of Magnus and an awesome guy and
we are waiting okay we have to get the
shot of Magnus going out of the car and
going into the playing venue did Magnus
get out of the car no he stayed in the
car for seven minutes discussing
something quite animated with Peter
Heinen Nielsen so probably maybe some
last minute opening preparation going on
and then he got out of the car he had
the laser focus and he went straight to
the plane uh Hall so that is the status
update I have a interesting guy I will
interview later and I will return with
more back to the studio
thanks so much and loving the sunglasses
today as well thanks for that report and
that very interesting uh story from
earlier today you would have thought
that Magnus and his team would have made
the plan for the first White game for
months now but then the seven minutes in
the car yeah yeah that's disgusting
fascinating nugget of information there
I mean I'm not sure whether they were
discussing chess or discussing
basketball football results you never
know with Magnus but either way yeah I
mean it shows that the world champion
despite acting cool despite playing fast
in this game so far he's not 100 uh in
the zone yet he's maybe a bit nervous
um I mean there's no other explanation
to discuss chess moves or kind of
opening preparation so close to the game
and there we go after seven minutes
having a chat he does eventually get out
of the car and uh either way I think
he'll be happy with how this opening has
gone maybe they were discussing other
options something else that could have
happened but well isn't a little bit
relatable to you know it's it's soon to
be December now I at least in Norway a
lot of people will be doing their exams
now at this time of year and I can
remember that you know going to my exams
I would be studying hard in the bus to
the final repetition trying to remember
everything
is I like that a little bit with chess
as well so you decided you're opening
and then you're like okay
yes I'm gonna revise everything you've
got to cram it all in because you have
your long-term memory and your
short-term memory and so just before the
game sometimes you just whiz through a
few lines and just mentally clarify
everything and just say okay if he plays
this I'm going to pay that down this and
uh you know I'm sure Magnus he's done
this is his fifth world championship he
has a routine yeah and I'm sure he's
sticking to that and I've often seen
pictures of him uh Magnus walking
alongside Peter heiner Nielsen and
they're deep in thought deep in
conversation chatting about the game so
you know you have a pattern you should
stick to it and incidentally I was
listening to Gary Kasparov a former
world champion who gave a talk and David
your move is on the board Knight attacks
the queen and well Magnus instantly
replying centralizing the queen and uh
Gary Kasparov said that you know all his
life he just lived chess you know
everything he did was chess and when it
when it came to the world championship
it was nothing different he would spend
or morning working on it and wow David
Nostradamus in action the Knight now has
occupied that post yeah they do say that
every single chess game is like a new
exam and right now there's a very
difficult question that Napoleon
actually has just answered and now he's
posing a difficult question uh in this
exam to Magnus and uh look at this Black
Knight it's an intruder it's a bit of an
octopus there with all of its tentacles
controlling lots of squares in White's
camp and Magnus needs to get rid of that
Knight ASAP as soon as he can and if you
want to trade it off maybe for his own
night
um either way that black knight cannot
be allowed to live for too long it will
just control too many squares it will
paralyze all of White's pieces and maybe
we have to pull up the analysis board
here just because it's such a critical
moment this night is the key it's a
beast if Magnus can get rid of it then
his position is beautiful but if he
can't then he will regret that and right
now he would love to play a move such as
just retreating his Knight to try and
trade this guy off but this would lose
connection lose the defense of this
Central Pawn so I'm not sure white can
Retreat his night right now maybe you
can play around this night for a couple
of moves for example you can develop
your Bishop first and uh depending on
what black does for example if black
finally belatedly develops a piece maybe
now you can try and trade off this guy
you can try and trade it off for your
knight I don't think you can try and
sacrifice for example
um a rook for this night I don't think
it's worth a material sacrifice right
now but you need to get rid of it the
one question that bugs me though is that
if Magnus does play this move this
natural move the first one that comes to
my mind is that maybe black can bring
his other Knight
support this guy for example if white
offers a trade nope the trade happens on
Black's terms and one octopus Knight
gets replaced by another one and yeah
suddenly black remains with this
fantastic beast and
if Magnus cannot play the slow game and
slowly exchange off Knights then maybe
he needs to look for something more
direct does that include maybe breaking
up to the center right now
um you could make an argument for
trading pawns first but breaking over
the center in a way in this type of
um this type of manner is very tempting
because the black pieces are still
asleep black has one good piece right
now but maybe White's pieces are ready
for an opening of the position
especially this bishop yeah and I have
to say I feel that the time is now you
have white has to do something something
that also really worries me about this
position is um if Blackwood simply to
attack the Knight with his pawn and I
and then once the Knight is driven back
the light squared Bishop can actually
develop itself over to the A6 square and
suddenly there's all sorts of X-ray
attacks against the queen and this is
actually a really interesting moment we
do get a hint here about the stockfish
opinion the stockfish's uh move
suggestions and in the current position
after Black's just landed with his
Knight into this glorious D3 Square
the computer suggests two moves for
white anything else gives black a
reasonable advantage and those two moves
are pushing pawns one of them is this
Pawn push in the center it's not the one
I suggested but it's similar it's
opening up the diagonal for this bishop
also maybe trying to trade trade pawns
here to try and get towards this black
king uh the other uh Pawn push
suggestion is actually a trade just to
take on this Square potentially with the
same idea so after we see a trade uh of
Pawns maybe now white would push a pawn
forward again with ideas of opening up
this diagonal for his Bishop you could
make an argument for both of these Pawn
pushes to be honest this one or this one
either way Magnus needs to play very
fast very directly and very
energetically otherwise he is just to
pull down for nothing yeah oh dangerous
moment
um how natural is that porn move I must
admit it doesn't come to my mind at all
it might come to my mind after the porn
trade I have to say because then you're
lengthening uh the bishop maybe you get
there by kind of reverse engineering
your calculations so you see that okay
now if I push this Pawn forward now The
Bishop's nearly open but then you think
oh this does give black the chance
though to challenge this diagonal with
his own bishop and then you think okay
why give black the opportunity to put
his Bishop on a good diagonal maybe I
don't trade first and this is the kind
of logic that's going through magnus's
mind maybe he thinks okay I won't touch
this yet I'll do it in the different
order in the uh opposite order and maybe
now pushing forward is the most accurate
that's what stockfish thinks that's what
the computer thinks and now it now it
has a lot of logic right but it's not
it's not an instant instinctive move as
you say no uh I because you know you
just think hey black is simply going to
advance the pawn and then you stop the
evaluation there without thinking hang
on a second one takes Pawn is a little
bit annoying
um yeah so threats of maybe portex porn
opening up this bishop as we mentioned
but also if black maybe just blocks this
diagonal there's a couple of ideas white
could go for you could plant a knight in
the center of the board or maybe just
trade off first and no matter which way
black recaptures there will be targets
black now has an isolated Pawn you could
maybe go in this direction and try and
Target it with your queen and Bishop and
uh suddenly the more I look at it the
more I think white has decent chances
but it's all about finding this
difficult move
and I wouldn't be sure I'd find it in a
game I think it would maybe be my third
choice uh well in terms of instinct I
would first look at just developing a
piece just because I want to finish
developing everything I just want to get
all my pieces centralized first if
that's too slow then I would look maybe
at trades like this one or maybe a
direct Pawn push initiating complete
chaos
then maybe a more strategic Pawn push we
should also mention that if black
captures this Pawn then now white can
jump forward with a knight
attacking the black queen but also about
to trade off and eliminate this powerful
black Steed that we mentioned earlier so
I don't think that would be beneficial
for Napoleon actually actually I think
this is very strong this Pawn push for
Magnus but will he find it he's got
enough time to do so ah yeah the world
champion has been thinking for some
minutes now about this next move and
many will be saying that Magnus Carlsen
is the greatest chess player of all time
of course that is a discussion maybe
Kasparov is the one maybe Bobby Fischer
but uh we have now launched actually a
new collection of nfts so nfts are
basically digital Collectibles you can
collect now digital moments from Magnus
carlsen's road to goat is what they're
they're called so every now and then
there's going to be a launched and
released a new moment that you can bid
for and if you go to chesschams.io
there's actually been at least one
release already moments that led Magnus
Carlsen to become maybe the greatest of
all time definitely one of the greatest
chess players of all times so head over
to chess champs.io and start collecting
your nfts have you gotten into the
business yet David not yet yeah I'm not
brave enough but I was severely tempted
during the Champions Chester finals I
was on the brink of putting a bid in and
just trying to I got one thank you
um the gold money
Asian rapid one cool okay so that is now
in your digital it's Collectibles yeah
wow and I also I'm obsessed with the
pieces yeah I have um they're like
crystals this is beautiful yeah I want
to have them in showing in my house I
don't want to just keep them in my
digital data base I kind of want it out
there on my walls yeah it could be worth
a lot someday yeah yeah
the nfts you guys it's kind of a new
thing out there I see it on the news all
the time now people and celebrities
buying nfts of different stuff and now
you can collect these uh chess nfts
Magnus Carlsen road to goat and we're
gonna take the road down to Simon at the
good night oh I bet you're having a good
time Simon
I'm having a great time
um yeah just underwater obviously it's a
very exciting game going on at the
moment I mean this is the kind of Chess
we want to see we want to see porn
sacrifices we want to see Dynamic
positions and what we're going to do
just to do something a little bit
different I'm playing a very good friend
of mine oddbjorn who's a chess player
we're taking the position in the game
and we're going to play a 30 second each
game from this position I'm gonna play
Magnus You're Gonna Play Yan is that
okay is that okay opion okay so we're
keeping an eye on the clock and this is
going to play out who's actually going
to win the real game
so keep an eye on the clock so we've
only got 30 seconds off we go
there we go
Magnus is going to smash you Bjorn I'm a
bit slow here
look what's going on
I don't know okay well it looks like
Magnus might oh he's coming towards the
king now here he comes he's coming in
come around the angles the knight's
coming in oh and he's lost his Queen
sacrifice oh my words you're smashing me
Beyond you've got 19 seconds left this
is a terrible game of chess and it looks
like according to this game that Magnus
is in a lot of trouble especially the
way I'm playing but there's only 13
seconds left on the clock and this is
obviously how the game's gonna continue
in the real world this is obviously
everything like this is going to happen
nothing else eight seconds left and uh
Bjorn is now doing very well on the
position
um I don't know where that one I look
like a legal move and
okay so that was a very sensible game
there and that's exactly what's going to
happen in the world championships we can
see that Magnus is going to sacrifice
his Queen but win on time then I think I
think that was very realistic beyond
what what do you think there realistic
game yeah I was happy there was a couple
of moves where I didn't like play the
ultimate move but uh in general I was
very happy with my play except time of
management of course so are you happy
being Yan I'm very happy being Magda so
would you rather be Magnus I'll be
rather be young here
obviously it's going to win as long as
he keeps uh
I watched on the time and the clock that
he should yeah that's good quite easily
actually okay well that was uh that was
kind of random
um and you can see this is how the day
is going to pan out uh down here at the
good night chess Pub in Oslo a great
place where they're showing the chest
everywhere lots of fun going on lots of
supporters now back to the studio and so
it looks like Magnus is still thinking
but yeah what's what's going on in the
game yeah
I was super impressive Simon being able
to commentate and play what would be
like a super bullet game there very
impressive thanks for doing that
and anything for TV yeah anything for TV
very nice thank you so much Simon and uh
yeah David I guess if this happens in
the game that's going to be the most
Sensational world championship game ever
imagine if uh Carlson and Nepali
actually follow all of those moves or
imagine if Napoleon actually gets a
winning position and loses some time
just like uh happen there yeah yeah
these guys I mean that shows the fun
they're having down uh down at the good
night and I think around the world
there'll be similar uh scenarios I know
lots of Chess fans are putting the
position on the board and playing it out
and that's one way to learn that's one
way
um to improve that's what these guys did
when they were young as well yeah
yeah I'm jealous of Silence
our test is fun and in various shapes
and forms and the most important thing
if you ever want to get better at chess
is just simply to enjoy yourself while
you're playing and just even that game
you know it is something to learn from
and it certainly it will inspire you to
play even more because you know once
chess bites you know you kind of you
can't just Escape it you know and it
also shows that chess is actually a very
social game yeah you know when playing
at this level it is I mean these are of
course sitting you know in deep thoughts
but it is and I think it's one of the
barriers I think we need to break down
actually that chess is just this
cerebral game that two players play in
silence yet that is one Element but like
you said it's a there's you can have
jokes you can have banter and you can
involve everyone in the audience and uh
talking about that
we we do have some tweets yay and I
would also like to thank everyone for
sending in their selfies I'm very much
appreciated we will feature them on the
show but uh Kevin winter does ask us why
are the players playing behind the
screen surely they would appreciate an
audience to add atmosphere and they're
playing behind a screen because they do
need silence it is a world championship
match and you certainly although they
would appreciate the whole atmosphere
and audience you do not want any kind of
case where the audience shout out an
answer or a little bit noisy so
in this particular situation the stakes
are too high to have the players playing
in front of a full audience and we also
have a question from Michael Thomas I
love this question by the way Jan has
this great tick where he Twirls a
captured piece in his hand while
thinking who has the best thinking tick
ah oh that's interesting actually
um if we're not just talking about these
two players then I would say Boris
gelfand a former World Championship
Challenger in 2012 he I mean he's the
quickest and the most skillful I've ever
seen at twirling the pieces and he can
do it on all sorts of different
directions and different movements with
every single piece I didn't notice Yan
doing it actually here so far but maybe
that shows a bit of nerves but I think
in general chess players just like to
keep their hands busy yeah um it's just
to do something while the brain is
working so fast I learned his u12 with
your pieces I always make sure that I
take it below the board though so my
opponent can't watch me ah so they can't
get distracted while I scroll play with
the pieces but the best one I've seen
was actually kramnik she went and so he
went and got one of his captured his
opponents her captured pieces he went
and said that's mine and he started
twirling with it and his opponent said
well I'm going to do the same
and then just grabbing all the places
back yeah that's fun yeah I guess some
other ticks would be just facial
expressions as we mentioned and uh yeah
someplace I've I've faced they hunt to
themselves occasionally and lots of
different uh yeah different habits I
actually the last question as well the
last tweets that we had about playing in
this box behind playing behind the uh
glass it just brings back memories of
this match uh well stories that I've
read of the match between karpov and
Coach noi where there was so much drama
and cautionary was complaining about
members of the audience trying to
distract him or trying to hypnotize him
and I think the reason we have them in
this Fishbowl in the in the glass box is
purely to just dispel any
accusations of kind of
well non-family essentially and yeah the
players they're used to this kind of
scenario where it's just them and the
board and uh okay meanwhile a move is it
going to be the move we said was
important here Magnus he finds the top
computer suggestion wow fish said this
earlier has been quite strong for white
and
we aren't that surprised right Magnus
finding the best move she's the world
champion currently for a reason and uh
what what happens to the bar there okay
you're it's gonna correct itself it will
correct itself yeah it's just uh the
evaluation but I noticed it for a few
seconds it just counts the material and
then it says oh black support up that's
why it's around plus one then it looks
at deeper it starts calculating deeper
and it will realize okay it's still
roughly balanced
still anything can happen but I like
this move from Magnus it also signals
that he wants to attack any time a pawn
lands on this Square the E5 Square it
means that white wants to attack the
black king yeah and uh it's heating up
it's heating up but yeah is uh not at
the board right now we're gonna head
back down to Dubai to Tanya who earlier
today was in out right outside this fish
tank it was very intense where are you
at right now Tanya
hey guys I am outside the auditorium now
so I can at least speak louder we can
see the commentary is on the feeder
commentaries on behind me now it's been
a very complex opening in game two a
very fun position we've got with us and
to give us more opening insights I've
got with me front master Alejandro
Ramirez thanks for joining us Alejandro
always a pleasure all right now Ali
seeing second E6 second move E6 by uh
bayanachi what was your first impression
I think it was rather expected I think
at some point his team sat down with him
looked at netball and said Your name's
not mvl you can switch openings you need
something a little bit more solid to go
into the world championship because
imagine that you just prepared the
groomfield and a whole is poked into it
then you're kind of stuck but having the
NIMS of India and repertoire as your
main defense means that you have so many
matches and such solid positions to play
with that it's not strange that he added
it to the World Championship right now
so I'm not surprised at all that he had
E6 in mind oh wow a lot of us were
expecting the grunfeld but as you
mentioned you need something more solid
and we've seen Yan speak about this
change in style he's got new people on
his team Grandmaster Peter lecker one of
them so makes a lot of sense for him to
choose this line yeah absolutely and you
can see that they're not shying away
from complications that despite the fact
that it is a ninja Indian type of
repertoire that in this particular
Catalan they went for a complex one
right this B5 instead of a more
classical approach in in the Catalan and
I think that suits Napa's style but of
course it opens them up to different
types of plants like the one that Magnus
has chosen
Grandmaster srinath Narayanan who has a
course on the Catalan had a very
interesting tweet that everything that
Magnus has done so far reeks of him
having worked with dubo for this match
is the Catalan giving up a bond for
initiative what's your take on that I
wouldn't be surprised and even if duboff
is not working in this particular match
you can see the remnants of his work
with dubov in the previous match the way
that he handles Dynamic positions the
way he's not afraid of giving away pawns
for long-term compensation he did it
yesterday he's doing it again today so
it might not be true that he's working
with duboff right in this one but that
Specter let's call it of duboff's work
is still around influencing the match
even today wow that's fast and of course
the whole talk is about who are the
seconds for this match now speaking of
uh Yan playing the move B5 those talk
about wait a second this is grishek's
favorite line what do you think are the
odds of Alexander gristook being on team
Yan for this match it really is a bunch
of speculation out there it's hard to
say the thing is uh you even if you have
a list of solid seconds you still want
to play properly for your own player
right so even if you have seconds that
perhaps wouldn't play B5 themselves you
can sit down and think what is going to
benefit my player and in this case I
think that it could be anybody that
analyzes B5 to its entirety now of
course we have a lot of strong Russian
players who mentioned grishyuk a lot of
talk has been around karaoke and but
although that doesn't seem very likely I
think that it's really just a guess at
this point amazing staff now Alejandro
the position the current position on the
board with Magnus just having played E5
who do you think is more pleased with
the outcome of today's opening I think
they both are pleased in different ways
I think Magnus is happy that he got a
little bit more prep and he was able to
get a bit of a Time Advantage but he
also knows it's a very complicated
position I think he would have been
happier to not see Queen D7 and instead
have seen the lines that included the
move B4 and the reason I think they were
just more studied and they went into
more forcing paths and I think it was
wise for nepo to shy away from them I I
don't know if you've been able to see it
but they would have transposed into this
beautiful girlfriend Cheryl from 1992.
that was just a just one of the most
brilliant games ever girlfriend was
unable to finish her off but executed a
wonderful wonderful attack and it's a
very funny transposition because it
seemed like the variation was completely
new but somehow it would have transposed
back into that semi-slav game and of
course that would have been a huge
preparation by Magnus and instead we
have Queen D7 which I think was Wise by
nepo and he's a little bit in his
comfort zone in the sense this is very
complex and I really liked what you said
before this interview that your favorite
part about today's game is that this is
not going to fizzle out too soon you
can't even imagine how it's going to
happen and I think this is a chess Fan's
dream one side has a pawn the other one
has the initiative man an apple
maneuvered is Knight to D3 and hasn't
developed any of his Queen side but he
has a pawn and he has that expansion on
the queen side this is what we want to
see this is going to be a dramatic game
man it could even be the first decisive
result of the round of the match already
oh my God so much to look forward to in
this one big drama big fight coming up
back to you guys in the studio thanks
Alejandro
and thanks to you Tanya and that was
also very interesting launching
um Grandmaster Alexander grishock a
great Russian player maybe as a second
Rihanna pumniacci yeah it's fascinating
with all of the speculation and we know
that the whole of Russia is behind upon
me actually so I wouldn't be that
surprised I mean at this point it's all
speculation but uh yeah it just shows
that you can draw ideas even if it's
just inspiration even if it's just
looking at some uh some of your Rivals
games you can draw ideas from everywhere
and that's what napony actually has done
in this opening playing the favorite
move of one of his compatriots one of
the most successful Russian players of
uh of the last few years and okay it's
led to a really complex position there
and Napoleon actually just bringing his
Bishop to the side maybe just kind of
trying to keep some control over this
long diagonal we talked about white
slight Squad Bishop a lot but
um yeah Napoleon actually maybe the
speculation about karyakin maybe grow
shook so many names and either way
Magnus carlsenal and his team will have
to go and study Alexander grishek's
games they'll have to burn a lot of time
waste a lot of time looking at his games
just in case he is part of the team now
what do you think right now David of
this position is there's a drawish game
or or what is it I think it's about as
far as way from a draw as you can get in
chess I mean every single piece is on
the board wow only one capture so far
black is a pawn up and uh with a
material imbalance with all the pieces
remaining with neither side's King
completely safe especially the black
king
I think that's going to be decisive
result in this one I just have a feeling
I'm not sure which direction it's going
to go and who's favor but
I don't think we're going to see a draw
here I'm going to say it now yeah I I
have to agree with you that uh David
although the computers are kind of less
enthusiastic about White's position I do
know that the vibe on Twitter is very
much that the advantage is very much in
Carlson's hands and we have a tweet from
German Grandmaster Nicholas husenbath
who says this uh move that Carlson
played would be huge for Carlson and
both players are now definitely on their
own so yeah absolutely thrilling stuff
and uh this is what we want actually
from the Catalan yeah I think this
opening the Catalan opening was the
perfect choice for this game uh maybe
for the rest of the world championship
for Magnus Carlson because it's such a
hard opening to neutralize there's no
way for black to immediately make a draw
there's no way for black to force the
issue either way you will be on your own
at some point and you'll have to
improvise and if you're improvising if
you're kind of winging it you're
probably actually with less experience
in these types of positions with both
colors he's not going to be in his
comfort zone and you can tell Napoleon
actually is not his in his comfort zone
because of the clock difference still 20
minutes down on the clock and yeah we've
talked about the Catalan go check out
that free chessable course because it
will change your life if you are a
strategic player especially if you're
maybe above uh 14 1600 and if you want a
new opening to add to your repertoire
it's been endorsed by the world champion
in this game and uh there's no better
reference than that so
um yeah Magnus Carlson we love his
opening so far from the white side or at
least we love the position that has
written from it just in terms of
double-edged combativeness of it but uh
if you can continue the momentum he's
got chances now yeah and I have to say
those two those two Bishops they're
really sort of just eyeing up each other
on the diagonal there how important are
the black pawn and also the White Knight
sort of blocking them yeah um I think
the black porn is important black needs
to keep his pawns where they are black
and barely touch them so as you
mentioned it's these two Bishops there's
a lot of kind of indirect tension um
it's as if they're on a date but on
opposite sides of the restaurant right
now and uh if this night suddenly moves
which it might well do at some point if
this pawn moves which it might have to
for example if Magnus trades and
suddenly the bishops come to life and
this tension it would actually favor
Black if the bishops come off but while
the Bishops remain I think it favors
white so Magnus won't touch this Pawn
yet he doesn't want to open up the
length uh kind of and lengthen the
diagonal of this bishop but uh the moves
I would be considering here I still want
to keep this tension uh the move I would
be considering is simply Pawn takes Pawn
just to open up a line for the White
Queen against this potential weakness if
black takes with a pawn then suddenly
the black king is really Airy really
open you don't want to ever see this as
black because suddenly the bishop will
jump forward for example and already
there are checkmating ideas if this
Knight moves then the White Queen is
ready to come and Checkmate this black
king So this won't happen but if it
doesn't if for example black takes with
the bishop on the Square on the F6
Square then suddenly isolated pawn and a
Target and for example the bishop can
come hit this Pawn later on once we get
rid of this Knight The Rook will join
the action and try and line up against
this weakness
and of course the Knight can actually
jump into the center and control a
square and uh I will be yeah the other
night I was actually thinking yeah you
know invite all your pieces to the party
as they say and uh then of course you're
looking at many squares and uh or even
jumping in with this Knight and just
opening up this diagonal can I mentioned
this tension yes now it definitely
favors white look how many squares this
bishop controls relative to its uh
counterpart over here
all right this looks promising for white
it's it's maybe the simple approach
maybe Magnus is looking for something
more sophisticated something deeper he's
got options he can move this bishop he
could jump in immediately but
think there'll be a long thing here for
the world champion
all right thinking for four minutes now
my name is Carlson he is still quite a
lot up on the clock but do you think I
mean yesterday we had a move where one
player was thinking for over 50 minutes
yeah is this that critical moment for
minus I think not yet but it's getting
there I think we're inching towards the
critical moment uh we've already had
some big big decisions from both sides
firstly napoleonchi to grab the pawn
secondly for Magnus to just allow the
pawn Black's extra Pawn to survive uh
and especially magnus's last move
pushing in the center those were all big
decisions but they didn't necessarily
lead to any long variations any forcing
moves where there's checks or captures
or threats so I think when those start
to arise and they will soon that's when
we'll see the players spend a lot of
time and I have to say I've noticed one
different thing today from yesterday
Jana ponyachi is spending a lot less
time by the board yesterday it seemed he
was mostly sitting there if he wasn't
sitting there he would be maybe walking
around the room a little bit but being
there seems is now you know shifting
tactics a little bit leaving the room
trying to stay a little bit away yeah as
soon as Magnus moves he's off he's out
of there yeah it's uh strange he lost
what was it eight minutes on the clock
earlier during one move just being away
at the wood and then a couple of months
ago he lost another five minutes being
away from the board so
um could it be that he's yeah hopefully
there's no healthy hopefully there's
nothing distracting in there yeah I was
trying to think back to his normal
behavior I mean because I'm also just
like Napoleon when I play chess you know
I make my move and then I'm out of that
pacing and just trying to get rid of
this nervous energy formulating my
thoughts and uh just thinking back to
Napoleon she's normal over-the-board
behavior
walks around he walks around a lot
but is is he so instantaneous with his
departure from the board not always no I
mean I've played him maybe
nearly a dozen times and every game and
he gets up at some point and walks
around but half the time he likes to
just sit there and kind of smile at his
opponent and just show them he's fully
comfortable and you can tell there's
like a Swagger an air of confidence
around him but uh if he's not singing to
the board he can't show Magnus that he's
feeling confident
so maybe it is a bit of nerves part of
the Russian so how how big of a part is
the psychological battle here and when
you're playing a game in a big
tournament will you sometimes think okay
wait I'm gonna make this move but I'm
gonna wait a little bit so he thinks I
maybe haven't decided or I'm gonna
put my hand here and then switch to here
so he thinks do you actually have these
thoughts at all uh I think I have them a
bit too much I focus too I focus too
much on the psychology for example
during the grand Swiss recently I sensed
that my opponent's most natural move
would be a big mistake but it requires a
lot of calculation and I was getting
quite low on the top on the clock
already I was down to less than 10
minutes but I thought okay if I look
nervous if I act nervous it will tempt
him to play quickly and play this
mistake so I was just thinking thinking
I knew exactly what I was going to play
I was just nervously kind of shuffling
and then I made the move and he reacted
instantly with the blunder so
um yeah sometimes there are tricks like
this in World Championship matches
there's different types of psychology I
mean Magnus he's acting really stoic and
really calm at the moment but
yeah some players act confident on
purpose some players act nervous on
purpose and uh I mean it can go either
way you can't guarantee that it will
affect your opponent but if it does one
percent of the time then you might get a
chance at some point in this match yes
and you have to remember this is a match
a 14-game match where he's playing the
same opponent again and again and uh the
Mind matters here and they definitely
have to get the measure of each other so
I I think uh maybe Napoleon is
distancing himself from Magnus for a
reason actually just to kind of say hey
I don't want any part of your
over the board off the board game so let
me just focus on the chess and just
think about it from a distance which
chess players can do yeah I mean they've
for shortened upon me actually he's got
the position in his mind anyway if he
doesn't necessarily need to look at the
board but the one concern if I were for
example if I were putkin if I were on
the ponyachi's team if I was one of his
coaches I would be looking at the clock
and I would be thinking okay you have
two hours for 40 moves that means the
first 20 moves you need to spend an hour
we're only at move 15 and he's got just
over an hour now so he's actually
technically slightly behind schedule in
terms of how long he should spend on
each move and in the opening you want to
be ahead of schedule because Napoleon
actually played what was it the first 10
or so moves instantly yeah because he
was still in his opening preparation and
uh that means he spent nearly an hour on
his last six or seven moves yeah and
that's slightly worrying uh he's
normally a very quick player as well
very instinctive he trusts himself and
he makes quick decisions but today that
hasn't been the case all right well with
his last move at least he's brought also
Magnus Carlsen into a deep thought we're
gonna head back down to Dubai there's so
many interesting people uh out and about
and around this world championship Arena
and one of them is a very famous chess
streamer um Eric Rosen is with uh doing
that down in Dubai
yeah hi you know if I say oh no my queen
everybody is going to know what I'm
talking about and that is due to this
guy right here I ran into I am Eric Rose
and hello Eric nice to meet you it's
great to be here thanks for having me
well thanks for coming and sitting down
for this interview so I would like just
to get your first impressions on being
here as a chess fan for the World Chess
Championship yeah it's super cool uh
it's pretty surreal just seeing a world
championship in person and to be
photographing in the playing room is uh
it's a treat for me so yeah super
grateful to be here
and you mentioned that you were
photographing in the playing venue
because you are actually not here as
Eric Rosen the chess star streamer
you're here as a few days official chess
photographer is that right uh well I've
I'm still Eric Rosen but I am working
for fide as uh official photographer so
it's a cool job but uh I'm still
reminded that I have a streaming
personality I'm getting stopped uh
pretty much non-stop by just fans here
so it's uh I've had to balance it too
between taking photos and taking
pictures with fans so
yeah it is pretty crazy
um do you have any predictions have you
been following the game today
um yeah I mean the position right now is
actually like really crazy like some
wild Catalan opening and uh it's hard to
predict given that uh the position so
tactical so I think all three results
are still possible
thank you very very much uh I would like
to go back to the studio and just say
thank you to Eric for always being Eric
Rosen even though he's also an official
test photographer I will return if I can
catch you a little bit later to ask some
more questions of the streaming star and
chess photographer back to the studio
thanks so much and I see it's gotten
dark and Dubai and the sunglasses are
off and we also have uh two moves on the
board yep we have a couple of moves
Magnus eventually did decide to capture
a pawn and Napoleon actually instantly
uh made his reply so let's just dive
into the position just to explain what's
happened there's been a small change now
we saw that white had a very strong
point here but maybe he needs some
direct action he needs his pieces to get
some squares as well so he went for a
trade and as we saw black didn't really
want to open up his King by trading and
recapturing with his Pawn instead he
took with a bishop very sensible and now
Ivanka is itching for the move Knight to
E4 this night on the E4 Square the
Central Square it's a beautiful piece
it's on an apple post actually can't get
kicked Away by any black pawns and also
it hints at capturing this bishop if
this bishop is captured for example if
black makes a night move if this bishop
is ever captured then black loses all
control over the dark squares and now
white Bishop for example could jump out
white tonight could uh jump in towards
the center lots and lots of options here
for white I think this would be a
favorable trade yeah and one thing I
just want to point out about this type
of positions is that the black queen has
to stay on her Square guarding that pawn
that is being challenged on B5 okay yeah
because I mean otherwise you know if she
gets greedy and she tries to initiate
some kind of Trades to kind of capture
the pawn in the center well you know
Black's whole Pawn structure on the left
side of the board can fall apart yeah
that's right there's too much pressure
on this guy black has to protect it with
a pawn but also the queen behind so if
White's Knight jumps into the middle
some viewers at home might be wondering
why can't a pony actually get greedy and
capture a second pawn and if this
happens is that we might well see a
trade in the center as you mentioned the
black queen now lured away from her
ideal Square she had to stay here and
now after a Trader pawns on this side
there would be some tactics there would
be some potential tricks for example
along this diagonal we've been talking
about this diagonal the whole game and
finally there would be a breakthrough
for white this Knight is in the way so
you give it up with check you force your
opponent to take this Knight but you
open up the diagonal for example uh
black has to react to the check now
Bishop takes Bishop not only do you win
that important Bishop but you trap the
black rook in the corner so uh yeah
Magnus Carlson now calculating some of
these tricks just making sure that
everything works in his favor but once
he does once he sees the potential of
his pieces especially uh this bishop on
G2 then I think he will go for a move
such as yvanka's jumping forward with
the Knight I would also be slightly
tempted to consider a move such as
bringing the bishop out but all of these
ideas are to dislodge Black's best
defensive piece right now black has two
good pieces the active Knight and the
bishop here which does a good defensive
job so you need to get rid of one of
them and I'm expecting to see yeah this
move might jump into the center or the
bishop coming out
all right and I have to say it looks
like the white king is very safe and
it's like King less safe agreed fully
agreed not only does the white king have
a lot of pieces around it and actually
this is one of the perfect Pawn
structures in terms of defensive uh
formations in chess but it also has a
lot of bodyguards Bishop Knight Rook
queen and the black king in return yes
he's got his Rook which is also a good
Defender but if this bishop is traded as
we mentioned if White's Knight just hops
over and takes this bishop then minimal
Defenders for black right now yeah and
also the black Rook very sort of just
locked in is that a big worry for Ariana
yes and we showed that variation a
moment ago where if okay it's four or
five moves down the line but if Napoleon
actually plays some very natural moves
this Rook might even get trapped in the
corner so they'll probably actually I
think if white jumps in with to the
center with his Knight I think he has to
catch up in peace development he has to
just ignore this threat of taking a
bishop and just bring his Knight out so
that the Rook can finally breathe some
fresh air yeah uh I agree and uh well
Black's position is a little bit shakier
at the minute
I mean maybe he's okay but it is kind of
hanging by thread already
uh I'm gonna be really careful with
black and if I were to put the
if I were to point the finger of blame
at one piece I think I would point it
out that night that has found its way on
the D3 Square because I mean quite
frankly why it's a black pieces should
have been developed the rest of them I
mean this Knight alone has moved once
twice three four times four times and
we're only on move well he's just made
to move 15 now as black so that's a
large percentage of moves have been
committed by this Knight and uh maybe
those moves would have been better
allocated from the other pieces instead
all right minus deep and thoughts we are
uh enjoying so much uh receiving all of
your selfies and I think it's time to
take a look at the pictures that you're
posting on hashtag c24 live
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much for posting all those
selfies we're so happy to have all of
you around the world joining us and
watching the drama unfold in Dubai and
here in Oslo Simon Williams is down at
the good night pub and Simon I'm
wondering is this game anyway unfolding
like your bullet game earlier
yeah I think it's exactly the same as
the bullet game
um nothing has changed whatsoever
um no it looks a very exciting game
chances of both sides I think Magnus has
got this real Target that you can attack
that pawn in the middle of the board so
I'm liking his chances at the moment but
maybe we can ask some people in the pub
so um let's go to the bar mate and hello
there um can you introduce yourself hi
my name is Rebecca I work here brilliant
Rebecca and do you have you been
following the chess yes I am pouring
some beer and then I'm also watching
some chess so I'm mainly relying on the
computer I must admit but uh it looks
pretty exciting it sounds brilliant who
do you think is going to win
yeah and you're a big Magnus supporter
yes absolutely so yeah and have you ever
met Magnus does he come down here at all
he does yeah
yeah quite a lot actually okay brilliant
and he's always friendly
yeah yeah good it's good yeah all right
well good stuff well thank you very much
and we're just gonna now walk around and
just see what else is going on in the
pub and uh we've got another chap here
so uh hi there do you want to introduce
yourself well I am
hello hello and your opinion on the
match so far oh it's uh to uh and
nerve-wracking right now
but to be honest I'm very happy if it's
in a draw today yeah but but yeah it's
quite Celtic yeah and I really don't
like the might no of Nepal so uh
it's a good chance it's a Magnus so yeah
brilliant okay I would pay for him still
okay great okay well we're just uh you
can see the atmosphere is really picking
up here people are playing Blitz as you
can see they got beer they've got clocks
they've got everything you need they're
even shaking hands look at that really
well played and um it's a great
atmosphere it's building I think there's
a lot of Magnus Carlson fans down here
no surprise there and I think he's got a
great chance to win today so um back to
the studio and let's see how Magnus is
getting on
thanks so much for that report uh Simon
and uh you're optimistic for Magnus but
we did hear the Norwegian fan they're a
little bit worried about the night
situation can you agree with him yep uh
if white can get rid of that centralized
Black Knight deep in White's Camp then I
think Magnus will be feeling very very
confident I think that one piece well in
conjunction with Blackstock Square
Bishop those two pieces are holding
things together for napony actually so I
understand why that Norwegian fan was uh
slightly nervous I would be too
especially if one of the best players in
the world like Napoleon actually had a
knight right there next to me but I do
feel magnificent I can get rid of that
piece at some point and uh I think most
of the Norwegian fans are because he
just cares so much he wants Magnus to
win so badly yeah you know he is a big
favorite experts have launched Magnus as
a big favorites in this match
how devastating would it be for him to
actually lose his title as a world
champion
I think it would hurt yeah a lot if
Magnus were to lose and especially I
think it might hurt just a little bit
more if it were his childhood rival yeah
you know maybe you know a few years down
the line when Magnus got older and it
was some up-and-coming kid then maybe he
might think okay well fine let them have
a time but you know childhood Rivals I
don't know I don't think Magnus would be
very pleased about that as anyone would
because Magnus is still very much in his
prime you know he seems to get better
and better it's not like we've seen a
decrease in his standard if if anything
is the opposite and of course you have
to remember I do think that Magnus has
his eye on Gary kasparov's record which
is what is that record he said 16 years
right 16 years but then again we heard
yesterday Alaska 27 years seven years
yeah but with an 11-year break with uh
the first world war going on exactly
yeah so everyone kind of tends to look
to Gary you know as the main one to beat
because he spent so much time I'm at the
top and of course Gary was the one who
picked her Magnus Carlsen to that number
one spot when the chest 24 did the 50
best players of all time so yeah I I
think it would be upsetting in summary
as a long answer but it would be
upsetting for Magnus yeah and sometimes
he brushes it off he talks about being
world number one on the rating list as
being more important but he's been world
number one 10 years in a row that
probably won't change for a while I
think the title now he's there now he's
in the competition himself I think the
title will mean a lot to you and yeah he
won't want to see Napoleon who's
actually beaten him several times in the
past to take another title from his
grasp
you can see just by magnus's facial
expressions there his body language he
cares when Magnus is maybe playing a
more friendly event and uh with lower
Stakes then he'll just be in his chair
kind of leaning back we've seen it
before from Carlson but uh right now
he's in full Focus mode and he wants
this we said yesterday as well any sport
anywhere any opposition he wants to win
it's all about winning for him yeah and
thinking for 14 minutes now is this a
critical moment in the game can Magnus
go dramatically wrong in his next move
not necessarily in his next move but we
do have to remember that there is
certain risk to magnus's play because he
is after all pawn down and uh if he were
to play a few inaccurate moves perhaps
adopt the wrong plan then things can go
wrong and if they go wrong with Black's
porn majority there on the left side of
the board it can seriously go wrong I
mean we're talking about he might be
leaving losing so we've got a powerful
Black Knight yeah exactly okay we have
his move okay well it's ivanka's first
instinct Ivanka suggested this what was
it 10 15 minutes ago yes but I didn't
have any calculation to back it up
because I mean this is the big
difference actually between higher level
players is that they devote a lot of
energy to the board meanwhile uh lower
rated players tend to play by instincts
and they go yeah we'll work out in the
end and sometimes this is good you can
trust this but uh and then even Magnus
himself talked about this in Norway
chess that he didn't feel he was
particularly sharp but he put in a
hundred percent effort over the board he
was working so hard and look at him
there you can see his uh deep in
concentration even after making his move
yeah and he's calculated it all out he's
like worked out what's going to happen
if the bishop Retreats what's going to
happen if he's allowed to capture the
Knight and of course if black gets
greedy and captures the pawn that's
really interesting the two different
strategies among the players Napoleon
actually just running away from the
board just going and chilling out there
in the back maybe just trying to turn
off his brain save the energy for when
he's back at the board with Magnus not
afraid of burning that energy just still
in Focus mode trying to get as deep into
the position as possible and they'll
probably actually instantly making him
move he's actually played the move I
suggested a bit earlier bringing his
Knight out purely because that night was
sitting at home doing nothing and at
least the Black Brook in the corner now
does have some leeway
it does have some squares to run to and
instantly leaving again Jana pomyachi he
is this is definitely part of his
tactics now making his move leaving the
board and looking at the position right
now David what do you think it's still
in the balance I mean all three results
definitely on the cards
personally I would pick white here
despite being a pawn down and despite
black having this really powerful knight
in the middle I would pick white because
I like the centralization I just like
the coordination the pawn structure
somehow with black it feels like you
need to be more energetic you need to be
I don't know you just need to be ready
to react and reacting can be hard rather
than dictating the play rather than
bossing which side of the board you're
going to play on then again yeah
anything anything possible here and uh
yeah I was actually going to say on the
last move Magnus jumping with his Knight
into the center it just reminded me of
that Alaska quote it's like when you see
a good move look for a better one and I
think that's the situation Magnus is in
right now he sees a few good moves but
he's looking for the best and uh right
now for example white tonight in the
center can go and capture the black
dusker Bishop white Brook can slide
across so I can capture a pawn push a
pawn I mean I don't envy him this type
of position because I would be spending
20 minutes for sure just working out all
of the options and at some point Magnus
will have to end his calculations and
just trust his instincts yeah yeah
because isn't that one of magnus's
strong points his intuition just
following his intuition making the first
move that comes to mind yeah and that
that suits him very much in Rapid play
chess you know when the game is a lot
speeded up you know that he can rely on
his instincts when it's a classical game
you know you do have to take that time
and you do have to work things out like
my instinct is a screaming at me going
Knight takes Bishop
I don't know why but I almost want to
play it instantaneously
um but you can see Magnus is just okay
and I think he's done it yeah it looks
like he took a piece no no he didn't he
put his knights in the center Johnson's
the center I was about to say he's about
he's going to take this bishop eliminate
Black's best defender and then make a
decision but no he's jumped into the
middle with his board and the computer
really hates that move will the
evaluation bar correct itself or will
Magnus be justified and
okay he must have been calculating this
on the last turn this is maximum tension
right now he's attacking the black queen
he's also got an eye with this Knight on
the Black Knight the black powerful
knight but remember this square is only
covered once by the white pieces it's
only covered by the white Pawn but it's
attacked twice by the black pieces so
for example if the black queen runs away
I can we I think we can rule this out
white will just take back the Knight and
now he has a glorious position he's won
back his pawn and this Knight is
centralized the queen is perfect white
has a big Advantage there's two things
to calculate in the current position
instead of that black for example can
take a pawn with his Queen running away
with the queen but grabbing a pawn
Magnus would be two pawns down
how is he going to justify this maybe
he's going to take the bishop with check
now yep um
yes the black Rook will take black could
make an argument for taking with the
pawn and then does he just want to take
this Pawn now that he's opened up this
diagonal for his Bishop this one's still
incredibly complicated so many pieces
hanging so many pieces attacked this
Knight might drop off but then again the
Black Knight might drop off oh so much
action happening here this was one
option or will napong actually simply
capture this Knight remove it from the
board will that come at the cost of his
own night I'm not sure about this one
because we'd see a trade and then the
white Pawn stepping forward and now the
Black Knight has disappeared I don't
think we'll see that one but we might
well see Bishop takes Knight and for me
it's not clear who this favors white
tonight does have a landing uh spot now
protected by its Pawn but at some point
black could get even greedier and take a
second pawn and uh also last night has
survived that whole transition this
powerful night and Napoleon she's back
at the board he's lost another two
minutes away from the board yeah this is
all gonna add up actually but uh in the
meantime extremely complicated position
right now and the computer thinks it's
still roughly balanced but this one
could go either way over the next two or
three moves wow now still a bunch of
pieces on the board obviously we are
only in move 17 is it for them looking
at this now is it a little bit chaotic
totally chaotic it feels really
uncontrollable actually because the
lines that you some of some of them that
you showed there actually showed both
sides being incredibly active with
Dynamic possibilities and and uh and
again
oh well I feel like we have to run
through them again just to kind of get a
handle so we can just we can discount
the ones where like simply Returns the
pawn but what happens if black gets the
greedy again this is so there's two ways
to be greedy remember white tonight is
attacking the black queen and the Black
Knight yeah so by being greedy I think
that would mean either capturing this
Knight with a bishop or by capturing
this Pawn right for black queen so two
main options here for black which one
are you attempted by your Banker
Instinct wise uh grabbing the poem with
a queen okay take this guy yeah and now
just to be safe I'm going to remove the
black Bishop from the board yep okay now
I liked your Rook taster night okay
makes the most sense now to justify
White having given up a second Pawn I
think we need to utilize this diagonal
yes I'm going to play Pawn text Paul
yeah this is what we this is what you
had and then the nighttime capture it
because of this bishop takes bishop move
yeah and uh we have to go Knight takes
might taste I know hang on a second the
night tastes Pawn takes and then yeah it
takes night and then I guess white will
capture this Knight on the side of the
board kicking this black Bishop away and
uh then the back Bishop is forced back
to the back row and somehow this does
feel like white has has a lot of bite
here you know with the bishop pair and a
very far Advanced Pawn so I don't think
this one is entirely convincing for
black these guys are just two weeks yeah
support up but all of these three guys
will eventually drop okay right already
I think and bring this bishop out with
devastating effects this Square maybe uh
maybe to the square lots of ideas yeah
so we can discount
I think we can discount this one right
okay
therefore that would leave okay Napoleon
actually's reacted actually instantly I
mean it's such a complex position
completely chaotic and he's taking this
line yeah okay so this has done the same
as us though process of elimination he
saw the others weren't working and now
he's taking this white knight Magnus
will instantly recapture and now will
black grab a second Pawn or not I think
you might have to and you just have to
bite the bullet Magnus now is giving up
two pawns but he's got rid of Black's
Key Dark squared Bishop yeah and uh he
probably should grab that form because
uh like you pointed out the night path
will come into the center the G6 square
and uh look at these Knights too
powerful and he hasn't grabbed the pawn
and he played very very quickly okay
this is one thing that's been talked
about as a strengthened upon me actually
trusting its instincts playing quickly
dynamically but it's also been talked
about as a weakness of his in a critical
position like this one not even thinking
that oh that is so risky the opponent
actually he's trying to eliminate this
white knight I think he's trying to also
set a trap if the white knight jumps in
now and saves itself maybe Black's
Knight is going to jump in and look at
these two guys this game is a game of
knights it's it's I mean it's good
timing that uh that Simon went down to
the good night tonight
these three nights now I mean
so much chaos they're causing and this
Knight now hits this Rook as well as
this bishop which is also hit by the
Black Knight on this side so I have
these two black knights I think are
going to win some material on this
square or this Square
still not over to be honest still really
complicated this position but Magnus he
has to calculate a lot before he decides
whether he can save this knight from a
potential trade or not
well yesterday a tense game that ended
in a jaw what words would you describe
to to describe this game tense as well
yeah it's more tense and even more
dramatic even more chaotic yeah I mean
it's a different type of tension as well
you know the first game was it was just
kind of almost clouded in confusion we
didn't quite know what was happening how
the pieces were going to be developed
here is just a tension because the
pieces are just getting ready to spring
to life and this means that it's going
to be all about timing and every single
move now is critical
um and we're talking about game changing
moves actually if someone blunders here
I think it's going to decide the game
yeah I mean yesterday there were lots of
mysterious moves really deep Concepts
that you needed to study the position
for 5-10 minutes to get to the root of
today is just cave Manchester it's just
I'm gonna threaten this you react I'm
going to threaten this you reacting then
um yeah right now I see your bank
conventions one wrong move from white
black will have a decisive advantage and
likewise black makes one slip white will
be winning so let's not trust the
computer evaluation too much despite the
fact it says pretty much is zero this
one could go either way instantly one
slip and the bar will shoot off in One
Direction and One blunder will shoot off
in the other direction
um just because it's equal that only
means chances for both sides this one is
still far far away from a draw all right
and looking at his position
well Magnus is he uh sort of looking at
this piece as a problem for me I need to
fix this or is he looking at okay I'm
gonna attack
he wants to do a bit of both of them
yeah I think last resort will be to make
some trades and to eliminate one of the
two black knights that's kind of Last
Resort time he's going to be looking for
more ambitious continuations first for
example bringing the White Knight Into
the Heart of the black position we've
highlighted earlier bring the white
knight to D6 maybe he can bring his dark
Square Bishop out as well shall we go
into and again because
down and divide with this super
interesting position Tanya is an
outstanding with because there's not
only chess players down there I also
heard uh hear rumors that we have some
journalists Tanya
we do we've got journalists from all
across the world now very few of them
actually had access to both the players
before the start of the world
championship match and one of them is
the chief sports reporter from the
garden and we've got him with us it is
Sean Engel from the gardening Sean
welcome thank you very nice to invite me
Sean how's it going covering a chess
match first few days well it's been it's
been interesting the games have been uh
already uh starting off with surprises
uh and the traffic back home at the
guardian for the pieces I've written and
for our coverage has been very high so
it's been a very good start a very good
start now I read your piece at the
Garden where you spoke to both Magnus
and Yan before the start of the match
what was your feeling at that moment
when you met the two players going into
the start of game one well as a
journalist for General Sports uh Pages
I'm always looking for things that will
grab you know the reader sofa for nepo
his Russian supercomputer was an
interesting thing because it will
attract people that aren't just into
chess they want to know they want to
know more about him and what his
preparation for Magnus you know that he
can he can be very good but he can get
bored if he doesn't like the questions
so therefore you again have to try and
work out how can I probe him on certain
things and hunger seemed an obvious one
and he surprised me that he he was so
willing to to talk and be so open that
he didn't quite have the motivation of
being this fifth world title match so um
no both went very well both were
interested in nepo um I've sometimes he
can come across as being a little bit um
I don't know quite the right word but he
you know he could be a little bit loose
sometimes and he was actually very nice
very pleasant and uh someone else I
spoke to said oh you got him on a good
day so uh I was lucky Maybe
amazing now Sean of course you've
covered all sports for so many years you
have this intuitive understanding of
athletes of sports persons acrossport
tell me a little insight on that when
you met Yan and Magnus what was your
personal feeling how confident were they
about the match the tension a little bit
on that there was definitely some
tension I mean it's not too dissimilar
I've been to a lot of world Title boxing
matches and they're two days before the
fight or even someone said there's a big
press conference and there wasn't quite
a Face-Off which you get in boxing but
some of the press conference questions
again you're wondering how cagey they're
going to be are they going to be
expansive and actually it was better
than boxing because boxing it isn't much
more than I'm Gonna Knock You Out no I'm
Gonna Knock You Out and actually both
players know they joked they relax I
think
um you know nepo smart a few times and
some of magnus's you know barbs and I
think it went quite quite well on the
whole that's really amazing to hear all
these insights now Sean we've seen such
a big shift in the chess while chess is
becoming so mainstream Guardian covering
the match what do you think has led to
this change well I mean the obvious
things are the pandemic and the Queen's
Gambit I think particularly the Crane's
Gambit uh and the big challenge for
sport I think is to
keep that going you know I think I think
like chess 24 and other sites have done
that a lot of women
um commentators uh just to make the game
more uh appealing to that young that
girl young girl like that young boy that
wants to learn I think I think
chess maybe five years ago it was almost
seen as a bit like attending a
university you know you watched
commentary on any site and it was it was
high level I think what the websites are
being good at is actually thinking you
know we've got a new audience here we
need to capture them we need to bring
them along and I think the challenge for
for the organizers now is to build on
that you know when when a young seven
eight nine year old watches coverage of
the world championship are they going to
be able to find a club when they go to a
club are they going to sort of have
someone there that help helps them along
and I think that is the next big
challenge Resort because it's had booms
in the past you know Fisher spassky in
England we had shortcut spa and then
it's had a bust so the question is and I
think that's what everyone in the sport
should be asking themselves how do we
make sure that doesn't happen again
wow that's amazing well it is the Golden
Era for chess right now and chess is
getting hot so is the position on the
board thank you so much for joining us
Sean thank you for having me let's get
back to the analysis in the studio
thanks so much Tanya and you're
absolutely right it is heating up in
this game Magnus Carlson thinking
tensely David are you worried for him at
all I'm very worried and uh so tempted
to launch the guess the move right now
because this is a critical moment and
Magnus I we've been discussing it just
while Tanya was doing an interview I
think he's only got one continuation to
keep the balance
it's not an easy one as well it requires
sacrifices it requires huge courage is
he going to make a move if not I think
we might have to launch the guess the
move all right that's a good point okay
so just before we launch the guest of
the move I'm going to explain the two
main options I think that White's gonna
pick and then the audience they have to
vote so uh right now let's jump in white
now has to keep his night I think this
Knight is the key piece if he trades off
then I don't know if Magnus has enough
compensation black has an extra Pawn on
this flank and I think this four versus
two Advantage he has on the queen side
on the left side of the board will be
decisive but jumping in with the Knight
does require a sacrifice
jumping in now allows the Black Knight
to come in and fork and double attack
the rook and the bishop and now Magnus I
think would have to just give up his
Rook move the bishop out the way not
sure exactly where and give up some
material and white now would be a pawn
down and what we call the exchange down
what would be a rook for Bishop down and
with it one less Pawn but this Knight is
so strong that maybe it's enough
compensation so this position the
current position
I think I'm gonna do it guys it's time
for guess the move and uh what is Magnus
gonna play Black has just brought his
Knight forward is he gonna trade Knights
is he gonna jump forward with his Knight
audience you guys tell us we want to
know your opinion
[Music]
all right and this means that you guys
have to tweet us on hashtag c24 live
with what move you guess will be
magnus's next move and you can wrinkle
prices yeah you can win an amazing prize
it's one year membership of G chess it's
the first ever website where you can
just set up a position and you can get
that position searched on chess
databases chess articles short and sweet
chessable courses and YouTube It's a
tremendous resource at your finger
fingertips and uh yeah look forward to
seeing your moves remember hashtag c24
live and uh excellent prize up for grabs
will Magnus Carlson take that risk and
move the Knight forward a big risk and a
big moments Magnus has been thinking for
almost 10 minutes so he could make a
move anytime now get your tweets in
explain why you think you'll play that
move as well and yeah we'll pick a lucky
winner yeah what what is sort of the
diff is one more attacking one more
defending sort of what is the difference
between the two movies suggested yeah
one is more ambitious that would be the
Knight leaping into the D6 Square that's
the most ambitious but it requires
another sacrifice he's already one Pawn
down Magnus who has to invest more
material for that if he doesn't take
that option maybe he's okay but he's on
the defensive and he'll have to be very
very solid so it's going to take a risk
or is he gonna just lock things down and
try to bail out of this game wow
interesting and dramatic moment in the
game and you can join in guess the move
using hashtag d24 live on Twitter all
right it's uh Magnus Carlson and deep
thought for this next move what will it
be for the world champion
can he go really wrong here yes yes he
doesn't play one of those two moves we
suggested maybe Knight takes Knight or
bringing the Knight forward
I'm struggling to come up with
Alternatives well we have actually a
suggestion on Twitter which is actually
developed dark Square Bishop which does
look very natural uh attacking the
Knight
um maybe the audience will get a move I
haven't predicted and then they'll
definitely be winning a prize I think so
we have an answer the move is on the
board you guys Magnus Carlsen
okay
he's up for the challenge and Ivanka you
will stroll Twitter to find a winner yep
I know all right well David yeah this
Show's Magnus is in the mood to fight he
wants to win and he's not materialistic
at all we might well see Magnus give up
a rook that white rook in the bottom
corner now it might drop off if Black's
Knight jumps towards it because I don't
think Magnus will save that Rook he
cannot save that Rook look at this and
upon me actually reacts instantly wow
straight back to the board move and is
he gonna get up again is he going to run
off
hey Magnus now has a big Dilemma to face
that rook in the corner is under Fire
and that white dark sky Bishop also
attacked by both the Black Knights this
one has reached Boiling Point now the
next couple of moves might decide the
fate of this game wow it's still early
20 only move 20. but uh so much
attention complete chaos
favor would you who's your favorite in
this position
two moves ago I would have said why now
oh
I do like my material Kaya I would be
greedy here as black maybe but then
again White Knight that white knight
that Magnus just saved the one we asked
the audience to guess the move for that
night is glorious and that is the key
piece
so it's so hard to call
um it's amazing the computer says pretty
much 0.0 despite the fact black will
technically be three points up on the
board black is going to have a huge
material advantage
yeah a minus he has 48 minutes left on
the clock to make 20 moves to reach move
40 where he gets another hour on the
clock and he is thinking again Magnus
Carlson oh this is intense game two in
the world championship match and it's
boiling point David owl says spoiling
point for sure and Magnus that he was
about to make a move he retracted his
hand he's not 100 sure this is not the
type of position you can fully trust
your instincts you have to calculate as
well
as he moved to start Squad Bishop as we
predicted is he going to leave no he
doesn't he leaves his Rook attack
uh well he doesn't leave his room he
leaves his Bishop attack sorry uh on the
C1 Square the white star Square Bishop
he moves this Rook across but okay now
black can still grab material but trade
off extra pieces in the process
okay we have to jump into this yeah we
have to do this um yeah what's gonna
happen Knight takes Bishop yep that was
a quick decision by the word Chuck and
he must have been thinking about this
beforehand the pony actually now is
going to run back to the board he's
going to make a move and uh we mentioned
here this Rook is attacked Magnus moved
it but he could also have just defended
his Rook by bringing his Bishop out the
way and after Knight takes Rook Rook
takes Knight is still the same material
um kind of imbalance that we described
earlier black will be three points up
but Magnus instead chose a different
option he brought his Rook across one
square and black and still win material
black can take this bishop we would see
a trade here white will recapture and
after all these trades we see that black
has an extra rook in return white has a
knight black also still has one more
Pawn so which piece is better
we're gonna find out you guys tell me
because I do not know it feels like The
Rook should be better but then again
White's night is just phenomenal
anchored as well by a very strong Pawn
Yeah and uh when you look at the
position a little bit objectively
because it does feel like black is a lot
better you're kind of like the Knight is
very strong as you say anchored but also
the black Brooks don't actually have too
many squares on the open lines yeah and
the black Rooks eventually they'll have
to dream of for example a pawn trade and
then coming to an open Line once the
bishop moves out the way it's not going
to be easy look at all of the black
pawns yeah they are but uh I'm not this
idea immediately but over the next year
over the next few moves yeah oh but this
position is about to arise on the board
neither player's sitting there right now
again but once we do see one of the
Black Knights take that white Bishop on
C1 we will end up in this position and
it's a battle which pieces are better
Knights or Rooks
and uh okay Magnus is the first back of
the board and upon that she's still away
where is he this is a mystery
are they does done to disconcert Magnus
he's clearly thinking about the position
backstage maybe there's also a screen
just showing the current position and
then probably actually rather than sit
on the board where he has to kind of
think about mind games with Carson maybe
he's just sitting there relaxed in the
chair he's looking at the screen maybe
it's like a tactic you know Force Magnus
to be in this room by himself you know
and uh Magnus maybe might get irritated
by that I know I certainly would lonely
right it's been a huge glass box all on
your own yeah because normally it's like
the battle of the minds you know like
can one person out with the other and
then suddenly you're just in a room by
yourself and it feels like maybe you're
playing a machine oh I love this about
World Championships you can overthink
things yeah definitely all right well
Dave uh David sitting here but Simon
Ginger DM he's down at the good night
and definitely following the drama in
this game what do you think Simon
wow it's a very exciting position at
this moment in time I mean it looks to
me like Yan is getting in the game quite
well there for those nights you see the
Black Knights are causing lots of
trouble in the position these two ones
here Magnus does have a knight right in
the middle of the board but it's uh it's
a little bit uh a little bit dicey at
the moment but we're very lucky to have
one of magnus's very close friends
actually with us so uh would you like to
introduce yourself yeah I'm my name is
aspirin so yeah just a test by myself
not a very good chess player but yeah
I'm a business friend and yeah I like to
like to watch yeah to follow chess and
I'm it was looking so good for Magnus uh
by Catherine arrogo I don't know what
really what happened but yeah but are
you a bit worried for your friend now do
you think he could be in trouble here
yeah this is looking it's looking as
good as it did at least so okay but I'm
yeah hopefully he'll uh manage to get
back into the game but that's those
nights I think I think we actually have
a couple of moves on on the board as
well I'm just going to try to work out
what's happened as soon as we get them
through where we're better play them you
can see uh yeah I think he has taken the
bishop here which we kind of expected
him to play so this looks like Magnus is
going to have to sacrifice more material
and he has Magnus to sacrifice The
Exchange now so he's kind of all in I
know Magnus is a poker player right yeah
and but he he's all in now right because
uh there you go the Rooks are coming off
and after this one well uh now Yan is a
lot of material up so this is like do or
die this situation if Magnus does not
check mate if Magnus does not get a hole
in the position he's gonna lose this
game Rook here has been played defended
the bishop so this is this is real
really sharp stuff right I mean uh yeah
yeah I don't know what do you think
magnus's plans should be here just to
hold on and well I guess the good thing
is Magnus has got this great night and I
think he must try to attack the king
here he must go for the king but before
we go back to the studio and go back to
that I mean you're flying over to UAE
tomorrow yeah I'm going to Dubai
tomorrow so I landed after the game
tomorrow so hopefully yeah yeah we'll be
going to manage to get a win before
before I land so you hope he's going to
be in a good mood right yeah yeah so you
all good friends of him and are you
going to support him over there just by
being there and yeah I'll get to see two
rounds and also two three days so
hopefully we'll get to yeah yeah and how
does he like doing his spare days does
he like doing a bit of sport or uh just
relaxing and yeah relaxing of course the
last match in London we're going to see
a football game on the free day so yeah
we'll see I've never been to Dubai
before so we'll see what's what's going
on there it's going to be interesting
yeah but you must be a little bit
worried because I'm sure it'd be nicer
if Magnus is in a good mood rather than
a bad mood I mean this is a tense game
yeah I think we should probably go back
to the studio soon because at this
moment in time
what is getting critical I know that
Magnus is a lot of material down here
but he does have this fantastic Bishop
yes that Bishop can start striking
towards the King and I think he's got to
go all out and attack that King now if
it doesn't work he's going to lose this
game so uh okay before we go back to
Studio do you think he's gonna survive
this one do you think he's going to win
any predictions
I hope so I think he's gonna I
he's he's good at not losing games so
yeah okay I think he will manage so more
Magnus supports it great to get a close
friend of magnus's here who's going to
go and support him over in Dubai soon
and again we're trying not to be biased
but we are in Norway we are in magnus's
Hometown we've got to be a little bit
biased if I start cheering for Yan I
could get thrown out and I don't want
that to happen so back back to the
studio ah thank you so much Simon and
for taking us through a couple of moves
that happened in the game here
is this super dramatic four Magnus
Carlsen the world champion right now
it's it's extremely dramatic he's taking
some massive he's taking huge risks and
they could well backfire as Simon
mentioned if white doesn't deliver
Checkmate if white doesn't somehow get
to the black king he's just gonna lose
the game I don't see any other way uh
about it right now and even getting a
draw he's far far away from that I think
the only way Magnus can get a draw is
somehow if maybe black gives back a rook
for that powerful White Knight and uh
maybe we'll have to jump deeper into the
position because there were a couple of
moves while we were with Simon and uh
Jan again instant replies from him uh we
left it here a bit earlier in the studio
black did indeed capture this bishop we
saw a trade a set of Trades and right at
the end of this variation black just
shuffled The Rook across adding extra
protection to this bishop so some
viewers at home might be wondering why
can't white play Pawn takes pawn and
good question the answer is white can
but probably doesn't want to because
after a recapture white can regain some
material for example taking this bishop
but after all of these trades white has
parted with his beautiful night his
beautiful bishop and only ended up one
Pawn down however this looks hopeless to
me these three are simply gonna beat
this one and uh White's one point will
not hold up that majority long term and
uh if we see white capture that pawn I
think Napoleon actually will win white
has to ignore this part of the board
well it has to allow these pawns to sit
where they are and I think it's time as
Simon mentioned to bring the bishop into
the game White's Bishop can centralize
itself maybe eyeing up some pawns
towards the black king maybe joining up
as well with the White Queen the White
Queen and Bishop will both Rush towards
that side of the board and uh at least
there will be some threats towards black
and they'll probably actually won't feel
entirely comfortable this guy is
certainly a Target and is black in
immediate danger in this type of
position because I'm just thinking the
ideal thing that black wants to do is
actually tuck the bishop into the corner
and then try to release it yeah and uh
you know if you've got the time to do it
great if you don't have the time then
Magnus might just be able to save the
game okay so talking of saving the game
Magnus decides okay it's not the moment
to actually bring this bishop into the
center maybe he's saving this one for
later keeping him up a sleeve instead
he's brought his Rook across one square
eyeing up the black queen and uh also
very very sensible if black work now for
example to play your move your Banker
bring the bishop back then at least
Magnus could capture a pawn with his
Knight I'm not sure which one you want
to capture but for example you could
Retreat the knights capturing a pawn and
opening up a direct attack against the
black queen and Magnus would be fighting
he'd be right back in this game so it
feels like Napoleon actually has to move
this queen out of the eye line of the
white Rook but where to do you Shuffle
her cross towards the king side just in
case she's needed as a protector just in
case yeah it feels that way if you go
the other way then oh no no no the queen
has to look after her King the queen is
the King's best friend after a night
maybe but uh Yep this queen maybe now
can jump towards this side of the board
if necessary to try and provide some
attack action yeah and you also want to
keep her along along the seventh row
again just in case something happens
with the king and you need to make a
pawn move yeah
yeah so maybe Magnus has some ideas of
lifting this Rook up going towards the
black king eventually it takes a long
time it's not clear exactly does he have
time David that's the question it's uh
all about timing right now if black gets
two moves as you mentioned if White's
too slow for example pushing a pawn if
black just drops the bishop back and
then somehow either just captures
releasing this Rook or just pushes this
Pawn forward and is able to trade
Bishops then Black's extra Rook versus
knight will be decisive but
yeah it's all about timing does white
have enough time to for example lift The
Rook up the board and then maybe swing
it across maybe to this Square lining up
against this this guy and the bishop
more come as well everything has to be
towards the black king right now no
other justification for Magnus and
sacrifice is all about this guy
oh gosh now Stakes are extremely high
right now yeah absolutely
um
gosh let's go back to the players
because she's actually at the board I
want to know if he's thinking because
he's been playing instantly over the
last half dozen moves some massive
decisions from the pony actually
just he's not there no he's not there no
it must be some kind of psychological
strategy or like you say he's not
feeling so great I mean he's known for
his speed
but again just to make that move and
then leave the board
he's probably spent what maximum two
minutes at the board in the last half
hour
um the pony actually just I mean I
admire his strategy yeah but not many
people could get away with it
um with doing what Napoleon actually is
doing yes he's back he's about to reply
will he just move his Queen instantly as
we're used to seeing from him now yeah
it looks that way like he's gonna take
the move and then
okay Shuffle the queen maybe he'll think
for a little bit he just took a piece
there to fiddle with and uh okay and
upon actually settling back into this
game he's got a 10 minute time Advantage
now still 17 moves to make before the
time control before move 40 would they
get an extra hour
and uh normally I would say that's not
enough 53 minutes but uh for the pony
actually judging by his speed maybe it
is ah it is and uh talking about moves
we do have a winner for your move of the
day and uh one year's membership of G
chess that goes to Flo who correct
correctly predicted that Magnus would
make that risky move and put the Knight
onto D6 so congratulations Flo you are
the lucky winner and uh someone will be
in contact asking for your details very
cool congratulations on your
subscription to G chess and I wonder
what G chess is saying about this
position right now yeah maybe Ivanka
contract but I have been checking G
chess uh you it's very useful in the
opening it also has some very powerful
engines and uh but it's very very useful
in the openings because there you can
check up the openings against the
articles that have been written and uh
also the YouTube videos how cool as that
and it uses even artificial intelligence
wow some very very complicated thing
just so so that his searches are very
fast yeah usually when the searches
happen they take a long time but no with
ghs pretty much done in seconds and
anyone who loves Ginger GM Simon
Williams should go check out GTS it's
his uh brainchild and he's been working
extremely hard on it and he's been
showing up to us right and I think it's
going to help our dress a lot so G chess
Flo the winner let us know what you
think of it yep definitely
and meanwhile Napoleon actually he is
deep in thought
and uh okay spending almost five minutes
on this move I'm expecting the black
queen to move I don't see too many other
options you could potentially make an
argument for Black's Pawn uh if you
would look at the left side now the
queen side black spawn capturing a white
Pawn but that would completely dismantle
the black porn structure black would be
left with five isolated pawns and you
don't really want that
so
I think it's time to just play Safety
First automatic chess your opponent
indirectly attacks your queen with a
rook
Slide the black queen away to safety and
um yeah I'm also reading this Tweet now
from Douglas Griffin
under 44 minutes and Counting for 18
moves that's right for the world
champion now critical position
it's uh it's not going to be easy for
the world champion for Carlson to
Escape time travel if you weren't if you
were in janapomnia's chair right now
what would you be sort of feeling inside
would you be like
ah I got this you know yeah excitement
you know the feeling that
you know keep calm I can do it you know
maybe I can win this game if I go right
you've got to calm down your blood rate
uh your blood pressure your heart rate
sorry uh because yeah for now right now
it's beating it's beating and
um he might be acting cool he might just
be taking a few deep breaths but inside
he knows he's got a golden opportunity
here to take the lead in this match
napony actually it's not going to be
easy there's still going to be a lot of
pitfalls along the way a lot of mistakes
that he needs to avoid but
yeah I think his evaluation his internal
evaluation he knows that he with correct
play should never lose this game and
could possibly win it I have to say I
think the most nervous people watching
this game must be the seconds
team magnus's team because you know they
know that there's a huge amount of risk
involved in magnus's play and uh you
know
it's true the engines are on occasions
they kind of lie they kind of assume
that you're going to play Perfect chess
and it is after all two humans playing
chess and you know humans make mistakes
so yeah but still yeah even the computer
evaluation it's not a winning Advantage
Plus One Plus 1.5 it just means that
black with perfect play has the
advantage yeah maybe white can still
hold it if white plays perfectly as well
so
um yeah from a human point of view
chances for both sides yes and in terms
of ease of position maybe white has
easier plans white knows he has to go
for the black king at some point and
upon actually it's not exactly clear how
you simplify things how you trade off
Rooks trade-off Queens how you get to
your end goal of winning with your extra
material yeah and we have some questions
on Twitter where they're asking us hey
why why can't black play the very calm
puntex born
good question I was uh wondering myself
I mean my first answer is what black
can't play it because it's just too ugly
right I mean instinctively you know the
Rook is opposite the black queen and you
know like skedaddle with the queen get
out of her out of his way but uh yeah I
mean this is just so calm I mean look at
these double pawns doubled pawns
isolated one yes anyone who's played
chess for a long time will be uh
reluctant to go for this it might well
be a good move it might even be the best
move but uh human instincts tells you
that pattern recognition
yeah you can't go for this uh for
example at some point white we'll just
recapture one Pawn I up this guy I up
this guy
if you take this Pawn yes you might
survive you might even win this black
but uh you also run the risk of even
losing now I think uh taking this Pawn
for black would really be playing with
fire taking this guy too much pressure
and especially on that pawn standing on
the E6 Square I mean with the queen
bearing down and maybe a light Square
Bishop don't touch it this guy and
Bishop can come around towards it as
well so
um yeah I think this one it's Brave it
might even be good but it's unlikely to
happen I think the most natural move
would just be to get out of this tension
out of this pressure and slide across if
they'll probably actually place this
move however if he does take Pawn takes
Pawn full respect to him uh he has Nurse
of Steel and he will be able to put
aside those prejudices about Pawn
structure that we all have so yeah I'm
very biased against Bad Blood structures
I must have been and I think most top uh
most of these guys such as Carlson and
Napoleon actually are two so I wonder
whether that's the computer's Top Choice
but even if it is I would say sometimes
just follow the basics he's done the
hard work upon actually he's one
material he's actually technically three
points up on the board with his extra
Rook for Knight and extra Pawn so you've
done the hard work just keep things
simple and slide across with the queen
yeah
Magnus Carlsen ever lost a game in the
world championship match with the black
pieces he basically yeah
not that I know of yeah didn't he lose
to karaoke but that was with the black
pieces no one's with the white pieces ah
yes you're right actually yeah it was
with the white people okay mate yeah
because he over pressed yeah he was
trying too hard in a roughly balanced
position and uh again maybe Magnus in
this game he's been creative he's been
attacking but maybe he's pushing things
too much being a bit too direct it's not
normally his style he likes the longer
games this isn't necessarily going to be
one of those longer games and uh
meanwhile Napoleon actually has
retreated his Bishop to the corner so
he's dropped the bishop back there's two
reasons for that first so that the
Knight can never capture this bishop and
secondly because he wants to open up
this line for his Rook now on the next
turn if white does something quiet then
we would see black play Pawn 6 Pawn
because it opens up this Rook so a very
calm move there from Napoleon actually
however it does cover consequence it
does come at some cost whites Knight can
move out the way now for example White
Snake can come and capture a pawn black
queen would suddenly be attacked
interesting committal from Napoleon
actually I'm very surprised I must admit
by this last move uh White could also
capture this Pawn maybe attacking the
black queen black doesn't have time to
take the White Knight because the queen
would drop off I think the idea from
Napoleon actually is to slide the queen
across and say that yes you've won a
pawn but you've opened up this line for
my queen and Rook so once the White
Knight jumps back away then Queen takes
ball and suddenly if Black's Brooks ever
get active black wins on the spot wow uh
if Black's Rook ever finds an open Line
uh especially if there's a queen trade I
think black's the material advantage is
just overwhelming so you set it for some
time this white knight for Magnus that
is his hope his star piece basically yep
it's holding everything together at the
moment it's controlling a lot of squares
the black Brooks want to use and it's
also just plugging uh it's kind of
blocking The Black Queen from Ever
Getting anywhere active so Magnus can
take Capone for example but he's got to
be careful that he doesn't let the black
queen and Rooks into the game yeah oh
it's your teeth so I I must admit I
don't necessarily like this idea of
playing Knight takes Pawn I feel like
it's kind of losing losing the kind of
The View on the goal at the minute
because you're kind of taking a step in
the wrong direction
um maybe what about the plan of just
lifting
well actually there's a problem right
you can't just lift up your rook and
introduce it into the attack because Mac
actually has a concrete threat you know
of actually pushing forward and
releasing the light squared Bishop yeah
absolutely wants to push the C pawn and
open up his own light Square Bishop
trade off those Bishops if possible I'm
not sure it's a threat right now but if
the white Rook were to lift itself up
then maybe black would go for it yeah
um okay
so how else to I mean okay what about if
the bishop actually moves the diagonal
that you wanted to play a long time ago
yeah so White's Bishop can try and align
itself towards the black king
I don't know I don't know if there's
actually any threats there behind
White's pack no I think white should if
he wanted to play that he should have
gone for it last move White's Rook
sliding across one square the only
justification is a night jump to attack
the black queen with that white Rook but
uh
it just feels loud if white switches to
the other plan of moving the bishop into
the center it's inconsistent and he's
lost a move with which he could have
used to attack
and uh
yeah I think we'll see Magnus take a
pawn I'm not sure which Pawn but
I think we will don't see any
alternative maybe Ivanka I've just
potentially spotted an idea that might
win a pawn for Magnus and stop the black
queen and getting into the position so
for example if Magnus takes this Pawn
with his Knight attacking the queen
I have mentioned the queen could slide
across but there's no immediate threat
for black because for example if I shift
my Rook up one square just defending
this Pawn which was a target for the
black queen then black cannot take this
Knight now the queen would be hanging to
the white bishop and obviously that
would not be materially good enough for
black so maybe white could just lift his
Rook up one square defend and if the
black queen ever moves away from the eye
line of that white Bishop now the White
Knight could go back where it came from
and you have defended your pawn and
actually you've won an important point
in that little uh in that little
variation so maybe it's not clear but
maybe Magnus can grab one of these two
pawns safely as Ivanka mentioned it's in
the wrong direction it's not ideal that
you have to lose a bit of time you won't
be going for checkmate anymore but
if there are no other options Being
Greedy is maybe the last solution yeah I
mean you might get there by process of
elimination you know like okay The Rook
lift doesn't quite work maybe the bishop
relocating to the center also doesn't
threaten too much so okay grab the
material and then try to hold hold on
yeah for example if White's Bishop does
come in as you mentioned maybe black can
just played Vortex Pawn Yeah we go for
checkmate and black and just block it
and uh I don't think any sacrifices work
because Black's Queen is ready to slide
across and defend her King
yeah are you getting it all worried
about magnus's clock
uh uh I've been in far worse situations
so I'm not worried I've also played
Magnus countless times at Blitz and he's
he sees things super fast but if he
ticks down below half an hour on this
move and still hasn't made a decision
then maybe okay normally you want to
have at least 15 20 minutes for the last
10 moves before the time control I never
have it but uh experienced players they
do a portion their time correctly
normally Magnus is very rarely in time
travel actually in time pressure oh
that's true it's uh you seldom see it in
classical chess in Long games he's
normally the quicker one yeah that's why
this matchup is so dangerous for him
maybe against the pony actually because
he won't be allowed too many moments to
rest yes uh we've seen that actually
and uh okay
anything else
anything else that's possible for Magnus
because we see him thinking very hard
and he moved 23. it's going to be move
24 about to make his 24th move yeah
um critical moment still another that's
incredibly critical I mean is Magnus now
dependent on inaccuracies also from Jana
pomniacci sort of to get back in the
game yeah maybe he can hold a draw even
if an apology is relatively accurate but
if Magnus ever wants to win he is pretty
much dependent now I think on a huge
mistake from the ponyachi wow so it does
feel like this is a game for two results
at the moment uh Magnus just fighting to
save it and probably actually trying to
push
it's uh either way the evaluation bar
less optimistic about Black's position
than it used to be so maybe this last
move this bishop Retreat into the corner
by napong actually on the last turn
I if somehow it feels a bit wrong to me
instinctively like putting his Bishop in
the corner there but uh yeah still not
easy for the Norwegian now yeah look at
him deep okay oh maybe he was going to
make a move he kind of half smile to
herself took a sip of water then settled
back into the position maybe he knows I
mean obviously he's aware the whole
world is watching maybe he knows as well
that it's difficult for him now
okay but there is definitely a little
smile on his face isn't there what is
that about Magnus Carlsen I'm not sure
about Magnus but when I smile it's
because I'm just thinking ah what's you
know my life
it's all gone wrong no no you wouldn't
be thinking no when I'm smiling it's
always because I think okay well that
part didn't go so well why not enjoy the
challenge yeah always look on the bright
side of life it's good to be an optimist
and that's actually something that Jana
pomniacci has he's an incredible
optimist about his uh confidence about
his play so uh yeah I mean it's why he
he's able to play so quickly because he
has tremendous faith in his abilities
and the same goat with Magnus actually
yeah I do remember actually uh I can't I
shouldn't name who said this but I do
remember someone telling me they uh they
were discussing upon me actually they
just lost an upon actually in the
tournament and they said ah that guy
he's so optimistic uh he thinks he was
winning and then I turned the board
around and showed him the same position
he still thought he was winning
always thinks he's winning and he said
that they had a chat after the game and
he was kind of disparaging towards his
thoughts Napoleon actually always
thought he knew better and most of the
time he does
but optimism helps you in chess you've
always got to be positive Magnus here
despite the fact he's material down
he'll be thinking I have this amazing
night maybe I can still win the game
maybe I can attack the black king gotta
look
kind of glass half full type of
philosophy and Jan has also been
described as a very emotional person and
emotional chess player do you think that
is why he's decided today to always
leave the board
to calm down his motion yeah could that
be a strategy from him well I mean I'm
also very curious to see like what kind
of psychological advice he's been given
because these matches are very grueling
and very intense and of course he's as
much we have a moment yep there are
magnets
moose
Bishop to the center of the board so
this plan we've touched upon it it felt
slow though it felt more effective on
the last move
okay he didn't look too happy about that
one it looked like it was a reluctant
move and the evaluation bar not
approving yes we thought it was a little
bit slow and we didn't necessarily see
that the attack was so dangerous that
because black could call me defend along
the seventh row so what is the point
behind this move why he wants to attack
she wants to scan upon me actually but
it might be a bluff it feels like he's
hoping they'll probably actually see
some ghosts because we didn't see any
direct way towards the black king we've
got to do a deep dive now you know
because you mentioned the move Pawn
takes born here you think so White's
Bishop now has landed in the center of
the board attacking towards the black
king and I mentioned this move portex
Pawn very logical opening up the black
rook and uh remember two Rooks are
better than one so Plex Rooks once they
get active we'll win the game and now
what is Magnus considering if he brings
his Queen to threaten Checkmate actually
Checkmate in one move teaming up with
the bishop then uh then Napoleon
actually can simply block with his pawn
and for example if we were to see a
sacrifice this is a very typical
thematic idea sacrificing a bishop to
open up and uh the king's shelter to get
towards the black king it looks like
you'll deliver a lot of tracks but but I
think those checks will dry up black for
example can slide the queen across maybe
magnus's idea is that he can take
another pawn and then once the checks do
eventually finish maybe now he's going
to lift his Rook up swing it across okay
trying to get towards the black king
maybe maybe this is what he's trying to
do Magnus Carson I think we've stumbled
across the idea I'm not sure whether it
works or not it feels unlikely that it
should work but uh it's definitely
possible so right now can black play
Pawn tech support that is the question
or is magnus's attack when he brings the
queen into the game is it just too scary
yeah I mean okay because Suddenly It's
all forcing Checkmate is threatened and
uh black if he pushes this Pawn for
example to try and stop the queen then
the White Queen will snake in using this
diagonal and actually it's going to end
up in Checkmate maybe on this Square
scary times so yeah that definitely you
don't want to be pushing that age Pawn
you know we're big fans of Harry but not
here
um if you're going to defend against
that checkmating idea you have to push
the G Pawn or you have to give up
material so let's assume it's the g-pawn
push it Forward okay so Bishop takes on
and now we're not obliged to take this
we can be we can be cool about this
whole position again no we don't
necessarily need to take it exactly so
we have one spare move here so we can
move the queen across just to I don't
know
exactly and uh or we could have another
move
like maybe
yeah maybe you could consider taking
this poor exactly oh sorry uh you could
also consider pushing this guy forward
creating a threat maybe with this bishop
exactly yeah into the position
uh this bishop could jump in attacking
the White Queen attacking the white Rook
but that kind of feels complete chaos
actually
wow maybe white can argue that the
Knight might jump back but then
it's a queen but then there's ideas like
taking the bishop this one is just wild
I think even if I were calculating here
for 20 minutes it would be difficult to
get to the root of the position but
maybe this is magnus's idea he decided
there was no other option he needed to
be very direct create these ideas and
they'll probably actually once he does
get back to the board we'll have to go
into calculation mode Napoleon actually
cannot afford to play a move quickly
right now Magnus upping the stakes even
further they're already high for Magnus
is pushing them Sky High right now
um he's going all in as Simon says it's
the poker game he's put all his chips in
the center he's saying okay I don't care
you can take as many pawns as you want
you can go as many points up on the
board as you want I'm going for your
king
and uh chat mate doesn't end up again so
if Magnus can get to that black king
it's like tal says right you've got to
lead your opponent into a deep dark
Forest where two and two makes five oh
well yeah there definitely is drama in
Dubai in game two in the world
championship match you guys Magnus
Carlsen the reigning world champion is
in trouble against his
isn't even here yeah struggling to
understand four minutes into his move
I'm just wondering uh people say I mean
I've learned this over the last year
being in the commentary Booth is easier
because you just relax you see the board
you're not biased you can kind of throw
away your emotions maybe Napoleon
actually is trying to adopt that same
approach you mentioned he's an emotional
player maybe he's just sitting there in
his armchair maybe there's a screen with
the position on the board and there
definitely is a screen yes right yeah so
maybe he's just sitting there thinking
okay I don't want Magnus right in front
of me that's distracting I don't want
the glass uh the glass box there I just
want to sit look at the screen and work
things out and then when he sort of
decided then he'll walk out and make it
yeah maybe I mean I nearly never seen
this strategy adopted by any top player
I was going to ask I mean there's been a
bunch of strategies probably in World
Championship matches historically
just maybe a new one yeah new to me and
it's not what he did yesterday remember
yesterday he was away from the board
sometimes but he would immediately come
back when Magnus made a move today
complete opposite yeah no sorry when he
talked about like like I had suddenly
had flashbacks to this
1971 between karpov and coach now and
the strategies that they employed and I
was like because they were hypnotic I
mean this was like a different level you
know hypnotist in the front row
thugs being employed to sit in there to
sit in the audience in this in the
theater just to intimidate the hypnotist
and also the player no I mean this is a
completely different level but um I mean
I hope they asked him about this in the
press conference later yeah I I hope so
too and uh I'm just checking the tweets
you know and everyone I mean it's
everyone seems to be like half mind you
know some people saying porn takes porn
will definitely happen others are saying
no no it's too scary the queen will move
uh Napoleon will take some defensive
resources because White's attack does
look very dangerous and as always you
can tweet us your move suggestions your
thoughts by using the hashtag c24 live
and don't forget we also want to see
your selfies where you're watching the
position from and
okay now where's nepomach is not there
yeah it's been six and a half minutes
now I think he's yeah I mean he's spent
now one hour 20 minutes since the game
began but probably half of that's been
away from the book yeah
wow a strange strategy from the Russian
in the second game here in the match but
it seems to be working because the
situation is looking good for him on the
board yeah I mean I'm kind of curious is
there a screen where he can uh yeah
definitely as watch look at the board
yep do you think this is getting on
magnus's nerves do you think he's
getting frustrated that he could never
actually look at his opponent read any
kind of tells read any signs from his
facial expressions
I mean Magnus now getting up and going
as well we've seen this picture of
nobody at the board going on today oh no
do you think this is going to set a
trend you know though each side just
goes back to the board to make a move
and then empty chairs and can you
imagine how strange is this the
intensity of looking at
no one and the chess board it's it's so
strange and it's so intense and dramatic
yeah and remember the glasses there that
uh where the audience can see the
players but they can't see the audience
but imagine they must know there's
hundreds of people behind this pane of
glass
staring at them and maybe both players
are just cracking under the pressure
cracking under the scrutiny wow yeah
yeah she's cook is ticking almost eight
minutes into this move and he is not at
the board but the situation is looking
good for him we do like seeing faces
though so we're going to take a look at
a few of your selfies right now
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah thanks for bringing us those faces
on the screen everyone keeps on coming
on hashtag c24 live one player has now
arrived at the board and bayana
palmyachi is in the move
been thinking for now 11 minutes but at
least he's here now yeah at least he's
here and he's got a lot of work to do at
the board it's a lot to calculate we
show some of those scary attack lines
that white was aiming for that Magnus
wants to initiate and here comes the
move here comes the movement whoa this
was not on my radar at all he's just
given up a pawn
for free uh what is the idea behind that
one
is that an error is that the blunder
Magnus Carl's needs possibly I'm not
sure whether it's a blunder maybe
there's a deep idea behind it but it's
mysterious white can just take this Pawn
for free and what has black gained
I don't see it and we see the board that
it's the correct move but that is
neither defensive we were talking about
maybe just pushing a point in front of
the black king to stop White's Queen
entry into position so that's neither
defensive doesn't stop that it's not
aggressive either it doesn't open up the
black Rooks
if it surprises you this much it must be
surprising to Magnus as well and force
him yeah look at Magnus he's half
writing down the move which is
obligatory after your opponent's moved
but he's still got his pen in his hand
he's trying to figure out what the point
is I don't either I must admit should he
just take it
I think taking it is an automatic if you
I mean if there are no other options but
there is another tempting option White
Queen could jump into the game and try
threatening Checkmate as we mentioned so
I think we'll see Mike just take that
pawn but he'll spend two or three
minutes figuring out the idea behind
that last move wow it is uh dramatic
yeah in the game in Dubai and it's
dramatic for minus calls and end the
move let's head down to Tanya who is
close to both the players and of course
the teams around the players Tanya
Kaya everyone's as surprised as you guys
in the studio about that last move by
Jana premierchina I'm at a very special
spot in the Exhibition Center this is
level one and we do have the chess 24
Lounge here that's actually where team
Magnus is uh everyone who's supporting
him his family his friends and I want to
take you guys in come on in
and this is how it is we see here by the
way that's us at the back a very
critical moment a tensed moment in the
game and we can feel that in this room
right now on my right we can see
magnus's family magnus's dad there
Henrik Olson on the left
and if you just turn around here we see
that there's a lot of discussion going
on on the position uh nobody show what's
going on what was Yan's idea
with that last move it looked like
Magnus was in a bit of trouble Alejandra
critical moment in the game uh has that
just changed with C3
apparently I mean that's such a crazy
move how did you even come up with it I
was looking at the position with very
strong players here we didn't even
consider the move C3 it's just wild I
kind of understand that in some
variations you want to take on C3 take
on A4 and in this line is okay this Rook
is open and there were some mating ideas
down the line when the bishop
disappeared and there was C5 but that
might be a little bit too deep I don't
know I don't get the move entirely we're
gonna have to wait and see and what do
you make of the players when you see
them on the screen what's going on with
them you see nepo coming in playing
relatively quickly and leaving this is
his comfort zone it's a mess he just
says I'm gonna make a decision I don't
have to calculate every single line
let's let Magnus think and you can see
the clock ticking yeah 30 minutes but
it's a lot of moves to make in a complex
position Magnus looks a little stressed
right now I would be too
wow and yeah that's that's what's going
on this is the Magnus here this is the
chest 24 launch guys this match is
getting hot back to you guys
thank you so much Tanya and for bringing
us the tenseness and maybe the
nervousness from inside that lounge with
a lot of people around Magnus Carlsen
you can almost sense that they are
feeling a little bit nervous but maybe
optimistic after the strange boom Bion
yeah maybe relieved uh it looked like
half the people in that Lounge were
trying to figure out what the idea
behind that movie is we're still trying
to figure it out but also half were just
nervously silently watching the games
and uh maybe just channeling some of the
thoughts that are going through magnus's
head right now as well could this kind
of move be one of those that kind of
disconcerts your opponent because after
all it's so unexpected and you're
thinking okay I understand the point
behind it because as Alejandro Ramirez
pointed out you know you get a past Pawn
along the A-line
but
you know what else what else I I don't
know yeah and maybe we can just show
what Alejandro was talking about there
because black has just given up a Pawn
on the Square if Magnus plays the most
automatic the most natural move and just
captures this Pawn uh you're talking
about a passport on the A-line Ivanka
this guy is only three squares away from
promoting so black also has created an
open file for his Rook there is some
justification for this temporary porn
sacrifice therefore by Napoleon actually
but at the very minimum the first move
that comes to my mind is the White Queen
sliding back across towards this side
and it's a double attack the White Queen
eyes up this Pawn but more importantly
she teams up with her Bishop to eye up
this Pawn near the black king and I
think black's King now is actually under
heavy fire black has to be a bit careful
you need to push the right Pawn you need
to I think block The Bishop's diagonal
uh you need to block the scope of this
piece in the middle but now Magnus can
just capture this pawn and yes he has
one Open Line for his Rook but what else
I don't see the benefits or enough
benefits behind the ponyachi's idea for
example there are also traps if the
black Rook tries to infiltrate into the
white Camp eyeing up this Pawn teaming
up with his colleague then suddenly the
White Knight could drop back and it's
another double attack by Magnus uh the
white Rook attacks the black queen and
the White Knight attacks this black Rook
note as well that the White Queen
protects her rook and this all works out
I think in White's favor and uh what
else can Magnus be thinking about maybe
he's still trying to figure out whether
he can go on the attack with the White
Queen I'm not sure this will work now
because for example if the White Queen
does leap forward if we do see the
variation we actually showed earlier for
example some crazy sacrifices we might
see on trade and uh as soon as the white
Rook lifts up the board there will be
some problems maybe this black pawn will
start promoting in some lines there's
still a lot of details to work out
that's why Magnus is uh thinking right
now he's still maybe trying to go for
checkmating ideas against the black king
but it feels like if black is actually
it they shouldn't work out and Black's
Pawn here is just too dangerous so
eliminate it move on and think again I
think that's the tip for Magnus they'll
probably actually meanwhile he will be
happy that his last move pushing this
Pawn forward giving up a pawn has at
least forced Magnus to invest seven
minutes and at this point with 15 moves
to make before move 40 that is getting
critical now yeah and uh they're very
key moves as well I was just thinking
something could this kind of move also
be based on a miscalculation because we
do know that Napoleon actually has spent
a lot of time away from the board and uh
we're speculating that maybe he's been
looking at the position from a screen
and so he's kind of just calculated in
that and maybe he's kind of forgotten
that that sometimes you need to be
present at the board to kind of gauge
sense things yeah exactly and whether
it's actually a really good move it's
like that feeling that feeling you get
when you hold on to Wood and uh and I
just wanted to share with you a really
interesting piece of information that
someone has shared with us on Twitter
it's Pi underscore oth who says actually
spasky and actually spaski use the same
strategy against quartzner in 1968 in
their candidates finals in Yugoslavia he
would spend most of his time in his
restroom thinking and by only watching
the demonstration board
aha interesting interesting so I didn't
quite realize that this this Behavior
could have some president yeah so maybe
Napoleon actually inspired by his fellow
Russian spassky former world champion
there and uh yeah maybe he read about it
maybe he thought oh why not adopt this
why not try and get in the mind of
Magnus and play some of these
psychological games
um yeah I mean the one thing that
surprises me is that if Napoleon
actually is watching virus screen or a
demonstration board
screens they're always shown from the
white side but here's the black pieces
so he would be looking at the position
from magnus's point of view and that can
be a bit of a you know it can mess up
your mind it can skew things
um if I look at the white white side of
my own position if I'm playing Black
then suddenly it's like is this even the
same game so uh yeah it can be confusing
here to though see or uh the white
players sort of plans maybe then yeah
but for an optimistic player like
Napoleon actually he's always looking
from his point of view he always thinks
he's doing well so if he looks at it
from the white side
I don't know uh it's kind of clear who
that favorite but we have a move um the
queen now slides two squares across so
there is a threat in the position to
actually go Bishop takes Pawn yeah and
by Bishop petite born we mean the H sir
oh yes
um yeah a threat towards the black king
this one I mentioned this idea earlier
but not in this exact position teaming
up with the queen of Bishop do you think
he needs to defend it Ivanka can black
get greedy and ignore it if he takes
this Pawn wants to go away from
promotion
right I need to I need to give a
considered answer here because this is
complicated stuff so do or die time
exactly so Pawn takes porn calm Bishop
takes born check King has to move and
now what's White's going to
play because you know if that Queen gets
anywhere close to the black king then
it's kind of dead if the queen can
somehow sneak across and then back and
Target the black king it does take two
or three moves though uh for example you
could even just drop your Bishop back
one square and then try and Slide the
queen back where she came from and try
to Target this black king this black
king is naked it has no Defenders no
protection but if you're not quick
enough then black might even just make a
new Queen and win so uh it does feel too
scary to allow this for the pony
actually if Magnus played an idea like
this against me I would trust him I
would not allow my king to be opened up
like this but the opponent actually can
consider this idea maybe uh if he wants
to play safe then he'll just block this
diagonal he'll block the queen of
Bishop's diagonal towards his King with
another pawn and I guess magnus's idea
is to capture this guy but with which
piece that's the question with queen or
with pawn and uh there are pros and cons
for both
is backed by the board and we know that
usually means he's going to make a quick
move Let's uh go back to him yeah
he's calculating look at his eyes
darting across both sides of the board
there he's working out some variations
if players are planning making long-term
plans they normally lean back and here
comes the move yep it's going to be a
pawn push I think he's going to push the
point in front of his King there we go
that's the most safe defensive move so
he didn't get carried away calculating
any scary kind of risky lines he just
plays the safest move available
the Barry X and Yana pomyachi he is
still sitting at the board this time
okay
yeah in terms of the last couple of
hours right it is the first but uh okay
I think he needed to be by the board
because again I do feel that you need to
be present at the board to get nope nope
he's off okay he is off Magnus Carl's
now thinking about this move let's head
back down to the good night and Simon
what do you think about this strategy
that janapomniachi is using today just
never staying by the board
I'm I think it's like one of the things
he does quite often I mean it's a sign
maybe a nurse but if you sit at the
board you maybe think a little bit too
much by getting up you sort of stretch
out a little bit and relieve that
tension
um it's a very interesting situation
going on if we take a very quick look it
looked like Yan was doing very well but
he played this peculiar move which he
pointed out in the studio pushing the
pawn here and I think that was you know
giving Magna some chances magnus's Queen
has swung over going for the attack
there over on Black's King and then Yan
I'm gonna do a Yan now Yan does this and
then he's
foreign
do you like that little move there I
thought that was quite cool uh don't get
me to that again later
um but what do you guys think about the
position that's going on with so we have
uh we have odd Bjorn again and his
friend here have been following the game
throughout and uh it looks to me that uh
well
um that basically
uh nepo was doing very well but now it's
maybe turning around a little bit do you
have any thoughts on how it's going
two complex uh situation for my
apartheid is simply cannot uh
analyze it and give anything useful yeah
but it's a very sharp situation and it
seems like this is a very exciting game
I mean uh opioid you do you think uh
Magnus will do the job here I mean it's
all over the place this game much more
exciting than maybe the first game even
more exciting than our game uh I would
take on Gia G6 in a heartbeat here but
uh that's that's why you're sitting
there and that's why they're sitting
over there okay let's get away from what
Beyond good suggestion mate okay and you
guys um you're obviously been following
the game uh greatly today sorry Bjorn
and uh how do you think it's going at
the moment I mean do you like Magnus
chances or do you think uh first opinion
let's say Magnus or nepo who do you
think is going to win
I think Magnus is going to win uh for
sure but uh
he has to keep his nerves yeah sure and
uh what about you sir do you think it's
going to be Yan or Magnus
uh I'm hoping for Magnus I mean it's
going between zero and about one for
nepo so yeah it looks kind of dangerous
dangerous situation brilliant well look
we we have a lot more moves coming in so
we need to go back to the studio and
keep up with the moves but you can tell
the tension here is mounting greatly uh
but luckily there is beer for these
people to calm their nose so that's a
very good thing back to you in the
studio there I bet you're a little bit
jealous yeah yeah cheers to everyone not
the good night and everyone at home as
well uh we have more moves coming in you
call them strange moves David yeah a
couple of moves have really confused me
really surprised me I must admit and
another quick move I actually showed
this position earlier on the board but
through a different move order so the
players they've kind of tricked
themselves into going for this position
but I do think both sides were a bit
inaccurate uh we have to jump into the
board just to explain what's happening
we see the moves coming thick and fast
right now
um here Magnus took this Pawn he took it
with his own Pawn I was a bit surprised
I thought the whole idea of bringing his
Queen across was to capture with the
queen that he captured and janapon
actually barely thinking took this Pawn
uh as black and I was surprised because
I thought maybe he had a trick up his
sleeve he could have brought the black
queen across eyeing up this really
important Pawn this Central Pawn is
actually the whole reason that the White
Knight is good it's the anchor for that
white knight and if this black if this
white Pawn drops off the board black is
just winning the only way to protect it
actually is to weaken the white king
white porn would have to push forward
yes creating a nice Pawn structure here
but also creating targets for the black
and I'm not sure whether now or in the
next few moves but black does have the
option of just completely wrenching open
the position opening up lines for the
rook and if you can break down this Pawn
structure black is just in control so
I'm surprised Napoleon actually didn't
at least invest one or two minutes extra
going for this instead he captured a
pawn so after Pawn takes porn sorry in
this position he captured allowing White
Queen to get active and now this idea is
maybe less tempting because if the black
queen does slide across white doesn't
have to weaken his King to protect this
Pawn wyken for example just use the
queen as a protector instead and uh okay
in the current position has Napoleon
actually missed that he can't get his
Rook active uh backward night moves are
the hardest to see in chess and this
looks tempting for black but as I
mentioned earlier the White Knight can
leap backwards uh with a double attack
attacking the Black Brook and attacking
the black queen and this would actually
be very strong for Magnus
what else couldn't upon me actually have
missed because I do feel there was one
golden opportunity for him and he just
passed it by he just raced into this
position but he could have had an even
better one I don't think he saw that
possibility of sliding the queen over to
attack the pawn and uh I think it's
possible to still do it actually yeah I
think it's probably the best bet yeah I
mean it's less powerful now it's it's it
was better on the last turn it's been
coming across attacking this Pawn also
keeping the black king nice and safe
and uh yeah I mean at least now Magnus
has two options which weren't previously
available either the White Queen could
just step up one square defending across
or the white knight if it really really
needs to you can step back defending
this Pawn also covering this key square
that the BlackRock actually wanted to
use as an entry point
so uh okay it's not ideal that you maybe
Retreat a piece but Magnus has more
options than he would have done if
Napoleon actually went for this turn uh
went for this idea on the last move okay
they played for three hours now these
guys in Dubai so I guess it's becoming
night and Dubai now let's check back in
with the rooner who's all around the the
Dubai 2020 Expo what's going on Arena
well I'm here at the Spanish Pavilion I
am literally in the middle of everything
we are standing in the exact position
that we have going on and I'm here with
aafm Kevin pan that means almost an FM
and uh you were just checking out the
game and we were setting it up here we
also have Moyer playing the role of the
queen because uh our big Queen got lost
and you had some idea about what we
could uh what black could play in this
position yeah so
uh black screen isn't aligned with the
Rook so first idea is probably to move
the queen somewhere
um from first instinct I think the
Korean should go to G7 to attack E5 okay
uh so perhaps maybe Korean to G7
so attack E5
yeah
and
probably next
black can look to play like C5 to trade
the bishop off
okay so you want to place
uh it might not work in this position
exactly but it looks like the white
Bishop is very strong on e4 uh controls
a lot of squares right so and the bishop
in front of the pawn does not look very
good so C5 trading the bishop off also
seems like a possible idea that
um Jan can play thank you very much for
that inside
a a FM Kevin Penn uh how does it feel to
be in the middle of everything in this
like chess Mecca
um it's very exciting um yeah this is
like first time I've ever like been an
actual world championship and I this
game itself is really exciting that
we're probably also gonna have a
decisive result it looks like it
especially with the exchange sacrifice
so
yeah I'm really excited to see what
happens in this game thank you very much
and to Kevin Payne and now back to the
studio
thanks uh and Kevin and that expert
analysis saying that this will probably
end up with a winner and I do love
seeing that huge chessboard a tip for
everyone at home go to a park and find a
chessboard like that A big one and play
Blitz chess I've seen that in action and
that was so much fun janapo miyachi is
still now thinking about his next move
in this dramatic position do you agree
with Kevin yumaka well we see a winner
in this game
ah I'm gonna have to hedge my bed so I
think uh with the Napoleon she's very
daring poor move a bit unexpected I
actually think that maybe Magnus can
generate enough play so that he can
maintain the balance and that the
position might just might kind of he has
enough to kind of secure himself a draw
because some of the lines that David
mentioned you know with the queen
sidestepping and the Knight stepping
back I mean they were very very scary
because White's pieces are so active I
mean just take a look at them Black's
Brooks are not mobilized so I think all
three results now are possible before
okay we have the moments coming in okay
what has he played
okay so he's lined up The Rook against
the queen so he's super bold you know we
were predicting that the queen would
kind of move across to the edge and
attack the pawn but no he's just going
Rook against the queen so now the Knight
cannot move to attack the to attack the
queen
but okay
the Knight is pinned you pin a new wind
sometimes but not this time no just pin
and you hold the balance but um
yeah very strange very defensive move
because that Rook was on a nice open
line now it's just staring at its own
queen and a knight which is very well
defended so that black Rook is not
likely to break through past that white
knight anytime soon
struggling to explain that one there was
such a natural idea of just swinging the
queen across in that interview with
rooner it was suggested by the players
as well that queen move so natural
um the black queen is sort of far safer
far more active Square actually on the
other side of the board but the panachi
just stubbornly holding his ground is it
you see you know making this more
complicated than he should
I think so I think he's maybe trying to
be a bit too clever that pawn push we
saw earlier that I was struggling to
explain Alejandro Ramirez was struggling
to explain that pawn push just giving up
upon that that yeah that really felt
like the type of move where
you're just trying to do too much
sometimes you just got to realize you've
done the hard work and you've got a
material advantage just keep things
solid keep things simple but uh I mean I
like the idea behind Napoleon's last
move because uh his earlier move pushing
that pawn because he's got an open line
but it didn't feel necessary I feel like
you could have got more for Less effort
yeah I have I have an explanation as to
why okay I agree with you this looks
like a bit of a strange mysterious Rook
move but it maybe has a one point to it
that you can actually finally release
the light Square Bishop tuck there in
the corner so you know if white is makes
a move a random move then yeah that was
the move that I was actually thinking
about and then you can step forward with
the pawn and uh finally that Bishop has
some life finally for the first time in
the game the bishop is no longer worse
than its counterpart on this long
diagonal and actually these guys are
going to trade off for each other and
the reason actually Black's last movie
was useful bring the Rook across is
because it now defends the queen and uh
the black queen now that it is defended
it also creates some tension here and
white because Magnus is a rook for night
down cannot afford a queen trade I think
a queen trade would be the last thing on
his mind so uh yep in the current
position I don't think white has time
for luxury moves for example the one we
just showed on the board white has to be
careful I think this one is coming next
nearly no matter what
and uh White has one move to prepare an
answer to this Pawn push you maybe have
to move either the queen or the bishop
because one of them or both of them are
going to come under Fire once Black's
Pawn pushes forward I'd be very tempted
here to maybe just Retreat the queen
just to hint at some sacrifices but
maybe now Black's idea is to bring the
queen across in a more favorable uh
favorable position so can you also
centralize the queen and move it two
squares to the right just to kind of
keep control keep an eye on both the
weak pawns and stop the poem well I say
stop but I mean just say hey you're
going to have to sacrifice a little bit
more material to motivate to mobilize
the bishop so for example if the poor
steps forward yeah we might well see a
trade the black Rook will have to put
itself in the corner and then at the
very least where I could gobble up this
Pawn
it may be white has something better
more active for example once you move
the white Rook away from this awkward
pin then at least you have ideas of
rerouting the Knight towards the black
king and uh okay critical moment now
again for Magnus Carson the more I look
at it the more I think okay there's iron
logic there's hard logic behind the pony
actually's last move this is actually a
bit of a threat right now to push this
Pawn forward how is Magnus gonna deal
with it he's going to move his queen or
his Bishop oh he's hesitating again or
is he going to move his Rook across
maybe he can use move his Rook across to
eye up this isolated Pawn in the corner
here
oh it looks like he's made that rug move
he's made a long move with his arm
and a cross move it is that Rook move
and uh yeah rather than move one of the
two pieces that I highlighted earlier he
is getting out of the pin actually
that's just very good strategy this is
one for everyone at home as well if your
opponent creates a pin now the White
Knight can't move because the white Rook
would drop behind it just move the piece
behind move the Rook out of the way and
now this Knight is no longer Frozen it
can move safely no more pin and also
this Pawn about to drop off yeah both
players now have a rook and a queen
lined up that's uh you know I know that
much that is uh good news but there's a
big difference though because the rook
and the queen that Napoleon she has well
sadly they're being stopped in their
tracks by the night that is anchored by
the pawn
star piece exactly it is still very much
the superstar in the position but of
course the white working Queen are
working perfectly together and there is
the question how are you going to defend
the pawn you can't you can't defend this
guy you're gonna have to just let it go
sorry you say that I'm about to burst
into songs
I also ban myself
so if the porn for example does push
forward there is still it has done upon
actually moving quickly now there's
tension between the Queens remember but
also tension between the bishop which
that's not a bishop between this bishop
and me and my arrows uh these Bishops
sorry and uh yeah either the Queen's
will get traded or the Bishops will get
traded maybe even both I'm just
wondering here can Magnus afford to take
this Pawn with this queen it feels a bit
shaky
feels like there might be some trouble
with the white king the white king is
open to some checks later on but at the
moment it looks like maybe everything is
hanging together for white if we do see
a trade of Queens for example and the
trader Bishops then suddenly white is
out of danger white has a phenomenal
Rook we talk about the seventh rank
seventh heaven this is where Rooks wants
to be they have targets uh also the
black king is cut off more importantly
the White Knight is about to jump in
with a deadly check this is an end game
but white is attacking
if anyone's better white is better the
Magnus right so actually I think Magnus
if he can get away with taking this Pawn
he will do okay well will the game be
more Jewish then
or will there still be chances there's
going to be still chances for both sides
okay and he's made a move okay he looks
like he hasn't taken that porn with his
Queen maybe there were some tricks there
maybe there was some downsides and uh
okay instead the White Queen just slides
across two squares this idea you
highlighted earlier Ivanka hanging up
some Pawns
also just heading towards the black king
yeah okay and we've kind of kind of
transposed to the position that uh you
we highlighted and uh okay Magnus going
for complete control and there's one
thing I have to say about Magnus Magnus
loves it when all his pieces are working
and here this is harmony
well basically it's the definition of
Harmony and the only problem is is that
he's actually material down so how is
Napoleon actually going to react to this
he has some candidate moves his Bishop
takes Bishop but of course Bishop is the
most natural it is the most natural but
uh what happens after Knight takes
bishop and uh suddenly the Knight is
threatening a really unpleasant check on
F6 [ __ ] the king and the queen yup if
black isn't careful if black for example
just moves a rook then suddenly there's
a check and a fork a double attack and
white would win so uh yeah really really
difficult moment here for Napoleon
actually he wants to get these Bishops
off the board he wants to trade but
maybe it helps the White Knight improve
itself
so will he maintain the status quo
maintain the tension another move that I
would be very tempted to play at some
point either now or the next turn would
be just to move the king out the way
firstly out of this diagonal but also
later on if the white knight does
reroute itself as we showed earlier it
won't come with check
this will however come at the cost of a
pawn so
um pros and cons there yeah no I mean I
did like that move another move that I
was considering but I feel like it's
just uh
Puff of hot air which is just to just
come down with a rook to the second row
and just say active Rook yep we talked
about the seventh rank for what the
second row for black is the equivalent
yes but I'm not really there's no threat
there's no nothing in there it's just
simply saying Hey look I'm active for
the first time yeah this Rook finally
breathing some fresh air but yeah white
can just take a pawn maybe threaten to
capture this Pawn as well now teaming up
once again with the queen and there's
still the issue of if the bishops come
off and suddenly White's Knight is
hopping into a really powerful Square
despite the computer saying 0.0 this one
might be turning the momentum is on
magnus's side the trend is in his
Direction
it feels like Napoleon actually just
rushed a bit and tried to be too clever
tried to provoke Magnus but he forced
Magnus to find good moves and okay he
just made a move and looked at the
Norwegian looked at the world champion
as if to say what have you got up your
sleeve what have you got in store will
Magnus take with his Knight or will he
take with his queen queen keeps more
control keeps the Knight on a good
square but Knight takes his more
ambitious okay going towards the black
king
so with Magnus taking with a knight is a
signal that he is maybe going for the
win I think so yeah Queen takes
okay it keeps control but it doesn't
threaten anything and it just feels too
slow it feels like you have to be
dynamic here
so uh okay it doesn't mean that it's a
bad move for Magnus taking with the
queen but
if he can't take with the Knight he will
take with the Knight okay well he
doesn't see any downsides we've got to
calculated out right okay here we come
for it okay and he's decided for us he's
taken with the Knight within the night
okay ambitious it is ambitious and uh it
has a deadly threat for not coming to
give check on F6 so okay black has some
choices he can move the queen he can
move the king
um to be one of them definitely so what
happens if we just uh moves the king
okay he has done he has done and he's
tucked it away into the corner hiding in
the corner maybe the king didn't feel
safe on the seventh rank because there
would have been a knight export here
attacking the queen and attacking a
deadly pawn and the king is just too
exposed so uh okay the king hiding out
in the corner very logical this is one
thing I advise everyone to do I've done
it myself many times when you're scared
when you think things are turning
against you just hide in the corner
far away from any night checks as
possible especially when nights exist
especially now the players are ticking
down on the clock you don't want to walk
into any blunders any nasty night Forks
yeah remember they still have to make
nine moves before they get another hour
on the clock Magnus is down to 16
minutes on his clock to make those nine
moves I guess that's not very dramatic
not not yet but the position is still
incredibly sharp very dangerous and it's
not so much time to consider and really
get into the tank and and think about
all those possible variations yeah I
mean if we count this move it's actually
10 moves to make and 16 minutes 10 moves
that's not gonna be easy normally you
want to move two minutes on average per
move right and you have to remember the
players are not getting any increment at
this stage you know what you see on the
clock is what they're getting and I mean
there's some potential downsides that I
can already see with that King tucked in
the corner you know it's a
some check mating patterns and just uh
jumping out at me and if especially if a
rook were to come to the seventh row
yeah so Black's King not entirely safe
whites King feeling much safer right now
it's got an extra Pawn protection in
front of it and uh even if the queens
were traded off that that King there in
the corner is not going to feel safe at
all yeah even if the Queens come off if
Magnus can win a pawn in the process
it's not clear who's better to be honest
who has the advantage
has Magnus grabbed upon that nope it
looks like he's just brought his Knight
back where it came from back to his
dominant post on D6 now now do you think
that Napoleon she will try to repeat
moves the thing is it wouldn't be a
repetition of the position of anchor if
Black's King were to come across because
last time there was a bishop on the
board that white tonight recaptured so
well spotted Magnus definitely not
playing for the draw here I think he's
got ambitious intentions wow yeah that
White Queen is about to grab a pawn as
well I don't think black can save all of
the pawns we talk about isolated pawns
quite a lot but black actually has three
isolated pawns right now on the A-line
in the corner there on the c-line and
the Blackpool on the E6 Square Black's
Queen is currently defending two but it
can't defend three the black queen is
overloaded he's got too many roles to
perform and one of those pawns is about
to drop off if one Pawn drops off
suddenly Magnus earlier he was a lot of
material behind then he's now he's less
and he'll be too much level of material
and White's night is definitely making a
mark against those Rooks right now I
have to ask a question like okay so
Queen and Knight versus queen of Rook
would you go for this kind of trade or
would you prefer two Rooks against
American Knight I'm asking this is
because black does have the possibility
of just like sliding The Rook behind its
own pawn and just
pushing that pawn just in order to make
trades and maybe alleviate some danger
was that a good trade
possibly so I guess you're talking about
the roots going to the A8 Square the
back going behind the a pawn and then
pushing yes I'm not sure I would want to
uh trade Rooks with white but if you
gain a couple of Pawns in the process
tempting yeah very very tempting yeah
look at that face from yarn and probably
Archie well uh this game is uh
chaotic maybe dramatic topsy-turvy yeah
I like that British word spell uh we do
have we have launched uh nft collection
of Magnus carlsen's road to Goat you can
check that out on chesschamps.io start
collecting nfts for Magnus Carlson's
chess career and if this game would end
up with a win for young and pomnia then
that would definitely be a big highlight
in his career and probably that should
be an nft as well but right now David
you're saying it's maybe turning to
magnus's favor feels that way just
looking at the last five or six moves
Magnus is going to be very very happy
now black has brought his Rook forward
the K is he trying to draw this game is
black trying to somehow eliminate that
white knight even if it comes at the
cost of a rook
uh I don't know it feels again like
Napoleon actually just playing Safety
First chess now it's it's a bit
inconsistent earlier who's playing the
most ambitious moves then suddenly he
took his foot off the pedal and suddenly
again I don't know if he's going back to
yeah he's keeping all the pieces on the
board which uh
I'm a bit scared by that to be honest
you know I would be seeking trades and
simplicity but uh yeah Okay so we've got
to be again this is a position where you
need to calculate what are the
consequences of work just capturing the
pawn that's up for grabs on C5 very good
question Ivanka I'm not sure there's
anything wrong with it uh so white right
now can't just take this Pawn for free
it's just it's looking at the Queen the
queen might just say Okay stop staring
at me I'm gonna take you and uh I think
Napoleon actually has maybe a couple of
ideas in mind uh one of them might well
be just to eliminate this Knight
and uh this would come at the customer
Pawn so for example we could see Mass
trades here actually the Queens can stay
on the board yeah if the Queen's come
off I was going to say decent drawing
chances for black because you can for
example just put your rook in front or
maybe even behind this pawn and even if
you're down upon in the end game some
chances to hold but uh
the Queen stay on yes if the Queen stay
on for example Rook takes then I think
white is just gonna win not only does
white have a safer King Black's King is
open on some diagonals but white also
has an extra Pawn so actually if this
isn't his idea what is his idea it can't
be to swap Queens this isn't possible
right now because after a queen trade
there would be another nasty night Fork
another check
white would win the black Rook on the
next turn
what else did the idea be Ivanka I don't
see it Queen takes Pawn just looks like
when the only other thing that I could
see was just to move the Rooks double
the Rooks on the B line and uh must be
this actually to try and come down and
check the check the weight is just the
check
and again it is and uh look how well
protected the white king is behind this
wall of three pawns meanwhile Black's
King very shaky and what's even worse is
that it doesn't even have the prospect
of a safe home in the future either yeah
maybe though just by forcing upon they
actually might be able to hold the draw
here because actually how do you stop
this check swapping off some Rooks
how do you stop the trade here if you
step forward with your king so that that
move doesn't come with check maybe now
Blackman's forced the Queens off the
board checking the white king forcing a
queen trade and even if it comes at the
cost of this Pawn black I think should
be safe here but I have an idea David
okay okay I'm gonna Retreat the Knight
now back and I'm going to attack and now
you have to be very careful where are
you where because if you do not play the
move that you played then I would have a
good old-fashioned Arabian mate on the
board this is what we call an Arabian
Checkmate black here can defend by
bringing the Rook back but if he had put
the wrong Rook on the wrong Square
suddenly Rook takes pawn and this is an
Arabian Checkmate you taught me a lot
about checkmates over the last year
what's the names I didn't know any of
the names I knew the patterns not the
names how many Checkmate Checkmate names
do you think exist I think there's a
[ __ ] Awards okay not so many just
it's actually possible to learn all of
them 35. I think so
maybe maybe 37 actually including wow
Scholars mates and schools oh they count
they count yes ivanka's mate that should
be the next one yeah
that would be awesome well we're always
talking about you know Novelties or even
new opening ideas you guys want to have
an opening named after you uh which is
of course possible now can you see also
new checkmates coming into chess that
that hasn't been you know fully
discovered that one's hard yeah that was
very hard because you have to it has to
be a very common pattern so to speak
that keeps getting repeated and repeated
because yeah you have some checkmates
and you can kind of go yeah it's the
rainbow mate yeah but you know
it's not like a nice one it does sound
nice but you know it's a kind of a one
of a kind yeah it's not one that
everyone can recreate in their games
okay I've had a couple of special
checkmates in my game so then I thought
oh this must be unique and then I I got
told by a friend oh I've seen that
person before plenty of times and then
it's possible for it to be a named a
housemate Howl's mate I wish that's the
dream
uh meanwhile Magnus just debating
whether to go for that variation we just
showed which would be initiated by Queen
takes porn White Queen grabbing that
pawn it did however lead to a position
that's defendable for black I don't
think it's necessarily I any trouble for
weight either but black would be fine so
Magnus will find out a lot about his
intentions on the next turn he could for
example
think about pushing a pawn maybe Simon
Williams's favorite move pushing Harry
the H porn and here he's coming oh no
he's gonna go he's gonna grab the pawn
because he has
he could therefore be headed towards the
variation we just showed which would end
in a draw okay so the pony actually now
will bring his Rook across okay that's
the only plan that we can consider we've
thought about because offering a Trader
Queen doesn't quite work because the
Knight is threatening to give a check on
F7 so the queen has to guard that square
and now we're expecting Napoleon
actually to double the works along the B
line just to simplify the position you
know it's getting very tense there's a
lot of action on the board a lot of
possibilities and the human mind always
seeks simplifications and the move we're
predicted it David
has happened
yep the move has happened and black does
have a threat so bring its Rook down and
uh give it a check and check and Magnus
he is going to oh immediately he's
instantly responded with the King coming
forward and now this is where we had
looked at Queen giving check to the king
offering a trade of Queens forcing them
off the board and we concluded that
it's actually okay White's is okay and
black has also a narrow path to safety
so are we gonna see Queen Jack
okay big moments it is a huge moment and
uh how many moves left I'll just check
the account so white has six moves to
make black has seven moves to make in
your time control
Magnus has 10 minutes with which to do
that I think that's maybe why he didn't
want to take too many risks he's just
happy to see the Queens come off so it's
easier to handle easier to navigate so
the clocks have actually become a factor
for Magnus calls and sort of influencing
his decisions here because he does only
have a little more than one minute on
each move before the time control yeah
he doesn't have doesn't have so much
time and also you don't really want to
take so much committal decisions before
move 40 and especially not in time
travel if there's anything I learned and
I should have really been paying
attention to this was David's advice
okay and we see in the palmyachi getting
ready to make the move
hesitating as well now yeah because it
does require still some calculation
because we looked at one specific line
where black was okay but in actual fact
when you are calculating you should be
looking at more variations yeah I just
think if black misses the opportunity
here to swap Queens he won't get that
chance again so uh yeah I would be
trying desperately to get those Queens
off the board which you can do now
Napoleon actually but he has 18 minutes
it is slightly tempting to keep the
tension to hope that Magnus blund is in
time trouble and keeping the Queens on
maybe increases the chance of a mistake
from either side
you don't think it's going to happen no
I don't think it's going to happen
because when I take a look at the
position of each side's King I'm like
okay Black's King so unsafe too many
holes and uh White's King's safe as
houses so in terms of danger I think
there's only one side that's going to be
feeding it and it's the yam yep and he
must know as well deep down that he has
let some opportunities pass his position
was Far Far More promising about 10
moves ago and when you sense that
momentum all the top players do they
they have a real intuition in terms of
the trend of the game once you sense
that you just want to shut down the game
you just want to take no more do you
think it's actually possible that Magnus
could try to play that in-game for a win
possibly I mean I'm just thinking you
know he goes well you know because I I
did notice from magnus's style is that
he's very good at those transitional
faces you know where he's been losing
and suddenly he's slightly better and
he's got that ability to kind of make
that psychological adjustment and
actually push for the win like yesterday
we saw Yan didn't quite do that and
we've seen that in previous World
Championship matches where Fabiano
carono had a chance to push or put
Magnus a little bit under pressure but
they were both satisfied with drawers
yeah yesterday Jan turned things around
on Route 40 but he forced to draw
immediately he didn't even try he didn't
even look for chances
and uh well we see the same today and
you asked about the end game Ivanka
maybe we can check it out just to
predict what happens once more just in
case the
he hasn't gone for it he hasn't gone for
it oh okay well roll the dice things are
getting spicy he's playing for the wind
upon me actually if he had traded Queens
we said that this end game is likely a
draw white has a knight for a rook but
this Knight is very strong and it should
be sufficient and look at this move wow
Magnus Carson also playing for the win
um we didn't see the queen trade we saw
black keep this Pawn safe he's now
protected by Rook but now Magnus check
this out King march he's marching up the
board with his King he's gone away from
any potential checks so the Queens will
not leave the board whoa who's King is
weaker now this white king out in the
open if the black queen could ever sneak
around there might be some nasty checks
but the black king also vulnerable yeah
I went with the Queens on the board you
want to keep your king safe normally
normally I guess maybe here he thought
the king is safer away from any open
diagonals and also away from the black
Rooks black only has Rooks if black had
a knight here or Bishop this king would
not be safe uh White's king would be too
vulnerable but if it's only Rooks then
the white king is actually safe amongst
its own Pawns
wow Magnus Brave move I like it
personally it shows that well Napoleon
actually wants to win with this last
turn and now Magnus still wants to win
despite only having 10 minutes left oh
wow okay so we were thinking before
these two moves that it could be heading
for a draw what do you think now
do you think it's going to be a long
game well be I think the players both at
this point they would love to reach move
14 they'd love to get an extra hour and
then sit back and relax and reassess but
okay number 40 is still quite a distance
away and upon the actually especially
has six moves to make uh seven moves to
make if you include this one Magnus only
with six moves to make now
tense in Dubai you guys and well uh
hopefully for us it's going to be a long
game it's Saturday what better to do
than follow the drama from Dubai
not just thinking of this position I was
thinking there's so much danger for
napoleonchi and uh okay The Rook attacks
the queen
I was really afraid that if you made a
careless queen move that the white
because suddenly
pushed their Rook a few squares up the
board and suddenly swing across all the
way to attack a Black's King
yeah and uh okay Blacksburg attacking
the White Queen White Queen will step
back it's not clear where there's a
couple of tempting options uh I should
also mention that Magnus Carlson himself
he said there's no one better in the
world at Major peace end games than Jan
naponyachi when there's Queens of Rooks
on the board he said this before the
match he said actually in one of the
interviews during the Champions chess
tour he said when it's just queens and
Rooks Napoli actually is the best in the
world maybe even Superior to Magnus here
it's slightly different there's a knight
and uh also black is the one with the
weaker King normally Napoleon actually
wants to have the safer King but uh
check out Napoleon's Maneuvers later on
I get to see whether magnus's quotes
were Justified yeah I could uh spot a
trick actually if the if it's just uh
doesn't quite necessarily work if white
were sharp but uh the queen could step
back into the center it has done I was
thinking okay well now black can double
the Rooks okay double the Rooks exactly
on this line yeah okay so try trying to
Target this yeah and you can't go Knight
takes work why not oh you can go night
texture oh no no no okay okay
unfortunately no unfortunately not no
the Rooks can uh what I was thinking was
that you can attack the C Paul yeah but
okay
this one almost a pin but not quite I
thought that you were gonna say there
were other traps for example you could
try and take this Knight and hope that
white takes this Pawn so that yes this
is check but you could meet a check with
a check uh check with the counter check
you could push forward and check the
white king which is now very weak and
attack the queen this doesn't work
however because White's Queen can slide
across blocking the check and also the
White Queen could just take this Rook
but some tricks in the air at least the
beginnings of some tricks they're not
quite working yet for black but they
might well later on so yeah which king
is quicker that is the big question if
white gets time however to push the
pawns forward
um so maybe as you mentioned your backup
reroute this white Rook maybe somehow
bring it over towards the black king
then uh definitely Magnus will start to
get excited yeah but the idea my idea is
still kind of valid but not in obviously
okay so he's moved his King I actually
wanted to move my Rook now further down
but I like this kind of Safety First and
this is kind of what you recommend
especially you don't have so much time
on the clock yeah just makes safe simple
moves which avoid any blunders avoid any
potential attacks from the opponent
however if the White Queen moves now uh
it would allow the White Knight to
retreat you don't want to retreat
because of the queen trade but for
example if you can move the queen then
suddenly the White Knight is free and
again if black just kind of slowly
builds up then the White Knight is
within checking distance of the black
king so I'm not sure I 100 like that
move Black's king is not necessarily
safer now where where it's just moved to
than it previously stood but
I think just trying to bide some time
just trying to get to move 40 and
survive what do you think Ivanka is the
white king going to continue Marching
for it no it's finished its Journey it's
just going to chill out on the side here
I think he will leave that possibility
to when the Queens have been traded off
um and uh maybe as you mentioned this
Pawn push if it does happen this would
allow blacks Rooks to stack up and line
up against this Pawn because now there
is a pin here yeah Knight takes Rook
would be met by quintix Queen winning
so uh okay Magnus has to be careful
maybe he doesn't want to commit anything
too much yet he just wants to somehow
get to move 40 but what is it four moves
to make now or five if you include this
one only seven and a half minutes yeah I
would be tempting one and a half minutes
per move very tempted if I were white
just to improve the placing of the rook
and uh just move it along to the fourth
row just so that has the possibility
later oh hang on a second that would
also be a blonde I seem to be blundering
in the fourth hour because you can play
Rook takes Pawn
yeah maybe now you take this one it's
not necessarily clear yeah but I feel
like that favors black Yeah the more
more open lines that appear the better
the Rooks will become so
um okay that's the thing there's so many
tiny tactics it's not like game-winning
uh blunders or anything but there are
small tricks in the air and Magnus now
less than seven minutes to make five
moves if we include this one
okay wow we'll talk about time pressure
the first time we've really seen the
players looking at the clock getting a
bit shaky getting a bit nervy will he
want to avoid okay the move is coming in
forward okay so I guess he wants to meet
any Rook move by just defending his Pawn
maybe with his Rook or maybe now he
could just move the queen out of the way
and uh now the White Knight at least
would defend this Pawn no more pin
well is Magnus sort of trying to delay
the big decisions until move 40. I think
so it feels that way I think if you
offered him now just an extra hour to
think he would happily take it and he
would just sit back and say okay now
I'll look for ways to win this game it's
still with best play maybe should be a
draw but uh it could still go in any
direction if white trades the queen
selects the black Rooks out then black
wins if white is able to get an attack
against the black king white wins so
still all three results possible what do
you think is like sitting there now for
these two players in this game what do
you think it's like I would be terrified
in this kind of situation it's very
common that uh napomanache is got maybe
this tiny voice that he'd probably have
to quiet that says that you threw away
an advantage you had a golden
opportunity and now you have to really
struggle here to even mean hold the
balance meanwhile Magnus having been on
the point of suffering is suddenly
thinking hey life is good I have my
chances again and Napoleon now aligning
the queen and Rook together yeah if you
had to take someone now Ivanka Magnus
Magnus I would take white here every
time as well just because white tonight
is so strong and uh and the bar agrees
with you since we say that yeah because
actually if we think about the material
imbalance here now black is still up but
black has a rook in return for a knight
and a pawn a knight in a pawn with four
a black Rook worth five but earlier on
black had a rook and a pawn just for a
night so black had six white only had
three so actually the material count has
gone in White's favor by two just over
the last dozen or so moves and uh again
it's all about the trend it's not
necessarily a bad situation for black
but if this continues napony actually
will start to get nervous and I think if
actually Magnus makes move 40 now we
will see him take some risks to try and
win later
what a game this is game two in the
world championship match and we're all
ready seeing chaos drama two players
really fighting both of them in fighting
for Wednesday yeah
it's the second day in a room Magnus is
sacrificed and uh yeah we thought he's
the reigning Champion he knows he's well
on paper he's the better player he
wouldn't take too many risks you've just
let his moose do the talking but he's
taking massive risks wow and uh so far
they've been Justified well we have
heard this from Magnus because uh of
course the format for the match has
changed from 12 games previously to now
14 games and Magnus has said that that
invites taking more risk because you
will have another game to get or another
two games this time to sort of strike
back if it goes wrong yeah and uh 14
sourcing my lucky number so yeah I agree
14's always better than 12. yeah
and uh yeah I'm not completely sure what
naponyachi's last move does it does
break the tension between the two queens
that uh was maybe a bit uncomfortable
no threat I think he's just trying to
survive again until 40. maybe now it's
time for
the white Rook to re-maneuver the White
Queen also could maybe take up a
different post
the white king could step back or if
you're feeling brave step forward I did
I'm just uh yeah I feel that uh the
white work could improve itself and also
you know if you want to say pass a few
times you can just shuffle along with
the queen attack a few attack the pawn
on E6 and then ask black to defend it
and then take a decision yeah
so uh we're expecting either a queen
move or a rook move
both of those would be very sensible
here by Carlson but actually he's got
four moves to make now in four minutes
so average one move per minute that's
not easy we know Magnus loves bullet
chess online but that's different that's
uh far from all the pressure and you'll
move your anchor the White Queen comes
across attacking an undefended Pawn
in the center there Black's Pawn on E6
is threatened and that would come with
check as well doubly deadly so it has to
be defended does does this give the
opportunity for yarn to kind of play
Rook takes knight uh actually at that
moment it is a big moment right yeah we
can show this actually because if Yan
wants to just completely obliterate all
the tension he can give back his extra
material he can take White's strong
Knight with his rook and uh this has I
mean this has drawbacks this shows that
Black's just fighting for the draw and
will never win but if he takes this
Knight then suddenly at least the
position is simplified it's Queen and
Rook against Queen and Rook same number
of Pawns
and uh again now it's not clear where
the white king is weaker or not than the
black king maybe if these two pawns
disappear this game would end up in a
draw if the Queen's disappear now it's
definitely a draw so Yan will he Gamble
and
play on or will he just try to take the
safe approach of getting rid of this
strong Knight actually I was just
checking the computer variations and
that is the top choice of the computer
you know just to eliminate the tangent
except except that your black is
slightly worse and defend that position
but still
it does mean that Magnus is in the
driving seat if you do manage to keep
the the balance of a rook against the
Knight it does mean that there's still
chances for Magnus to go wrong and if he
does go wrong the Rooks will be superior
to the Rooker Knight
so surprised Magnus allowed this
opportunity or do you think just before
move 40 he's thinking okay let's just
play safe uh I think he was just
thinking the clock is ticking let's play
safe
um if I because he could have put his
Queen on a different Square he could
have just moved his rook and it's not
clear what Napoleon actually is actually
doing next he could have got some before
tea and then decided whether to allow
this trade but one thing I have noticed
about napometri is he has consistently
refused the offer of simplifications
he's had that chance many moves ago in
better variation in better forms and he
said no so maybe Magnus is kind of
taking a calculator Gamble and saying
well
I don't think he's going to do it he's
just going to feel like his King is a
little bit too shaky you think he's
definitely going to do it because what
else otherwise you're just in massive
trouble is black yeah I know I mean you
could make an argument for bringing the
queen across to defend this Pawn but
then the queen is passive eternally yeah
I agree stuck and uh you could even
you could even see white at some point
not now but at some point re-routing the
Knight to go for the black king
um you could see why it's Rook somehow
joining the action maybe on the third
Rank and coming into the black into the
heart of the black position
yeah it feels incredibly scary
yeah but at the same time you are kind
of admitting with Rook takes Knight
that you've made a mess of things and
that you're purely defending yeah but uh
I think purely defending is right but it
should be defensible yes and Magnus
there making some faces is he assessing
this as better for white or does he yeah
does he know it will end in a draw hmm
and the move three more moves to go
before they get 60 more minutes on the
clock Magnus less than four minutes on
the clock
just trying to get to that time control
now the world champion Bart is all the
way in the middle in this game
but I'm guessing from you guys Anything
Can Happen definitely anything can still
happen I think the bar will only remain
in the middle though if Napoleon
actually finds this move and takes the
White Knight but as Ivanka mentioned
it's not maybe stylistically his type of
move
and throughout this game he's he's
rejected similar opportunities
so okay interesting moment in the game
I must mention as well I've nearly never
seen napoleonchi around new 40 with less
than 10 minutes on his clock normally he
still has 30 40 minutes sometimes an
hour and he's gone for it he's accepted
that he's worse and uh here we go simply
simplifications but okay now you see him
exhale as well when he made that
decision he made eye contact with Magnus
yeah okay well when you consider the
position that he had earlier on where he
was felt like he could take full charge
and now
just surviving yeah it's all about
survival this is a two result game now
white should never lose and that is
because white has a slightly better Pawn
structure black has two isolated pawns
one on the a file one in the middle
there on the e-file and white only has
one isolated Pawn also Black's King
okay white king not safe either but
Black's King is a bit more Airy uh than
the white king it's easier to get at
that yeah and oh look at Magnus Magnus
okay so he didn't he missed this
opportunity he just forgot about it so I
just have a feeling he'll be so annoyed
at himself for not maintaining the
tension to move 40 at least he could
have allowed this opportunity after move
40 when he had one hour to consider what
to do yeah just feels like a I mean it's
not a bad position objectively because
maybe it was still a draw or maybe it's
still equal but in Practical terms you
want to have some time to mull over any
new kind of Transformations any trades
any captures you can't do that just
before new 40. you think do you think
Magnus was banking or perhaps uh being
able to attack the queen with his pawn
and just get that the C Pawn as far up
the board as possible and then saying
hey this is going to be a great position
possibly not quite realizing that maybe
it's not that fantastic yeah I think he
will attack the black queen either with
that pawn as you mentioned Ivanka or
he'll Slide the white Rook across to
attack the black queen
either way I think the black queen just
needs to move and uh there are a few
safe squares
because it's not 100 clear how he can
capitalize on this move Magnus Carlson
and
as mentioned if the Queen's come off it
should end in a draw I think he's yeah
so the idea is if the black queen takes
that pawn then it loses protection of
both of its pawns on the sixth rank so
White's Queen will go and take a pawn
with chuck on the E6 square and suddenly
the black key would be vulnerable yeah
okay and napometri has to take a
decision with the queen
um I feel like it's a little bit natural
to well it's only one move right to hold
on to both pawns and that's just a block
white block exactly block the sea Pawn
control is uh very very close now
um is this a draw will one the players
keep fighting for a win we're gonna head
quickly down to Tanya in Dubai with one
of the star players in the United Arab
Emirates
all right Sonia is getting ready with I
heard rumors a fantastic uh chessler
himself
okay
um the time control is
getting close
do you think
shortly this will be a draw David I
still think Magnus will push I could
press because there's zero risk now for
white unless there's a massive blunder
or a moment of blindness a moment of
Madness white cannot lose this game for
black it could go wrong black could just
lose those two-week pawns that I
mentioned and Black's King if the White
Queen can start delivering some checks
it could be vulnerable so
um it looks like a two result game it's
going to be a draw or a white win Magnus
will just get to move 40
then who will reassess he'll have a
think and maybe try and put some
pressure on but it does feel like with
best play it should be a draw
thinking about the his next move eight
minutes to go for him that's gonna be
fine but what will he do can he make
mistakes there or is it quite obvious
for him right now
um I wouldn't say it's obvious it's
definitely possible to make mistakes but
there should maybe a few ways to save
this game I'm trying to calculate what
happens if black does actually take this
one because clearly Napoleon actually
just looking at his eyes right now just
judging by his body language he's
looking at ways to take that white porn
with his Queen and if white gets greedy
to take some pawns he's looking at ways
to start checking the white cane from
the front so I have a feeling just
because it's Napoleon actually
and just because he's quite a direct
player he wants to capture that white
pawn and maybe he'll get away with it
maybe
[Music]
my instinct I can see from the Twitter
comments everyone's instinct is actually
just a side step with the queen block
the pawn and just hold the position firm
um capturing the pawn wasn't on my radar
at all felt too shaky
um shaky is right but the problem
actually he's the type of player who
would rather solve his problems
immediately than sit there and suffer so
he's calculating I think if he his
calculations aren't successful if he
thinks the whites do well then he'll
just slide across one square to C6 and
block that white pawn and look him yeah
she's chair kind of shaking indicating
maybe he's you know with his feet uh
shaking a little bit maybe a little bit
nervous right now you know yeah and you
see the chair shaking as well yeah and
uh you can occasionally hear the noises
that the players are making and you can
see the promenity is not very
comfortable and I'm sure at the back of
his head he's thinking about what could
have been and in the situation right now
because there is the issue that if you
do just sidestep with your queen hold
the two pawns that Magnus can kind of
amp up the pressure by moving his Queen
attacking both bones and then still not
easy not easy not easy at all for
foreign
just an update on Tanya was saying that
we would go down to her she made her way
now to the area where she can do
interviews with the players in case this
is shortly a draw
um but hopefully also we'll hear from
Salem Saleh later on but just in case
just so we don't miss those interviews
Tanya is making her way there okay okay
he did take the pawn that's just napony
actually style he doesn't want to sit
and suffer so he's taking that pawn he's
allowed a check the White Queen
recapturing Another Pawn with check
level number of Pawns now and Black's
Pawn over there on A6 is about to drop
off
hey what the black king stepping forward
and now there's a threat in the position
so if you do go Rook takes Pawn or queen
takes porn then black can simplify
things even further by actually giving a
check to the white King on C8 square and
they've gone because the move 40 has
been made yep
typical stuff they did it at the same
time as well we have reached the time
control the players are taking a little
break from their tourism that means that
we can also take a quick break to hear
from our commercial partners
[Applause]
today more than ever when the world
comes together to create a better
tomorrow it's going to be the largest
magic magic with music with architecture
with colors magic with celebration with
your safety From Here There and
Everywhere for six whole months day and
night join the making of a new world
starting October 1st
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
okay so let's send the challenge
ah here is challenging
nice Graphics easy to see
what are you thinking about you're
looking how it can be the most painful
exactly
okay fine fine
he wants to be even rude
[Music]
foreign
Global broadcast for the world
championship match the players have
reached the time control and Dubai
Magnus Crossing is actually back by the
board he has not made a move has he no
yeah not yet all right so we will uh
take a quick trip down to Dubai to Aruna
who is out and about in the 2020 Expo
area what's happening Aruna
and absolutely we have to uh cover the
chess history the other red bearded guy
he went to the pub he was supposed to do
the history of the Chess World Champions
luckily I am here in Dubai I'm in the
Spanish Pavilion and I have some visuals
to help me so it's a historic uh match
today of course it's the world
championship match but we're not where
did uh chess come from it started here
in India it was originally called
chaturanga shafo Shah the king uh and
then this is like 1500 years ago and
then it spread to Persia
and from Persia in around the year 600
we saw a great great expansion and the
Persian Empire spread across most most
of the known world at that time so it
went to Egypt Morocco 700 and the 800
and then the Persian Empire conquered
Spain and that is quite interesting so
they brought a lot of their science
their mathematics and they brought chess
to Spain so here we are talking 18 uh
825 to 1475.
and from here chess was developed quite
a bit and chess was uh the biggest place
uh Spain was the biggest place for chess
in the world and if you just come along
with me here I have something
interesting to tell you because at this
point they started developing chess
Theory we see here uh the first chess
book it's just called the book of Chess
It Was Written in
1283 so we are con continuing a
tradition that has been going on for a
long long time
now here this is interesting this is
about the first game that was played in
this world championship match because it
was the Spanish opening where in the
Spanish Pavilion the Spanish opening is
also known as the rui Lopez and that is
because of this guy he was the
Archbishop the Royal Archbishop of Spain
he was the best chess player in the
world and he in I think 1535 he wrote a
book about this particular chess opening
so when Magnus and the under punishi
sits down and plays the Royal Lopez they
are continuing a tradition that has been
going on for about
500 years which is pretty incredible and
you can see of course chess history
develops and we have more we have viewed
it here you did of course the best
female chess player of all time also
she's sitting in the back here where
she's commentating and that is most of
uh chess history of till now and thank
you for tuning in now back to the studio
I'm so glad you're taking care of the
history now that the other bearded guy
is down at the good night thanks so much
for doing that all right and Chassis
Street maybe in the making here we have
two moves on the board we have a couple
of moves since the time control was made
the players they had their break they
got refreshed they came back and the
first move was Magnus grabbing a pawn
maybe we can show this but they probably
actually did react instantly and uh in
this position there's nothing else to do
for white You could argue for giving a
check but the black king just hides in
the corner so Magnus grabbed his Pawn
he's actually a pawn up he's up material
for the first time in the game but
Napoleon actually just slid the black
Rook across and suddenly the black Rook
is able to defend his King uh the black
Rook if needed can guard the seventh
Rank and the white king is now the more
vulnerable of the two and you can see
there by magnus's Body Language he's not
overly optimistic this Pawn was attacked
by the queen and by The Rook notice how
you can't give a check with your Rook as
white because actually that square is
covered
so Magnus therefore pushed his Pawn
forward and here there might be a couple
of moves for black but the most
straightforward if he just wants to make
a draw it is to just get the Queens off
the board he can bring his Queen across
with a check
looks like he's done that and once the
quids disappear then black should be
able to hold this this is quite
Elementary stuff three versus two on one
side of the board it's not enough to
create a past Pawn for white notice how
all of these pawns and anytime they
match forward will just be traded so
this end game Magnus can play Forever
you can play for 100 moves if he wants
he can play for 10 moves if he wants but
it should end in a draw these three
can't beat these two yeah and I suspect
that the game will finish
quite shortly actually let's go back to
the players yeah definitely go back to
play it's a repetition or an offer of a
draw I think it might be an offer of a
draw actually we rarely see that
actually very often repetitions is going
to be interesting to see well then
Magnus be the one offering the draw yeah
if it is I would I would be very shocked
if Magnus offered a draw I'd be
surprised if either side off for the
draw I think it's going to end a
repetition because it's Pride it's Pride
you don't want to be the first one to
offer a draw in the world championship
match but it might be one of those
things where you just make eye contact
with your opponent and go like this and
Magnus could already have forced to draw
if you wanted to just by continuously
checking with the white Rook but he's
playing on just for a little while he's
brought his King forward
and uh yeah no great progress to be made
there black just Waits no how the black
Rook actually cuts off the white king
from advancing further up the board good
strategy I'm going to be so eager to
hear from the players after this game
what a dramatic game ups and downs were
both of them yeah yeah massive ups and
downs yeah maybe especially for Magnus
he must have known he was in trouble and
suddenly he was in the driver's seat
sadly it was equal again yeah I have to
say it's been a thrilling encounter so
far you know first of all it looked like
Magnus was going to be in the driving
seat as you say David and then
then Napoleon she turned it around in
some big complications and then some
mysterious moves and suddenly Magnus is
the one on top and then suddenly I think
it's kind of a draw feels like a fair
result in some way yeah it's like two
heavyweight boxes Landing punches on
each other but neither side going down
under the pressure
both just standing in their ground and
uh
I think Napoleon actually he will feel
some disappointment if this is a draw
but also some relief that it could have
been worse it could have been a full 360
turn around rather than just saving the
game
and the more that Napoleon actually play
and one the more games that he plays the
more confident he will become and the
kind of more
he will kind of gauge more and more of
magnus's style and where the Magnus is
in good shape or not
yep and black just continuing to wait
with his Rook I think he will continue
this uh forever if he can just waiting
on the fifth rank white pawns at some
point uh some moment will start to run
forward maybe White's Rook can challenge
the fifth rank to try and create a way
in for the white king but either way
let's ignore the evaluation bar for now
it's only up to plus one or almost plus
one because whites are pulling up it's
not because white is winning
and uh yeah this type of end game it's
all about experience if Magnus was
playing a less experienced opponent he
would try and press forever he would be
confident about winning but against a
world-class Elite Grandmaster like
naponiacci
I think no chance what do you think I
think no chance and now here I think
black has to be slightly accurate here
don't trade works I would move my Rook
to the Sabbath just so that I could step
forward with the king and the King can
sit there on the seventh row quite
happily because the kind of scenario you
do not want is you don't want the white
king to go on an adventure anywhere
close to the sixth row if it gets to I'm
thinking of the H6 square if it gets
there then suddenly there might be
serious trouble for Napoleon Ashi yep so
two things to avoid here for black one
is trading Rooks you don't want to go
into a king and porno game pretty much
ever when you're pulling down this Pawn
is actually going to win the game
White's King will slowly March around
and Black's King will have to uh
eventually give way and also as Ivanka
mentioned you don't want to allow your
opponent to take control over some key
squares if the Rook had gone elsewhere
in this position for example if the
Rooker just onto a random square and
White's King could potentially March
forward in into the black half and if
the black king tries to Parry that block
it off then white can give a nasty check
and black king forced to give way and
White's king would creep in so uh yep
and your move Ivanka uh the best
defensive move in this position was to
just cover the seventh Rank and he's
just gonna set up a barricade here a
blockade and white skin whenever it
steps forward will just be blocked and
met by the black king and no more checks
because the black Rook covers the
seventh row next Black and even just
push a ball forward and kick this white
king back where it came from
yeah this one should be headed towards
the drawer Magnus can try pushing his
pawns forward he can try maybe trading
one set of Pawns but the more pawns that
disappear the smaller his chances become
and uh no way around here he can
maneuver forever but it's not going to
change anything yeah and uh one thing
you have to say about uh those extra
pawns you kind of want it to be in the
middle of the board when it comes to
extra pawns what needs to be over in the
middle exactly then they can run and
it's just to do with the fact that the
Rooks don't have great checking distance
actually to the opposing Kings and the
worst type of Pawns to have are actually
those pawns that Magnus has on the H
line and then the second worst are the G
pawns yeah and Pawns in the corner it's
hard to support them exactly and in fact
if you were just to get uh if Magnus
were to get a position would be his king
and the g Pawn on the board
that's it it would be draw as long as
the black king is within touching
distance all the other pawns were traded
yeah no chance no chance of winning the
dream as well for Magnus if he pushes a
pawn for forward for example which it
looked like he was about to do just
judging by his body language uh the
dream is to force black to ruin the
Integrity of his pawns for example if
black ever trades a set of Pawns then
suddenly we see white at least has a
passport with no rival to trade it off
and later it could start marching
forward the problem for Magnus however
is that Napoleon actually will not
acquiesce to that he will never trade
here he will wait for white to do the
trading for example he can just pass and
if white ever takes then now still no
past Pawn anytime this guy marches
forward it's just traded off and uh yeah
as long as black is an inpatient then it
should just be a draw well one
interesting thing here with the very
popular Harry the H porn move actually
hasn't happened in this game at all
either side yeah Simon's going to be
disappointed but maybe now then you say
maybe now Harry is going to come alive
yeah
I wouldn't be surprised if that happens
because there's no other plan
and just judging by his hand movement it
looks like it is
finally every single piece has uh made a
move yeah yesterday
ah yeah okay opposite Harry still asleep
well Harriet
yesterday it was the A1 Rook never moved
today
for age seven porn okay so Magnus has
one idea of pushing forward and at least
forcing the pony actually to make a
decision but I think if Napoleon
actually just sits and waits no Headway
will be made yeah
and what about here
I mean can white kind of try to
intimidate black for instance you know
step forward with the King and uh
threaten to example if the king steps
forward yeah I'm thinking Force black to
move his pawns yeah let's step back and
if black continues to wait now yes the
black pawns do not defend each other so
you might well end up creating a pass
Pawn eventually that's my idea small
gains but at least it's something I'm
just wondering whether Napoleon actually
in the current position as well can
force the issue whether he can deliver a
check it looks risky I don't think I
would consider it too much but uh just
to start going after the white ones
maybe this holds as well yeah maybe
although for example this end game with
white being two pawns up is actually
technically a draw
um if you know the technique it's quite
a simple draw but
realized that even top Grand Masters
they don't necessarily study this type
of position I know that until maybe
three or four years ago I was just too
lazy to study this position I thought ah
I'll never be up two pawns down in a
name game it'll be fine and then one day
it happened on the board next to me and
my teammate lost this type of position
so I was like okay I have to study so
this is this is a draw with two pawns
because they're separated two connected
pawns will be winning for white but
separated pawns here oh okay not
sufficient so maybe he can force the
issue with the draw here but that's like
Last Resort YB two pawns down when you
could be one Ponder and here what would
you recommend as the best of fans for
black just to carry on waiting step
forward with the King yeah I would
probably just step forward and if white
pushes are pulling forward I would be
very tempted to just step this way I
think just to stop waking ever breaking
forward
and it looks like a king move from
napongatchi
it is indeed yes indeed
and uh yeah just planting the King on a
very safe square and as mentioned if the
pawn steps forward black can just try
and
kind of provoke an exchange try and
persuade white to do the trading on his
terms and this Pawn easily holds up
these two guys and uh yeah I'm hoping we
see this game played out to a stalemate
rather than a draw office just to show
the viewers just to show us why it's a
draw but either way
yeah if you don't have past points in
working games even if you're one Pawn up
it's impossible
and okay Magnus does push this guy
Harry's on an adventure yeah but he's
about to uh be neutralized by the other
Harry well by Gary the G4
all right well they keep uh they keep
playing
um are you saying it's definitely a draw
now
90 something percent yeah okay so we're
waiting basically to see if one of them
will offer it or if they can find a move
repetition where is the move repetition
here I mean with with the Pawns of
course that's quite difficult it would
be difficult to get a move repetition I
mean I think what's going to happen is
that they will play on that position
until they reach somewhere where it's
like no chance for Magnus to think even
about winning so and I like David's
suggestion which is just to go into the
corner with the King to the H6 square
and just to prevent the white king from
stepping forward that looks quite
straightforward yeah we should also
maybe mention some chess etiquette just
the way you should behave in a chess
game if you're on the defensive side for
example here in Napoleon actually he's a
pawn down he's got zero chance of
winning this game it's considered not
rude but uh in slightly impolite to
offer a draw you wait for your opponent
who's pressing who's trying to attack
who's trying to win you wait for them to
offer a draw so Napoleon actually I'm
pretty sure he won't be uh proposing any
peace treaty soon he'll just be waiting
and uh magnus's body language shows that
he's
not too confident either so yeah um yeah
it will come down to Magnus whether he
wants to repeat the moves whether he
wants to offer the draw
if he does then the game will end
Napoleon actually won't start that
process and I have to say there's a kind
of Unwritten rule kind of that when you
do offer the draw as if you're the one
who's defending you only offer it once
yeah maximum exactly and if it gets
projected mm-hmm and let your opponent
make the draw offers okay the king does
indeed go towards the white Pawn just
trying to force that trade instructive
uh technique now and uh Magnus go
sidestepping with his King maybe he's
hoping about uh pushing the pawn like
you mentioned Gary yep no rush no rush
to trade
yeah I've played Grand Masters actually
who offered several draws per game and
oh it's the most
annoying disrespectful thing played a
Grandmaster a few years ago I think he
offered me four draws in the course of a
game and the worst thing is that it did
end in a draw but I was always better I
always had the advantage and it was just
at some point he was just kind of like
looking at his watch just kind of
telling me you know and uh if there's
life in a position if there's pieces
I must admit I was once told off by a
Grandmaster for offering a draw you know
this he said I'll offer the draw when I
want the draw I was like okay
and the worst thing is that actually I'm
I was a bishop down it was a queen queen
ending I was a bishop down but I had a
few pawns and the worst thing is that I
survived for a long long time and then I
turned it around so that there were no
more pawns left on the board and I had
the pawns and he had the bishop and then
he offered me a draw and I should have
actually said no yes she's my turn yeah
and I want the draw gonna said you know
it's it's been eight hours I think I
want to have some dinner
I know I know I do regret not saying
that
I haven't played a Blitz game recently
where I was a bit unhappy with my
opponent's behavior and
um yeah when you're off the draw I said
no just a spider so uh
yeah this one will fizzle out eventually
but Magnus is trying and you can tell on
the world champions body language
they're just looking at the score sheet
he's probably just regretting a couple
of decisions he's wondering where could
I have maybe been a bit more accurate
where could I have put more pressure on
my opponent I should actually yelling
actually be the one who sort of regrets
more decisions because you know people
were very worried for minus at a point
here definitely but he's got more to
worry about in this position so he won't
kind of Reminisce he won't look back in
time until this game is saved I think
there's some really instructive moments
for both sides to learn from I mean for
starters I think magnus's opening was a
success so that's something for
Napoleon's team to go and work on and
just improve that a little bit and then
somehow other magnets took a little bit
too much risk yeah and Napoleon actually
was very very resourceful and he managed
to find some good moves and then he kind
of went a little bit creative maybe
miscalculated something and suddenly
Magnus was back in the game it was very
emotional no topsy-turvy game it was a
real it's a real thrilling encounter to
watch and even this you know it's it's
still quite an instructive stage of the
game because now they're showing us
exactly how to defend this type of
position yeah which is actually quite uh
popular and it is not uh rare to find
yourself in this type of ending yeah I
found myself in this type of ending from
the kind of attacking side with extra
pawns and the defensive side with fewer
pawns I found myself in it hundreds of
times in my career so
um yeah I think what I hope the viewers
at home you learn a lot from the same
game despite the fact it should be
headed towards the draw I think the main
thing if you're defending is just stop
your opponents creating past pawns if
you're attacking try and create the
passports yeah our experts here are
saying it's gonna be a draw at some
point let's also head down to to Simon
at the good night in Oslo are the
Norwegian fans giving up hope of a white
victory in this game now
uh hi there everyone in the studio
um I think it's going to end in a draw
and people realize that now uh it's been
such an exciting game though up and down
all the way and maybe we can just do a
little tour just to get a feeling of you
know a little bit of disappointment but
also I think people are quite happy that
uh he hasn't lost this game because at
some point it did look like Yan was
going to get the win so let's just take
a little Wonder shall we and see if we
can annoy anyone with the mic so uh
we're gonna go into the bar here and we
can see that uh people are starting to
leave a little bit still plenty of chess
boards everywhere and we'll go around to
the side here
and the good thing about this even when
the match is over everyone's just
enjoying a lovely game of chess so
um let's just grab someone randomly
um if we can don't know how this is
going to work so draw is it hey is it
gonna be a draw
do you think the game's gonna be a draw
now in the intro oh it is a camera
you're on man
yeah
so are you happy it's going to be a draw
it looks like it's going to be a draw no
no no I mean uh Magnus had some rough
time but I think draw is very good for
her I think he's doing that done a very
good job and hopefully uh you know we
will see what happens in the results and
uh are you having a good time yeah yeah
okay well look man I think that's the
most important thing whatever's
happening everyone's having a great time
here and this is the way that chess
should be loved
um it's not quite time to say good night
from the good night I did have to get
that saying in we could do that later
something could happen but at the moment
we think of drawers gonna get a better
result but whatever happens everyone's
enjoying himself so much here so back to
you guys over the studio and uh let's
see if Magnus can get any blood out of
this Stone I love the pun Simon and the
stunting good job down at the good night
and maybe it's time for you to have that
beer now it's uh maybe going to be a
draw quite soon thanks for thanks for
for joining Simon I I may have had one
beer thank you very much yeah you
deserved it you deserved it and we did
have some moves on the board David we
had a couple of moves and black has
actually regained the pawn that was lost
earlier in the game and that hasn't
changed anything it should still be a
draw
Magnus however he's trying to win he's
trying to take some small risks and
there we go no more porn trades he's
pushed forward so the reason white gave
up upon the reason it's two versus two
now is because white has created a
passport and we said it was all about
those past pawns White's f porn now has
no rival if white gets three or four
moves it might Sprint up the board and
cause some real damage so Napoleon
actually his pawns have lower quality
they're worth less because they're
double pawns and also Ivanka mentioned
earlier these Corner pawns here it's the
H pawns they're doubled and they're easy
to stop for weight they're weak they
don't protect each other
still a draw that's a tiny tiny chances
if Napoleon actually is careless what do
you think of Napoleon's decision in
capturing that pawn
I probably wouldn't have made that
decision I wouldn't have made that
decision at all because it feels like
this one is slightly higher risk and we
say higher risk simply because white has
that possible because exactly two white
pawns are connected blacks aren't and
there's no way to trade off either of
white spawns anytime soon
maybe black can give some annoying
checks
that's I think the justification for
going for this I'm not sure exactly
where White's King is going to hide long
term okay the king steps back hitting
the black Rook no more checks for now
but uh I just don't see how white is
going to make progress if the Black
Brook retreats to attack maybe White's
Pawn on the fourth rank
and then once the Viking steps back just
go back to where it came from The Rook I
think it's going to just yo-yo between
two squares this black Rook now okay
because I'm thinking maybe the white
king would dream about being on the F5
Square yeah but black also has a
passport
I'm not 100 sure maybe uh let's show
this while the players think because
Napoleon actually there's less margin
for error than there was five moves ago
and remember Magnus is an endgame
Maestro so uh there will be some doubt
in his mind Napoleon actually okay he
does bring the Rook the whole way across
I was about to say yeah The Rook is just
gonna step back the king will March
forward and then we would see a
repetition of moves but Ivanka mentioned
maybe the king will sneak in eventually
uh even if this Pawn starts running it's
slow for black instead we did see a
different move the black Rook came this
direction you it aims to check from the
side and Magnus now trying to be greedy
he's trying to take this Pawn that he
earlier sacrificed
it's green good okay I mean the record
misplaced now so now you can give a
series of checks yeah but uh I'm not
sure whether it's actually that bad for
Magnus because
um if you could grab this Pawn uh for
example if black just Waits if you could
grab this pawn and then go back where
you came from and then re-route the
white Rook to a more active square and
then start pushing maybe you have some
chances but uh Ivanka you mentioned uh
giving him tracks yeah and I will match
up the board
and uh now ah this is a draw for example
you can bring the Rook across to attack
this Pawn I wanted to defend it but now
you could trade off finally yeah a set
of Pawns and even if white comes out a
pawn up then this is quite a
straightforward draw
one point alone will not be able to
sneak past the black king yes it's a
passport but the black king is primed
and ready to block it
yeah I'm I agree with this tweet or this
talk of a draw has got him thinking that
uh some of these someone's going to do
something mental we've seen it before we
write it off too soon commentators curse
and then suddenly something crazy
happens but remember I have to say you
know
um when uh Napoli was given the chance
he defunded incredibly precisely you
know there's some really good
calculation there
continue how to he knew when to trade
his Rook for the night he also knew when
to make that Rook move if I'm going to
highlight a certain move that I was
really impressed by it's just that Rook
move to f8
and instead of uh just on move exactly
41 yes yeah that was a really impressive
move very calm collected and well
calculated I like this tweet as well
they're still playing on because they
don't want to go to the press conference
yet oh but it's so much fun with the
press conferences come on you guys I
can't wait I really hope one of the
journalists asks about Napoleon's
routine during this game definitely yeah
because it has been a mental game
talking about mental I mean the the
mental battle the psychological Battle
of Jana bomyaraji leaving the board
could be interesting to hear from Magnus
as well yeah I don't know if it's going
to be you know honest about his feelings
about her but did it affect him
I think in public he'll say that okay
the opponent could do what he wants and
upon me actually not breaking any rules
but privately maybe in his mind he'll be
thinking oh I was a bit odd yeah I was a
bit disconcerting a bit disturbing
and uh yeah Mind Games World
Championships that's why we enjoy them
so much yeah
it's about my games always talk about
the Magnus Carlsen effect you know that
players maybe won't be playing the best
or aggressive or best moves or most
aggressive moves because they are
playing Magnus and then someone maybe
figuring out how to deal with it they'll
probably actually affected yeah yeah
just uh leaving the board putting the
psychological pressure on the opponent
and uh talking about psychological
pressure
um ROM chess fan on Twitter tells a
story that the strategy that napomniacci
employed it's actually very exciting
similar to karpov's um the match in
carpool against of course where Magnus
has to be cautionary my plan was simple
this is what cautionary says to deprive
karpov as his favorite occupation
standing at the board staring straight
at his opponent while I was wearing
these glasses all he could see was his
own reflection because he was wearing
mirrored sunglasses
all sorts of okay so we have some moves
a few checks on the board
this is a
hey Magnus going back where he came from
with the white king did I just see the
hand kind of yeah it looks like that
draw offer oh there we go draw fat and
it is a draw
game two in the world championship match
is all also a drama
I might have gotten from Dubai today but
it is eventually a draw and a big smile
on magnus's face wow what do you think
they're talking about
hoping we can hear it
sorry I think you drink one before after
95 here there's some interior
um
here's inside there was some news I
think you take on D5
neither player too happy there exhaling
I think they were just discussing the
opening even very early in the game
well championship match
I think
I mean if it was like
19593 I felt like well please
basically before
you think or maybe B takes a four
because it became like very dangerous
like you should be seven ideas
four I just couldn't calculate but
you're giving up the queen
I can't give it away on uh you see
because
for Queen H4
yeah
I have some control
[Music]
yeah but at some point you could attack
like on
strongman is he's moving forward but
maybe you know I felt like C3 is like
it's a nice way just to make sure I'm
not getting mated maybe for maybe for a
subject to this channel yeah now after
this history I mean I'm also maybe
looking into it
then rookie yeah
because after okay maybe another maybe
what can't do much but I felt like it
would be it is very good therapy
Saturday
all right
excited live from Dubai you guys these
two players discussing the game
afterwards a lot of notation David can
you understand what they were talking
about I can it was various moments
actually firstly in the opening then in
the middle game and also discussing a
bit later on just before we saw all
those simplifications at the time
control but for me the most telling part
was magnus's last comment there he said
at some point he had no idea what was
going on
and that makes us feel better here in
the studio it just shows how chaotic
that game was yeah definitely okay well
the players have played for uh four and
a half hours game two it ended with a
draw it's been such a dramatic game
we're gonna wait now four comments from
these two players it's gonna be so
interesting to hear hopefully them talk
to Tanya now waiting for them uh before
they also head to the press conference I
mean yeah David what words will you do
you use to describe this game today I
would just say it was so up and down
that uh I think neither player had
control as well the word I would use is
control neither player seized it I think
world championship matches historically
it's all about who can get control first
even if it's just one game and then the
next game you build on that control but
this one neither side black was doing
well then white was doing well then in
the end it was a bit of a bit of a
topsy-toby draw so uh yeah excitement
and lack of control all right Magnus is
Coming to Town ended peacefully but a
very danced battle did you feel the heat
while playing it yeah it was was tough
at some point I blundered when I allowed
Knight C5 because I didn't intend to
sack quite as much material as I
actually did
and um yeah I I I think a lot a lot of
things could have been done done
differently
um
I was
after that I was trying trying to hang
in there
um not not to lose
um but yeah the position was very very
interesting
um but it was
it was going going my way for for a bit
but I couldn't really find a plan and
then
um
then yeah right before the time control
I just offered him the chance to
um to liquidate
um probably in hindsight I could have
tried something something else but I
didn't really didn't really see it maybe
earlier I had something he certainly had
chances as well that was when you went
Queen G4 yeah
all right and uh Magnus 95 was the move
that even the commentators were talking
about do you see anything now that you
could have done differently
uh yeah I don't know
um
I mean probably objectively the position
was not was not that bad for me
um and like yeah he was offering me a
lot of chances to to take back some
material uh and eventually eventually I
did
generally I I have no idea
thank you Magnus all the best for
tomorrow
all right Magnus calls and he he does
have a smile on his face using the word
blunder here at some point what you take
away from that David yep it just shows
that he's not quite at his Peak yet he's
not quite his freshest sharpest I'm
still missing some small things I think
he over exaggerated slightly yes he
missed a move or underestimated a move
but it wasn't quite a blunder he was
never losing he was worse but um
it was just uh again it was that last
comment he had no idea and it was just
that kind of game and it shows both
players are happy to go into Muddy
Waters and and actually move Magnus said
he blundered was this one Black's Knight
just jumping in to offer a trade and
Magnus maybe was looking at other
options for black but he underestimated
the threat firstly of a nitrate which
favors Black Knights are the most
important piece in this type of position
but also once he did jump in with his
own night maybe he underestimated this
move and he also said he didn't intend
to sacrifice as much as he did but this
forced him to and after The Rook moved
we saw a crazy position after some
trades here of white being down a rook
for a night but having This Magnificent
piece so
objectively I think this is very good
for black computers loved black here but
Magnus found the Practical compensation
and later on saved the game all right
and uh Napo has moved on to the press
conference uh should we look at more
moments from this uh Topsy tour every
game that you guys called it yeah and I
think the final key moment he also
touched upon in that uh in the interview
with Tanya he mentioned this move
bringing the queen across to the G4
Square it looks nice and attacking maybe
he had some ambitious intentions here
he's also threatening this Pawn from
where he would give check but it did
allow the pony actually to get rid of
this Knight that we just highlighted
this fantastic piece even at the cost of
a rook it was worth it and Napoleon
actually was able to hold the draw from
this simplified position if Magnus had
maybe had a bit more time on the clock
he might have maintained the tension for
example he could have moved his Rook
there's plenty of opportunities here
maybe you can swing it across this way
uh maybe he could have moved his Queen
to a square that is still indirectly
defends the Knight and once he got to
move 40 with an extra hour on the clock
maybe he to put some pressure on white
was in control here but this one small
slip at the end meant that the game did
fizzle out so earlier magnus's blunder
maybe not ideal and then this moment
just letting Napoleon actually survive
quite simply I think those were the two
moments Magnus will look back on with a
bit of regret all right oh
what a game two you might go in the
world champion match can you believe it
I know there's plenty absolutely
thrilling and I didn't expect to have
two explosive starts in different ways I
have to say
um but I have to say I've been very
impressed by both neponiachi and Magnus
for their fighting Spirit
resourcefulness and precision when it
comes to calculation and we're excited
to also get some more reactions from
Dubai from Simon at the good night and
at the press conference with Miners and
Napoleon before that we're gonna have a
quick commercial break we'll be back in
a few minutes
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
starting October 1st
thank you
[Music]
I'm ahead of the game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's what I'm here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the chess 24 Global
broadcast from the World Chess
Championship Match where we have seen
magnusi play a draw in their second game
Magnus had the white pieces in this one
it was a dramatic chaotic game
eventually a drove after four and a half
hours the players are now making their
way to the press conference it's uh not
going to be quite yet so before that if
you want to see some more of your
selfies
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thanks for sharing the Selfies using the
hashtag c24 live everyone and now we're
gonna Head Live down to Tanya in Dubai
how are you feeling Tanya after such a
chaotic and dramatic game
I'm still feeling the nerves it was an
absolutely topsy-turvy battle we heard
it from Magnus himself lots of ups and
downs and changes in the game from the
word go starting from the opening
surprises ton of evaluation and to give
us more insights on the action we saw
today I've got with me the number one
pair from UAE Grandmaster Salem Saleh
Salam what a game yeah it was a very
interesting game I like the opening
Choice by Magnus it was surprising it
was very interesting and yeah the one
the game went it was up and down I I was
surprised at some point by Nepal's
choice to actually take the exchange
because it looked very passive
but the more I thought about it it felt
to me that actually white has to find
the very creative ideas to keep the game
going and I felt the danger for Magnus I
haven't checked of course so this is
just my impression and then I felt that
the move B takes A4 somehow felt to me
strange
I felt at this moment actually was the
moment for black to be precise and maybe
to take over after that white had a very
nice position and I also felt that
Magnus allowed this Rook text G6 too
easily and yeah I mean again this this
move Queen G4 maybe that was the moment
to somehow keep the Knight on D6 because
this is the sole of the position
and I think it would have been very
unpleasant for nepo that's my that's my
impression
Magnus said about Queen G4 as well now
both players have had one game each with
black and white as a Grandmaster what
does that tell us about their
preparation and mindset the kind of
Chess we've seen here
yeah I mean uh okay Magnus I think so
far he's uh to me it seems like he's
winning the battle he is surprising yarn
and um but what I like about John that's
actually he is when it's getting tough
and complicated he's finding the way to
to survive and yeah so I mean the
openings I think went to Magnus Weber
but I like how Jan handled that
practically
and let's see if Jan would have the
advantage one day in the opening how
would Magnus react
all right and game three tomorrow night
pieces what are we expecting
okay that's a really tough question
I don't know but uh probably I mean each
player will always have to surprise the
other so maybe maybe not E4 today
tomorrow I have no idea no idea
all right now Salim you've been the top
player in your your top level
Grandmaster what does it mean for Dubai
to host the World Championship Match oh
this is a fantastic event for me of
course to attend the world championship
match personally it's a great feeling
and of course it will promote chess and
General in UAE many people who are whom
are known chess players visiting Expo
they can feel the atmosphere maybe they
get interested in chess so no it's a
great thing for UAE and it's a very very
nice idea thank you so much Alan for
your insights thank you and there we
have it it's a great thing for Dubai and
the great fights that we've been seeing
has really set the narrative for the
rest of the match it's clear the
Challenger does not fear the reigning
world champion they're both ready to
play complex positions I can't wait for
game three back to you guys thanks Sonia
I definitely agree with you yanaji with
the white pieces again tomorrow you guys
and with the mood we've seen from him
today and his uh you know fighting
Spirit what do you expect from game
three Ivanka I'm expecting that Napoleon
will be the first one to launch a
surprise because we've actually seen
both sides try to initiate some
surprises but in both cases Magnus has
been the one who's been in familiar
territory and napoleonji has been the
one who's had to be thinking on his feet
and finding the solutions to the
problems so tomorrow I think you'll be
like I've had enough of playing magnus's
on magnus's Turf I want to switch up and
see how Magnus can defend on the back
foot yeah what do you think I think
because tomorrow is just before a rest
day I think both players are going to
throw everything at it it's going to be
another long game today was over four
hours I think tomorrow might be even
longer and uh
as if I mentioned if you end upon
actually with white can of course the
first surprise I think we might see a
completely different game so far
yesterday Yan was defending a bit here
and there today despite being material
up he was maybe on the defensive as well
but if Napoleon actually can attack
long game but also maybe quite a
promising one for him and how do you
think uh minus Carlson's sort of team is
feeling reacting to what they've seen
from nepo today are they
if not scared maybe just you know
realizing that he's going to bring some
fire yeah I think it's been a roller
coaster for both teams today emotionally
Napoleon's team would have been very
happy at some point but then they would
have been worried by the way he played
at some point he just kind of drifted uh
kind of maybe a bit complacent magnus's
team
negatives in terms of maybe just
misjudging and the blunder that he
mentioned earlier but also positives in
terms of the fact he outplayed nepo for
a five to ten move stretch today just
like he did yesterday and if he can
continue that there are positives yeah
and of course with the white pieces
tomorrow do you think uh Team Napo you
said it after his white game yesterday
probably is going to stay away from that
opening he did yesterday because
actually Magnus maybe was the one to get
in as a prize in that opening so do you
expect something different from Jan
tomorrow somehow I have a feeling that
he will want to be making some changes
just to shake things up again and also
just to see what Magnus has prepared you
have to keep prodding at different
points to find different weaknesses you
can't just keep repeating things again
and again especially in this day on age
when we have these super computers at uh
you know at your fingertips so I'm
expecting something different I don't
think he's gonna necessarily open with
his kingporn I think it might be
something else yep he's played E4
already he might play D4 tomorrow as you
mentioned Ivanka to find out information
what Magnus is prepared but also just
before a rest day to force the team of
magnets to prepare in future against E4
and D4 I think it's just a good
practical decision so that's what I
would recommend for janapon actually
switch things up try something new okay
I'm listening now because uh you know I
have Ambitions and the predictions
challenge the Magnus never prediction
challenge the fantasy game that you can
actually play during the world
championship match um I had put down a
win for Magnus in this game oh didn't go
too well there I'd put down Sicilian
Defense zero points there I'd put in 65
moves today how many moves did we end up
on not that many maybe like 50 59 oh
that's going to give me points you've
got close ah yeah yeah that's going to
give me like six points or something
like that yay all right we do also have
Simon
down at the good night and maybe now
Simon it is time to say good night then
I think so yeah it's been a great day at
chess and um it's been a great day down
here as well so uh I hope you guys had
as much fun as I have
um the chess has been exciting it's been
up and down and I think one thing we can
say immediately is that this world
championships is more exciting than the
last one after two rounds at least
there's been loads of stuff going on I
think both sides had a chance today and
we're going to see if Yan can use those
white pieces tomorrow I think it's going
to be now they're settled in I think
it's going to be potentially a decisive
result tomorrow
um but now I probably have to be a
little bit cheesy get my point
and say good night from the good night
properly so um I hope to see you down
here a bit later everyone in the studio
thank you so much and back to you guys
it's been uh it's been great fun here so
cheers for now and I'll see you soon
cheers Simon we're coming down for you
later on and now we have to go to the
press conference
also if you have questions which
we will do after I ask a couple of
questions to the players there are
microphones to the size of the room
please do not take off your mask while
you ask these questions
but and also do not touch the
microphones as well
so first question to you Magnus the game
was a very exciting game very up and
down the I think a lot of fans enjoyed
it uh at one point it seemed that she
spent a long time before sacrificing
exchange and did you feel that what made
you feel that you had to do this at this
point
yeah so I kind of missed his last move
there every night Knight C5
um
I actually thought I was was doing doing
well
um I was mainly focusing on on other
tries for instance now before and then I
get to install my knight in D6
um and I'm doing well and some other the
Moon Knight C5 had just completely uh
escaped my my attention so that was uh
pretty unpleasant surprise
um after that I thought
in in case I
I I tried
um it's not gonna jump back to D3 and I
thought my position was just very very
unpleasant so
um it was simply out of uh necessity but
I did take some solace in the fact that
um you usually need to work pretty hard
to win such positions uh as as black and
I thought I had at least
um at least a reasonable little counter
chances but yeah
when you got this opportunity you saw
you'd be getting an exchange were you
feeling optimistic about your chances
well uh uh I mean uh clearly it was
obvious that okay 90 to C5 was missed by
Magnus so I felt like wow it's suddenly
getting very very nice for black
and probably probably your pb1 was a
little bit too much so Bishop E3 it was
called four uh to you know keep the
things under control
is nearly winning because well I mean
actually it's like a couple more moves
for me just to start converting material
like ba4 and C5 uh but uh I mean I
should give huge credit to Magnus
because he just played uh in a very
interesting way so this bishop E4 was a
very uh very nice resource and uh
actually it started to look really
double-edged so perhaps C3 was
a little bit I don't know human reaction
here like to make sure I'm not going to
get to be mated and I guess after C3 uh
it was more or less equal yeah since I
have to play G6
but uh I think I also had some idea I
believe instead of ba4 Queen G7
and the 4g5 but
okay so I have been told uh you know on
my way to the press conference
uh so in general I think it was very
very puzzling game and
uh I would say that during the game I
thought like okay we both are playing
not so well
but now it's like I start thinking that
okay it was like just very interesting
and
very chaotic
Magnus he he seemed to be playing
incredibly quickly which is basically
coming to the board and making moves and
getting up did that on nerve you at all
at any point
well I just reckoned he was uh he was
thinking in in the in the restroom
instead so
[Music]
um
yeah it was uh
was obviously unusual but I I don't
think
yeah anything
pretty sure about it so yeah
so far in both games Magnus has
sacrificed the pawn for the initiative
you feel this is a strategy that he
plans to employ throughout the match
well uh I guess uh the initiative in the
first game was quite questionable
I mean it was just uh another sort of
Pawn sacrifice but in the second game it
was Catalan so I mean it says it all so
Catalan is always very sharp if you go
for these positions uh so you just give
away the pawn but you get this super
Superior Pawn Center
and uh
well but
uh I actually don't know what to add
Magnus you felt you were in trouble at
some point did you feel you had winning
chances at any point
yeah uh
I didn't feel that I had any great
chances but per se I did feel that my
position was uh was improving quite a
bit uh but
when as yeah when I went for for this
queen G4
um my time was ticking down a bit
um and
um I couldn't really see a way to
um to comfortably improve my position
and that's why I decided to basically uh
force force a draw there which
yeah it was probably the best position I
I had in the game I just
I didn't really didn't really see um
didn't really see the way uh and
obviously after after what had
transpired earlier in the game
um
having a completely safe session was was
nice
um but yeah
um
obviously if this had been been a
must-win game that I might have treated
it's a bit differently
John you had the the black pieces there
was pressure in the beginning you you
resolved it you had some chances uh
do you feel
comfortable with the way the game went
in the end
no a game was uh was really crazy so I
just I had no idea what's going on you
know so it was obviously in the
beginning quite depressing and
um you know the structure F6 is 66 with
Queen on D7 uh looks maybe I mean it
works for black but it looks really ugly
uh so I still you know have very mixed
feelings about the game I think okay we
both had some some winning chances uh
but uh yeah it's just quite nice that uh
at some point I managed to take the
initiative but I believe yeah in the end
so I I I you know this actually this
night uh surely compensates The Rook but
um for an exchange rate also has a pawn
so I think it's root takes uh the six
was more or less called for
and uh then I thought like all right
maybe Queen takes F2 and then uh losing
a brilliant way but yeah instead I
decided to go for uh
genre can give
Badness you've played two games so far
against Yan what kind of opponent is he
proving to be in such a short spin if
you can if you can estimate yeah it's
very hard to say so far
um because the games
they haven't been
well they've been in lack of a better
word it's they've been a bit atypical uh
for for both of us so I think we'll see
yeah on two games in World Championship
nerves gone uh just just down the
playing now
no no even before these two games it was
like
uh I think the nerves gone uh once you
know the first move has been played so I
guess uh yeah just enjoy playing chess
all right journalists the floor is to
you if you may go to the microphones on
the sides ask the questions there are
two microphones
feel free to choose either one and
please uh direct your question at a
specific player please even if for both
you can say which one you want to answer
first
okay well it's for both but let's have
magnets answer first please and I'm
going from the test24 global broadcast
and I was wondering about
there's all this secrecy you know we're
not allowed to know who your seconds are
and it's very very secret what your
thoughts and kiss
are and then after the game it seems
that you just hang out and talk about
Chess for like seven minutes and
tell each other what you think about the
game so how does that work
I mean it's interesting to talk Jess
with somebody who understands the game
very well
um and I think it's it's a way of
unwinding for for both of us and I mean
especially after a game like today with
so much so much content I think it makes
sense
yeah
actually I was really possible with the
game but now I'm even even more positive
with your question to be honest
okay thank you
yeah I'm Anders from Danish chess
magazine a question to both players
maybe we start with a young
how do you manage to relax and sleep
after such a game
to go for a run do you
what's TV what do I do
well basically after such games once you
hit your bet it's uh it's enough
it's enough to follow Stevia it's like
really
uh
very tough and you know
uh you know the world championship match
level is
always takes it all but can you stop
your thoughts from Raising
nothing
good well you you always think about the
nature until it's it's on here so
I mean of course uh I'm gonna and you
know go for a walk or listen to some
music but
I mean I really doubt it would prevent
you from thinking about what's going on
right and Magnus
um yeah uh I think you've yeah you
focused on the
on on the next on the next game and uh I
think in in this particular
in this particular case
um
I think we both had chances or at least
a little bit uh and um and the result
was decent enough for for both of us so
yeah you move on prepare for for the
next yes thank you
myclimate chess.com this question is for
the champion Magnus Carlson uh just a
moment ago you said that the games have
been atypical I'm hoping I could expand
upon that are you talking about
stylistically atypical or are you not
pleased with the quality of play or some
other usage of atypical
no I would just say that the games are
not following any specific
pattern and their
frankly been
um different from from what I've what
I've seen before and I don't think
there's there's like yeah there's not a
clear pattern of
um of what anybody's trying to do it's
just it's just a fight but
uh we'll we'll see uh we'll see
eventually if
um the match will settle down a bit
um
question for Carlson
um as far as I understand from feed that
this match will continue without any
change of colors Midway
uh is that the comfortable for you
um yeah I think that's um that's
reasonable you can you can do it one way
or
or
um
or the other
um
as as I talked about earlier
I don't think it's very much affects the
outcome
um but yeah this means that I I get
white and um possible final games which
is nice I guess
uh hi I'm uh Theo waits for Leeches I
have a question for both of you but
perhaps you can start with Yan
um I just wanted to ask what you both
think about the time control being used
in the match particularly increments
only starting from move 61 uh not from
move one is it convenience and health
Pace out the game
um you know are you both happy to play
whatever the time control is
well actually so far we didn't
experience any any increment yeah
because uh games for perhaps too short
but on a serious note
I
find it particularly weird that it was a
different time control in different
parts of the cycle so for example in the
candidates it was like uh
as far as I remember 100 minutes and
uh increment was on and here okay they
I don't know if you decided to change
time control so I've
think I think it should be the same
but a part of it yeah of course uh I
can't really remember
then then exactly did I play with this
control for the last time yeah so
perhaps it was like about 20 years ago
or something
thank you and Marcus
yeah I very much welcome welcome the
change
um that's that's been made here I think
it's
um generally better more exciting to uh
to not to have increment before the
first time control it places more of an
emphasis on
on on time management and I think that's
appropriate
perfect thank you
[Music]
from chess base India
my question to uh Yan is that were you
surprised with magnus's Catalan and
Knight E5 in the opening and two
magnuses were you surprised with B5 that
was played by Yan
well 95 uh
uh
all right they're going into some deep
analysis that we have already heard from
the players going through the game so
we're going to leave the press
conference right there but what do you
think about what you you heard from them
David yeah some interesting comments uh
it was good to know Magnus approves of
the time control it certainly brought a
lot of excitement so far the comment
about the match being atypical so far
that's also a good sign it shows the
players are willing to step out of their
comfort zones in order to beat each
other in order to entertain us and uh
also Yan a bit earlier saying that he
feels the nerves have been shaking off
already that's yet to be seen but the
fact that he says that he thinks that is
probably a positive sign for you yeah
atypical and we're definitely getting a
very tense and very entertaining match
so far you anchor we certainly are we've
been rewarded by the two players with
some really
Fighting Chess you know it hasn't been
perfect but it has been a real struggle
between the two of them and at times you
know we haven't known what's going on
and the players themselves have admitted
they haven't known either so that's very
refreshing to see and as David says and
the players themselves said atypical and
I certainly look forward to seeing game
three tomorrow definitely with the white
pieces for Jana pomniachi we can take a
quick look at the schedule for the chess
24 Global we start every day at one
o'clock P.M CET then Dubai time that
will be four o'clock New York time
that's seven o'clock in the morning and
then half an hour after we start the
show so we build up for half an hour for
the game that is to come and then the
game starts at 1 30 CET and you follow
us on chess24.com on the World Chess
Championship page we're also on YouTube
and this has been such a fun exciting
day of Chess from Dubai tomorrow yeah
he's shown that he is ready to fight
he's gonna have the white pieces
tomorrow thanks for watching everyone
and we hope you'll join us again
tomorrow bye
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]